[Music]
foreign
come on
[Music]
let's go
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
whatever
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
two one here we go
foreign
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
right there
thank you
[Music]
it's really pretty
cool
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome welcome welcome everyone it's
another day of POG Champs action here
pogchamps five Danny wrench alongside
Levy Rosman but uh Levy we're going to
jump right in and let the fam know that
we're not gonna be starting on time in
the way that we thought we were because
we have not heard from Felix xqc for
those who speak uh twitch handle I'm not
a huge surprise Levy this happens from
time to time
um has Frank ever stood you up for a
lesson when you guys were doing chess
no no no he hasn't
um but we've only had two or three
collabs so I feel like okay you know
it's uh it's it's still set to happen in
the future uh yeah it's a weird one
um it has obviously happened a few times
but you know I I look at xqc as like
this
Divine other being that just kind of
operates on just own
orbit yeah like he's too he's too famous
for me understand so right if I ever get
into as big of an orbit as he does I'll
probably I'll probably be late to a
couple of things so I don't know I don't
get as worked up about it as as some
other folks do but um yeah uh there will
not be a match at the we we don't know
we might click go live right now but I
don't know he could go live right now he
might not be live for seven days you
don't know you I think you called it
right you know he's um he kind of
marches to the beat of his own drum
um but as my as my mother once told me
never forget who you're dealing with so
I would say that we knew who we were
dealing with when we got involved with
xqc and that occasionally this can't
happen
um Felix is is in my opinion an
awesomely fascinating character and and
part of the thing that makes him yeah
Frank knows right like we I think Frank
knows yeah we we're in discussion with
Frank and Frank is super responsive and
and all over it I think Frank might have
actually Gone live to his YouTube though
so we'll see we'll just play the xqc bot
for an hour like I feel like if he beats
this yeah zero then um yeah yeah speak
speaking of which we are going to have
content for you and we are going to have
a show we we actually I'm gonna queue up
in in a couple different orders here
we're gonna give you you these matches
just later on in the day the same three
that were meant to follow Frank and xqc
will be will be happening daily dose of
internet will take on cutie Cinderella
after that we're gonna have squeaks and
virtual and at that point the
consolation bracket will be closed out
we will know who is in Los Angeles at
least from the consolation bracket and
then we will have I did a thing in Alex
versus Sea Dog VA we know that these two
guys both played really really high
quality chefs yesterday Levy I can't
wait for that match up at the end of
today's show so everyone needs to stick
around before we even get to the three
matches Levy we're going to give
everyone a replay a lot of people are
shooting tuning in right now for xqc so
guess what we're going to give the
people what they want we're going to
give them an awesome replay of his
double overtime Thriller versus Papa
plot from yesterday and then if we're
still not live with matches by then
we're going to give you a an interview
an edited version of the interview that
happened between Felix and Tyler uh xqc
and tyler1 uh from the day before or the
match before so we should have a lot of
great content coming up for those xqc
fans lovey
yeah and then we'll also show them
Gotham versus Rosen I am not a GM speed
Chess Championship the first match not
not this first match that that was good
not the second match which was not good
that's also there right well yeah we got
we got everything so um we're gonna
we're gonna have a lot of fun and we are
going to be back on camera in fact I'm
probably gonna be hanging out doing some
work slacking and doing whatever else
whatever else that is that I do for this
company I'll hang out with all of you
guys on Twitch chat and YouTube chat if
you want to stick around we're gonna
have uh have fun watching this xqc pop a
plot double overtime filler and then
whatever other content we get to
um I'm gonna take a coffee nap
you're gonna take a coffee nap yeah I'm
gonna finish those coffee and then I'm
gonna I'm gonna sleep 30 minutes I'll be
back that sounds amazing so Levy's gonna
be back in a half an hour
I'll be back in roughly 45 minutes I
know that those things weren't even uh
that's you in fact if you fall asleep
and you don't wake up
it's gonna be okay because we will all
know that you're getting your needed
rest and I will just carry solo without
you so you do you
we may or may not see Levy in about 30
to 45 minutes I will be here everyone
um and I'm gonna be hanging out on chat
so and uh enjoy enjoy this replay and
we'll see you in uh in about 45 minutes
all the way
[Music]
s
oh
that's super dangerous one pork attack
Trident he's going the wrong way this
would be the ultimate podcast game this
is the guy who was the meme of pogchamps
one right this is the guy that lost in
six moves to Charlie we all remember it
because it's been seen millions of times
and now he is one of the better players
and that's a pretty cool thing and just
in regards to the whole POG Champs
tournament Arc right scripted
yeah uh but by the way that we do in
fact have game time uh we have a
a
we have a hedgehof defense xqc is
playing uh White mm-hmm
yep we can already we already know they
made some moves because we've got the uh
the stream delay fair play for those who
ever wonder why the look-in is a little
behind that is by Design don't yell at
us because for fair play reasons
um we already know that this is on the
board and it's a symmetrical Petrov
Danny my my eval bar shows percent win
percent draw percent law is that a new
thing yeah it's a new thing as long as
so so it's a feature that as long as we
are in the opening book rather than
showing the eval because what's the
point in showing the computer's opinion
about a position that's been played five
thousand times
um we show the percentages of the game
and then the moment we go out of book
um we we change to a traditional email
like like we have there
oh yeah it was showing me the pers oh my
good that is a little sexy you like what
do you think yeah yeah Eric will be
happy now now it's now it's just showing
an equal position and the the players
are in a queenless position oh is xqc
gonna take in blunder on B2 uh oh uh oh
you called it he did take
he did take
but will he see B2
we're already in a big moment that's it
I think my Pawn's out okay at least he
sees it he played ponza C3 oh okay that
is not a big fan of this is not
development though I'm gonna get my
Knights out of this right okay yeah I
got I got this as well
yeah
um down the line but hey we gotta move
we gotta move chat we gotta move
good plan
oh my horse are stuck at home
uh what for free he sees it
for free
paper
for free Levy
I don't know if you want to instant
replay that show what pop uplaw did with
Bishop H4 that was a bad idea going
after the pawn he he had an accuracy of
98 before he did that like he was just
playing like Magnus Carlson and then he
just went
here
double question word that's why he's 2
000 at puzzles Danny because for free
and he's not wrong he is not wrong that
is oh my goodness
there you go
pop a plot off track with that bishop
move as Levy showed and there you see
our explanation in case you ever wonder
what those symbols mean double question
mark is blunder I think that's pretty
intuitive I think people see double
question mark and that doesn't look good
red means bad the one thing he was
yelling at himself about Levy which is
one area he's improved has been time
he's like Chad we got a move we gotta
move overall like he's just very aware
of the clock and now he's down a minute
but again I know he's been in an easy
bracket but I have been super impressed
with his play and and here he's getting
free rewards from Papa plot with that
Bishop you're supposed to go here and
then trade the Rooks but we'll see if
we'll see if
it's not over yeah that's what I was
saying this is a Pog Champion game and
what I mean by that is this is not
outside of the world where where where X
UC blunders this away because the open
file Levy we can talk about that in a
game like this where yes you're up a
night but Knights are some of the
hardest pieces for amateurs to
coordinate he owns the only open file if
he plays rookie two or rookie three here
I forget what the eval Bar says I think
this is actually way closer than it
looks okay he's not playing yet
unfortunately he's helping him he's
helping yeah rookie two is a is a very
high level conceptual move just
understanding that you should be very
active with your Rooks uh yeah and Felix
will probably play Knight F3 like okay
goes forward that also makes sense
of excuse me sideways
Rock contest
wow then take take
move
that's pretty good
wow I can't believe he saw that is
pretty good
Levy he's been watching it was really
good I thought about on the flight that
only been a brilliant move for the
agenda
[Music]
mud and brilliant
oh but that's a great move too B6
pushing him back
no
oh wait a minute honestly if you take
back Bishop H4 it's coming it's good
wait honey why not Knight A6 Rook C8
Fork oh he sees it this way too
it's over I win
one two
it's over right one fork attack trident
back to back
thing
this game is over
his pawns are sideways beaked that's so
bad that's so bad that's like chat
this is a rookie mistake
it's not even more information that is
bad bad doesn't he have that too to the
center yuck
yeah
although F6 is a good move by Papa plot
yeah it was a great move
does he remember the Rook contest that's
a good move
sideways beaked
I look I haven't heard the Trident maybe
he said Trident Vista he said tried and
I've never heard of sideways beaked
that's I can't the things that these
streamers say is like Sensational I I if
spawns are weird very weird Pawns
they're pretty weird they're pretty
weird
he sees the fork
see if Kevin blunders this or keeps the
game going oh he did look at that good
move oh tonight tonight
does he see the Knight is hanging
oh wow
good game if he plays King D2
freaking development
sometimes I think he's just a joke he's
not thinking that like at all
it's not about not thinking he just
doesn't have much he can move he just
take take
huh huh
oh back to the fork oh he's he's crazy
one
yeah bro
killing you three four this guy is not
the uh not the xqc we've seen in many
other product Champs do I go fancy nah
no fanciness he's on the black pieces
too so it doesn't matter
what's snacking on these sideways
talking
about Metal game is very good you think
oh well you could just take in this nah
I'm good brother
yeah
[Music]
so fast
dude he's he's on another level like
honestly like this is
Planet X let's let's hope we get a
stalemate just not just because I'm I'm
looking for some content I will back
protect my pieces
that's right
that's crazy walk
eat the pawn eat the pawn to guard the
horse
okay that's fine too what will he do
Gigi paper plate is what it is man it is
what it is paper plate
calling paper plates I
all calculated okay
that is Sensational I need to be seven
in the pawns get got an escort and it
can't go back can't go top can go
sideways he's gotta go yeah first of all
that's pretty good I haven't heard an
English accent from you of all the ones
you bust out regularly that's not that's
not on the top of your list no no that's
kind of a sleeper one I I don't do a
great one I just kind of if I whisper it
it sounds good I mean yeah the scariest
moment for any chess player find the
stalemate for black for white
am I doing I'm not even paying attention
there's no way what am I doing there it
is he's gonna he's gonna get it done oh
oh
yes keep checking oh he's got it King G7
Queen H6 mate
sniper yeah boom wow wow
now
the accuracy one won't be very good
at the accuracy will not be very good no
problem I think I think it will be 90
so happy with himself and he should be
he gets another dumb Levy again I know I
know the strongest players in the field
have not played xuc yet they are your
sapnaps your Sea Dogs maybe one from
already went home and ghastly but the
dude is playing well he's I mean it's
it's how it's how he's finishing these
games too Levy I oh we have a game
speaking of something excuse yeah we got
a game we have liftoff pop a plot with
white I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that
we've been overestimating Felix's path
to the next round let's see what let's
see what Kevin can do with the white
pieces I think he's I think he's gonna
because again Levy you take back Bishop
H4
and papa plop played great last time
honestly yep yeah he it was just one of
those mistakes where there was
absolutely nothing you could do after it
uh yeah I don't know it was like
injuring yourself in a sport that was it
he had no chance after that let's
obvious that's a very not good move
because you weakened your light squares
forevermore but that's what happens when
they face the Italian they get nervous
about Knight G5
yeah I mean my goodness
um
F6 is definitely not a move but now
they're in a brand new territory yeah
they're in uh
they're in whatever this is they're in
the uh the the langel variation of the
of the Italian opening
whatever it is yeah the the chess.com
opening book
night's getting in trouble
oh he sees it oh I'm gonna die him but
yeah
um set it up set it up cover the Escape
score with the Knight or the queen and
then before X will never see it coming
yeah
agreed down yeah
look at that oh
Oh that's oh that's a cheeky little move
he's not gonna see it he's gonna there's
no way the only move now for black is
Pawn to B6 no way
you'll see it I agree
you even no Queen A4 doesn't work yeah
because C6 and the queen guards it but
he didn't see it suck oh huge
this is it oh it's already on the board
he played B4 oh Levy amazing we could
have we could have tiebreakers here pop
a plot with the white pieces that's
amazing wow yeah from the top rope and I
mean he he you know why he got all of
that he got all of that because he took
on G8 I have no evidence of that
whatsoever but the Knight is just
stopped yeah
well again this has been a bad game for
for X from the start for those who
aren't uh who uh calling it like they
see it F6 was a bad move and papa plot
is in control
yep he takes the Knight and now now he
has the same situation that xqc had but
the difference in my opinion is that
White's Knight Advantage here isn't as
easy to convert because the position is
so asymmetrical last game it was
completely symmetrical this game xqc
could go here he could do something on
the B file he could
I don't know but it's not as easy okay
that I'm not crazy about that move
though because that's making it more
symmetrical
uh those are Papa platters goons man
they're he's got he's taking on the
whole uh the whole Squad rookie shape by
the way on the board I predicted this I
I thought there could be some problems
here you know you got to go back
and you gotta go back what a twist
ending that would be by the way if Papa
plot takes this to Blitz Blitz Anything
Can Happen man these are these are not
professional chess players right this
isn't Hikaru Nakamura forcing things
into a blitz tiebreaker where he knows
he beats everyone
Levy this could be the end of a of a
really a really shocking POG Champs uh
campaign for xqc I love how we just went
from who is xuc playing in the final in
LA to pop up
D5 is
um
that's pot chips oh he has they take Z5
if okay we should probably listen to pop
a plot stream if he sees that it's over
yeah let's see that's it
let's see if Kevin finds Knight takes E5
almost okay it's not as good as 1965 but
it's almost better it shows he's using
all of his pieces sees the pin this
makes it makes it so hard to see how xqc
doesn't lose this
yeah I mean
actually I can see the reaction he's
probably dumbfounded at that he's like
what like I can't take the Knight he's
just put my Pawn to my Queen that's
ridiculous and he's threatening to take
the pawn one
and he's down on time
by the way he still doesn't if he trades
Queens xqc still has a chance remember
he only has to draw yeah like this is
not yeah that's not a good idea don't
drink don't do it no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's super dangerous
even with low time Felix has a very good
chance to draw this game now I think a
good reason to trade especially when
you're winning but in this case I would
not have done this because the attack
was more powerful than the other
Concepts you have two different concepts
clashing and one supersedes use your
knight and your queen get in here right
Daniel show how dumb that was show him
95 like show them how quickly it's over
I mean like if he finds this move right
yeah Knight E5 either this and then you
can win the The Rook if this you can win
The Rook uh oh this there's also a queen
and if this there's Queen E6 and I I
just assumed
they made somewhere here I mean you can
just
um
yeah but this now you gotta find Knight
E5 check and hope for this and then two
different forks and
this is a good oh oh Rook G4 Rook G4 in
here he's got it okay
no I feel like look at Felix he didn't
fall for that sorry go ahead no I was
gonna say oh but that's a great move
we'll pop up lots of play Rook F2
I love how you pointed out the competing
Concepts that is instructor for everyone
sometimes you want to trade when you're
winning but not when your opponent's
king is about to be checkmated so here
okay he does find him he does find it
Levy Papa plot converting converting
yeah we said it wasn't a great idea but
if he manages to get it done then he
will have the last laugh but does he
know the the winning kind of idea here
use the d-pawn as a battering ram get in
attack this or is he gonna get lost in
the weeds wow
wow does he take with the Knight because
it's a check yes he does he does now
it's still okay for black or you know
it's losing for black but not not clear
oh totally not clear 94 you gotta find
Rook D6
like is he gonna go yes he he's then
there's like back rank problems with the
king is always safe that's the good
thing the king is always safe on G2 his
nerves are showing
oh don't go
to H2 you're gonna get yourself mated I
don't even know how like he's still
feeling it's not possible but it might
happen
no he's thinking okay
that one's not right but that's all it's
like Sudoku it's all covered so just go
King H2 yeah
worked out
yeah I say we go listen to Felix soon
here get some get some English Jimmy not
that I don't love guessing what Kevin's
saying in German but yeah does does
Felix see a comeback at all there there
are ladder made comebacks there there's
uh H file made comebacks xqc is laser
focused he is laser focused right now
Danny stalemate It's Not Over
you're right it's not over oh it's mate
we're gonna change Ricochet was made in
one oh it still made one right now
suc's mated Rook h a Checkmate on the
board right now oh he's missing
his Rook oh
but dude it's not over as long as he's
alive there's a chance for stalemate Yep
this is like
freaking heart attack territory yeah
cause the Knight is covering some weird
squares too he's gotta like do this in a
way where he's gonna seal it yeah that's
it right there right there put it down
on F1 it's a ladder make just Rooks give
he's so nervous oh my God he's so
nervous
oh my God oh my God Danny I can't but
he's on it he's got it he's got a skater
he's ice skating the ice skater
he's done it
he has done it borderline pre-move he's
not going to do it he's that nervous yep
oh my goodness
is the inside of strength
excellent refusing to move let's see it
huh bro I thought I have another type
bro
oh God Our Stars
the BM from xqc oh my god oh my god
wow he's just gonna let his time run out
oh my god well oh he doesn't want his
opponent to feel the glory of checkmate
could be
wow all right ladies and gentlemen I am
highly decision
wow
Levy we have over time we have tie
Breakers that was absolutely wild yeah
uh and now it looks like we have a
for a night's thing ish they're just
playing fast they're just playing fast
both players are going to be super
nervous making the kind of Trades you
don't want to make bringing the queen
out for black but okay like you said I
mean it's not excuses for Felix because
it doesn't matter we're here in overtime
but he did have a disconnect he's got to
shake it off and focus and uh pop a plot
this is it he could send the uh the
highest viewed human on Twitch that
being Felix he can send him home
yeah the most famous chess player of all
time that's right XGC is probably the
most famous person to ever play chess
like
that's probably I don't know that's
actually a wild thing to say
because it weirdly true okay
um it could be like Messi or Ronaldo I
guess if they actually played it right
like if Messi actually played chess then
yeah it would be messy uh but we don't
know if they actually did I mean they
just took the photo and then it turned
out that it wasn't a real photo so yeah
uh Bishop D4 you got to take this you
got to take this guy you gotta take it
move your knight to safety
we got a lot of equal chests here still
nothing nothing huge for either player
pop a plot up by 20 seconds though
that's what I'm noticing
yeah
Knight takes before he is playing so
fast
I don't like that move I I don't like oh
I don't like that movie they're pinning
yourself was bad but taking the night
was even worse
agreed
okay so good unless he pushes up
yeah pushing was the better move but
this is fine it's equal
I don't want to live with the queen
take with the queen not the pawn
that's what you're cheering for push
take take yeah for a second I'm cheering
for the best move to be played by both
players on every move that's my that's
what I'm cheering for we are good wait a
minute we are good we this is solid this
is solid
does he see on passo wait what
a big moment does the French Canadian
see the own passion
okay or does he put the queen on a for
free Square botesque
shout out to Papa plot for playing so
fast by the way
do you think that's nerves or that's uh
he's just trying to assert dominance I
don't know but what matters is he's up
on the clock here I should have thought
that much I don't want to open up my
file
he's right he shouldn't have opened up
the file Somebody's gotta free a back
rank here or someone else is going to
get mated I'm like giving me anxiety
it's like watching your kids wrestling
someone's about to get hurt someone's
about to get hurt
it's crazy it's actually gonna push his
d-pawn just invest in deep on Industries
D6 there it is somebody free your back
rank please someone is about to hit
their head on the couch kids are
wrestling please for your back range I'm
freaking out as a chest Dad I'll put the
rook in front of the pawn first and then
do it
oh Danny it's gonna be like Rook d8
rookie one and then it's just gonna be a
mate it's gonna be a break made on E8
that decides POG Champs in this match
yep
time even by the way we're back to even
yep a minute five each 50.
oh that's a good move wow that is a good
one centralized the queen for white Rook
D1 or queen D5 don't go there don't go
there because there's no mate there's no
mate at the end there's Queen f8 and and
he accidentally no now it's takes takes
and he's not getting mated Danny he's
gonna he's gonna miss it and then he's
gonna block mate
oh my God possible checkmates
oh my God he's seeing the wrong way he's
singing the wrong way don't do it
don't do it
oh no okay now we got some Pantry Queens
don't trade Queens you can't trade
Queens if xqc trades Queens he might not
even make it out of the quarterfinals oh
no this is Nazis losing it's just math
just math it's six pawns versus five
they just gotta bring their kings up and
black is completely winning
don't know
it's like A4
A4 A4 is winning Pawn takes pawn and A4
and it's just a square you're outside of
the square oh God
okay and they're
I was just gonna say Danny and even if
you do take the pawn is a decoy and your
King has to go take White's pawns but do
they know all of that
I'm I'm having anxiety just watching
this Kingdom Pawn ending again what is
going on here
now Papa Plata has to clutch at Danny he
has to completely forget about his Pawn
here and he has to go King E6 King F5
which which you can do you can do he's
smart enough to go he's gonna go get
this Pawn I'm gonna go get this Pawn
yeah but
yeah ah we'll go check it out we'll go
check it out
what what no no he has to bring his King
he's got to stop using his pawns oh my
God no no no no don't play your pawn
move
oh wait he already did it we saw him he
did he did he did he did he did he has
to bring his King he has to bring his
King
oh oh no no put the pawn down
always sees it oh my God he's gonna do
it he's gonna bring his King to the base
of White's Pawn chain and he's gonna
just bring what no
[Laughter]
oh no that was the one move that draws
oh God he couldn't make up his mind now
excuse he's getting back in time to stop
White's King from infiltrating
it's almost impossible to lose it now
you just bring the king back you can't
even blunder it you could lose this with
black because you just because clearly
he's really nervous so he he might like
overextend Danny and then he'll he get
he's gonna get himself into which is a
German word and then he's gonna lose
both of his pawns oh my God
the irony of Papa plot loses by zugs
Wong over the irony by the way
Danny this is this is losable for for
everybody involved but now it's like
King E5 oh my God oh my God Danny oh my
God going the wrong way he's going the
wrong way this would be the ultimate
cause Champs game okay no okay no now
we're getting a trade xqc
dude they're both going the wrong way
they're both going they should have went
up and and yes this is still a draw oh
oh Levy if okay never mind if if it's a
trade on G3 there was a chance the papa
pluck could still win by getting the
opposition yeah King H3 oh my God
dude
this is still a draw everyone this is
still a draw but we're literally walking
backward
oh my God
oh my God that xqc's freaking out he's
like what all right let's go listen to
xqc see if he figures out that he might
have a winning chance let's do it
do not Summit stalemate Stevens
more chests around the corner XGC is
still alive in POG Champs in shocking
fashion Papa plot had this game
unbelievable wow official draw
yeah
Wild
xuc is about to find out that he
actually got lucky
look at that look at that throw look at
that black is totally winning in the
middle of that game Arc and then it goes
the other way back to a draw we are tied
at one and a half games a piece
um I'll double overtime let's let's
double overtime we already had this with
Frank and gasly this is the this is the
year of double overtime in pod Champs
apparently here we go we're back to the
Italian if xqc plays the same blunder of
F6 we are in trouble
we are in trouble if we're if we're xqc
fans F6 is a bad move he already played
it once and papa plot took him to the
cleaners
yeah oh Knight G oh I I didn't know if
if they if they knew about uh if they
knew about the fried liver but he looked
it up he looked it up maybe in the break
who knows and now he's no longer played
this bad F6 move
yeah this is definitely an improvement
uh and now castles D3 Bishop G5 is good
good beginner chess on display I would
say this is early intermediate chess for
sure by both sides I mean that end game
hold was really good
high level uh high level chess here
we knew this was going to be a good
match maybe not this good xqc's got an
itch scratching it scratching it himself
you know it's always using the festival
yeah what is X thinking about he's got
oh no that's not the right move
suck suck
that is definitely not the right whoa
Yep this is good for white now that's a
good move too I mean even if it lets
black take C3 that's a nice pin that's a
nice pin hey you it's a nice pin over
here
all right let's remind everybody real
quick we are in tie breaks we are in tie
breaks right now which means we're in
Blitz we're actually in double tie
breaks if you're just tuning in Where
Have You Been we got Blitz if we're
still tied we're gonna keep rinse and
repeating but we still have four more
matches today Levy I just want to tell
everybody because we've got a lot of
viewers the day has only just begun
after this matchup I think we go right
to do we go right to cutie Cinderella
and Jenny or who goes up first who's
next
oh saikuno I'm sorry I don't re I don't
read the names that are in front of my
face I'm the anti one burgundy but but I
like it I I like the name Sky Kuno in
fact
yeah if we interview him I'm going to
ask him if he wants to be Sky Kuno and
yeah that that is a mismatch poor
saikuno yeah
also there's a fork on E2 Levy highlight
it just so that just so the boys and
girl and every girl that's uh that's a
forking problem
oh oh oh it takes them this
oh but there's Knight D4 and that ends
the game that just ends the game because
White's king is too open
all right maybe let's let's go check out
Felix let's go see what he's talking
about if he sees Knight D4 we could be
over we could be heading home
he doesn't see it he's not he doesn't
see a levy never mind oh spoke to you
soon
um it looks like he does see it now I
think that's better
whatever
oh man what am I doing that's a move
that was down on the clock though this
isn't over 70 seconds oh my god he has
to take the pawn
no
oh no oh King H1
4's game over Queen F4 is made Queen F4
is oh my God yes there's in seconds
Levy hold me I know you can't but I'm
nervous I'm so nervous you gotta move
the king out of the corner he has 40
seconds he has to move his Queen out of
wow wow
D juicer
certified
juicer
paper plate eliminated it holy
wow wow
I don't know if Felix knows how much he
got away with one there but he was he
his back was literally against the wall
ladies and gentlemen should have gone
home in the last game
holds on and somehow is still surviving
in pogchamps five
we are back here with ecstasy and Tyler
one ecstasy just beat tyler1 2-0 we got
them here was this the most important
match of pogchamp so far
sorry was that question for me
I don't know what the question was let
me say my piece actually was 35 minutes
late after being I should have been
given at least 15 minutes of extra time
to play I would have smoked them the
first round he was panicking he's 700
rating above me and I had him shook move
for move it wasn't even close sure
second game wasn't wasn't competitive
that was my bad I still did some
trolling his garbage at chess it needs
to uninstall forever
guys
a little bit he shot up he made me
reschedule the last last week and then
he's 30 minutes now late now
right
yeah I was gonna say I said it earlier
when I was talking I was talking to the
broadcast I said it he's he was cheating
it I get it I won I Michaela's on the
room and he's she's giving him the
moves I could tell I I could
tell the way he's moving Michaela was
giving him the moves it's obvious it's
yeah
he was playing web of his rating he was
playing an average of like 900 1.1 K
average as of 200. actually cheating it
I play up to my opponent even at games
I'm not even the best at and
unfortunately you played down your
opponent he's gonna pip squeak and
squatty in real life xqc you're lucky
this is all you have is is this little
video game career I play this for fun
while I'm working actual labor jobs in
real life and I still invested you
almost
labor job we got Liberty you play League
of Legends what is he talking about
I work on pool labor
starters and repair pools actually
okay
I have a landscaping job and an office
job and I stream it and I play chess I'd
imagine probably yeah an hour late to
that too and in the real world xqc
that's not acceptable and hopefully in
the chess.com world that's not
acceptable for the quarters either but
you show up and I'll relate for that
maybe he'll face some punishment
this small person big-headed muscle head
is still molding it because I cheated
against him in twitch Rivals and I got
banned I got banned for a week for it
and I couldn't stream it and he wanted
to take revenge it he called Michaela to
cheat against me to get his revenge and
even would make it 2V1 I beat them two V
one two brains can you get the Mind any
come and tell her
yeah I have about 15 comments Number One
X UC to have to bring in IRL stuff about
that because look at you you're pale you
look like a ghost bro that can't be
healthy you weigh 75 pounds again
remember me snap in the pin I could snap
you bro personal you don't want to bring
iron all of this because I beat you and
everything in that secondly Bob accusing
me of cheating it's just a compliment
because I wasn't okay and then thirdly
about the cheating comment with you
cheating yes hello he's admitted
cheating in a previous tournament hello
yes you beat me this time well by the
way you will not go to semis you are
terrible by the way no no character
aside you are actually terrible
yeah
I will I did put terrible okay but when
your opponent is way way way it's more
than enough
your thoughts bro you struggle to get
squeaks and that dude sucks
against him
oh okay we'll squeaks is really really
really really bad you're not wrong
um I mean the guy was he was he was
wearing a wig that's enough about him he
was wearing a wig that's true
that is insane
click here from the start that's true
that's true
let me get this way we could both play a
year of Chess you wouldn't beat me I we
yeah I lifted if I lifted for a year I
would beat your PB I said it excuse me
I squat 600 pounds put the arms away you
have nothing to show him recruit
we're gonna allow him to embarrass
production like this
dude you're not serious
yes
for sure maybe not I heard that you were
getting GM pointers by that hikiru guy
for that guy's name is and he was Bond
reviewing me and then linking it to you
probably true actually and even playing
this is your like second POG Champs
right or your third I don't know how
many of these have there been I don't
keep track this is my first one
um yeah um yeah Iceland dude I've
already actually I was watching
um she gave up on you entirely
he he actually retired yeah he watched
it again but he actually retired he
hasn't streamed in a long time
and then see why she
playset my potential while playing and
he was like oh I'll never match this guy
and he retired I made him quit chess
congrats I'm a freak
well you know it's lovely to see you
guys really passionate about the game
and Pog Champs and you know Tyler
there's plenty of Grandmasters who could
coach this was a really lovely
professional interview which um
for a second give me an honest opinion I
played impressive chess compared to
before you did
um
by the way
no I I yep we were gonna say at the end
of the day no matter what's going on
with who can Flex harder who has bigger
muscles let's not forget that the people
United for chess today and Tyler you
played a great game the truth is you're
200 rated and excuse me
you played much above your level and
today you Rose to the ranks and we are
very excited because both of you guys
are gonna be making it to the
championship bracket which means you may
battle again and now there's gonna be
even more more insane chess competition
um so we'll really we really love how
much you guys love chess and you know
how competitive you are and Tyler it was
nice to see you do some studying it was
good to see the cow today we're happy to
help with chess lessons Hikaru has
retired so um you know you'll have to
settle first Grand Master
big Tonka 200 I'll see you on the next
game brother
he's not 200.
it was a glitch in the system you'll get
you'll get the rating tighter
um who are you guys most excited to play
in the championship bracket
both of you yeah
no
we both don't talk to the bracket all
right how they work yeah you guys you're
yeah you both made it this game was just
for pride and stuff you're in the same
thing okay I don't think Genie has ever
seen a chessboard before and squeaks was
busy playing Connect Four in the middle
of the game how is it fair that he gets
a free passes to the bracket
he's 200 and he played very well so I
think it's very well dessert
um I don't know anybody on this list
unfortunately so I don't know well looks
like you guys are each other's greatest
enemies you don't know sapnap he plays
Minecraft blood is called the German xqc
and Frank was awesome but he's not
really well known outside of the chess
Community
I played I know snap that but played
league with them once
you guys are kind of you know it's an
identity crisis if you guys play each
other
you can be a golden egg okay but I'm the
Golden Goose okay there's multiple
versions of excuses okay from all the
other languages it doesn't matter I am
better how many copies of Taiwan is
there none nobody because
other one erupt is pretty close
okay we're we're related by blood only
relax
yeah
okay final question do you think that
you will face each other in the live
finals in LA
if he makes it to the finals so so uh
you guys be in the same room to be
honest I'm flying from Sweden challenge
to see that I've promised that I will do
it
I'm not scared I'm not sketchy one okay
I I would do chess boxing against them
even though even though
a five second round and I'm not even
talking about the boxing portion you'd
lose it five six on the chest portion
his wing span is like two foot it's like
a toddler you're actually just mad I'm
six foot five measured on stream don't
listen to this guys I watched my heart
605 605 605.
my my sister weighs more than you
actually see and she's nine
okay but that doesn't change it's like
you have a T-Rex Builder
T-Rex Andy so how does it work guys guys
he's flexing for the camera we all know
this it's fine do we have to win the
whole thing on each side of uh uh how
many people go to La exactly only the
two finalists so you guys would both
have to be top in your group
yeah and the consolation finalists so
four people in total
I hope he makes it I actually hope he
makes it uh you know I didn't really
want to go back to LA because I just
left Ellie I escaped Ellie and I have to
go back now for your tournament
it is what it is
I'm just kidding I I'll win the whole
tournament
okay
it's the same as online chess if you
thought you had it hard I will you
up in real life
xqc now you're talking crazy now
watch watch yourself watch it I'll see
Atlanta
well this is I think the matchup that we
all need to see to settle this once and
for all Tyler if you want to get coached
to Prodigy they will do it same for ux
but we know you would like to do your
own type of studying but Tyler I want to
see you guys go face to face I think
this is the chat match that chat wants
to see most
by the way
yeah
I I messed it up but you were shook
yo
what what do you mean they start for 35
minutes for you did you reschedule your
match a week in advance we are still
looking for it
it doesn't count I took a small
impromptu nap okay I was dreaming about
you
can't wait to see you Tyler
okay yeah actually why you keep saying
that okay can we move on now he's being
weird
yep all right ladies and gentlemen thank
you guys for joining us this was a
really lovely interview we're looking
forward to more chess and
um let's let's go to the standings
yeah thank you so much let's check out
that's a pleasure guys thanks so much
[Music]
foreign
everybody
[Music]
hello everyone this is your daily dose
of Internet
God oh buddy he's not interested in
still mate we gotta give that credit oh
we do we do we do that's a stone wall
baby
hey 90 accuracy let's goal
wow we are in semi-finals if I win that
I have to get a plane to LA and play it
over the board final just even more
scary
welcome back everyone it is POG Champs
five we continue on this day if you're
just tuning in and saying it seems like
you're just starting uh we we've had
some awesome highlights of xqc over the
last couple days for you that's Libby
Rosman right there I'm Danny wrench and
we're gonna dive in here to a couple of
matches in the consolation bracket Levy
are you ready to start off and find out
who's going to LA from the consolation
side I'm super ready today's the last
day that we have to play chess remotely
and we're gonna figure out which two
from consolation and which two from
Championship are uh are headed to La so
I'm super pumped and and uh Levy's gonna
be in La I'm going to be in La it's
going to be a ton of fun we we need to
let the players know as you pointed out
Levy that they're going to be playing on
real boards that's IRL chess and uh it's
complicated so we'll make sure we do
that but let's bring up the consolation
bracket remind everybody of the four
players that are left standing and
quickly how they got here cutie beat
Jenny yesterday now she'll be facing
daily dose and virtual beat saikuno uh
of those two players who are you most
impressed by or least impressed by Levy
as they made their way to the
semi-finals
most impressed with the fact that
virtual lied to me on camera in the
interview that she didn't throw his way
out of the championship bracket uh
joking aside and I don't want to start
any false rumors uh neither one of them
has done anything particularly
impressive virtual beat somebody within
a nearly 1 000 Point rating favorite if
not more and cutie took care of business
if anything Jenny was impressive in that
second game really was impressive right
so so was saikuno so was saikuno he was
winning his black against virtual he was
he was listen the people that lost were
more impressive than the people that got
the job done it was just one of those
moments today we're gonna see uh but
Danny virtual has a higher rating than
like some of these people combined not
actually but it's true
you know what you pointed out that we we
had some odd disparities in terms of
some of the matchups you have guys like
virtual sapnap Sea Dog you had the you
know ghastly you had some of the
strongest players it worked out how it
did long story short we are here now uh
there you see the times for the matchups
that we're gonna have daily dose first
taken on cutie and then squeaks taken on
Virtual I'll say I was impressed by
Cutie's sunglass choice I will
sunglasses those you know the sunglasses
were stylish there is that
um and then we have later on I did a
thing Alex will be taking on his friend
Sea Dog VA that is Connor I'm in a
battle of who has the sexiest accent the
chess is irrelevant the chess is
irrelevant in that match-up Levy
I I I think we should stick to the chest
we shouldn't uh we shouldn't objectify
the the streamers you know but I I will
admit it's uh it's Aussie it's uh it's
uh it's the UK and it's gonna be a fun
one and it's probably two of the best
players in the event like uh Alex I did
a thing he has shown that 900 950
whatever his rating is and he's finding
tactics the 12 and 1300s struggle to
find and Sea Dog is to see is Sea Dog
right like he he uh he's gonna put in
the work too so yep all right well
before we get to those matchups and of
course preview what we think we're gonna
see let's do a quick uh we're gonna take
a quick look back at how some of the
players got here we've got daily dose by
the way look at that that was stylish
that was stylish like he was a chess
robot sent back in time to change the
fate of his pogchamps bracket there's uh
there's cutie Cutie celebrating
um but yeah these are the two that are
going to be going going down uh and uh
yeah I don't know who has more dramatic
more flares for the dramatic Levy
between the two daily dosing cutie
let's say it's probably cutie I feel
like daily dose uh is it it's like it
he's going a little Colby Covington you
know it's one of those things where he's
playing the heel on the camera but I
think he's a super nice guy and uh this
is a good matchup for him I really I
think it is I I was gonna say I think he
outperforms the 635 ELO and uh and
Cutie's like a solid 800 player so Danny
I think it's a very close match I I
agree I think this is a total coin flip
we saw there from the uh the player
matchup card that this right now is the
furthest cutie has ever gotten in
pogchamps she's tied her performance
from pod Champs too long ago back in
September 2020 for those who've been
around since then so can cutie
Cinderella make it farther than she ever
has in a Pog Champs um and then be
playing in her hometown we're gonna find
out
um and I agree this is this is a coin
flip I'm curious what Chad thinks maybe
at some point we'll do a poll because I
legitimately think this is could go
either way even if I think cutie is the
slightly more experienced player may be
stronger at her best she tends to be
more inconsistent than almost anybody we
have in POG Champs you know from
stalemates found heard around the world
to other things so who knows yeah for
Real uh those those listen those
stalemates were good content but I'm
just going to say as the as the chess
instructor uh a bit a bit broke my heart
to see those but uh you know uh it is
what it is and I She's Gotta dust that
off and she said she's got some secret
prep ready for daily dose
and she said she's gonna have a way to
fight against this Gambit uh not his
Gambit rather his his bird opening so
we're gonna we're about to find out and
this is actually one of the first times
that both streamers cutie and daily dose
uh I don't I don't think he's streaming
but we're gonna show his camera in a
moment that they're it's just their
camera Danny like they're always doing
something they're always reacting to
something they're always
they're playing only up or one of these
games you know and it's just them both
full screen
and and I appreciate that I was gonna
say is cutie gonna stay that way though
because she might
she might switch to uh
to chess once it's going I'm pulling up
her stream here sorry on the side
um you know you never know she started
full she started full stream her stream
title is she showered for this so she's
taking it seriously uh she's saying she
got up and she's getting going
and uh we're gonna ask daily dose when's
the last time he showered or if yeah
he's got he's got a hoodie on he was
trying to show the the chat his mug
there I don't know whatever the mug is
he was drinking out of maybe it was
something special don't know but uh
I was just gonna add that cutie has made
a fatal mistake because all chess
players play better when they don't
shower
um that is fair that is fair I shower
every day at chess tournaments which is
why my title still has an eye in it so
right the amount of stories I could tell
you about looking across to uh to a
grand master who was so maybe greasy
that he had a fly landing on his
forehead and he didn't even notice while
I was getting beat by that Grand Master
on the board would baby shock you but
now we're getting weird let's go let's
go back to pog Champs what's at stake
and away from the rabbit hole of uh
playing in uh and and chess clubs in the
middle of mosqueva uh from my childhood
all right we've got uh Stakes that are
higher than they've ever been Levy not
because the cash is necessarily higher
than prize funds we've done but the
winner goes to LA in a live finals and I
know that may not sound exciting to you
I know you're not the biggest fan of Los
Angeles can I say that on Earth that
you're not a big La guy I guess I just
did what um I'm a big La guy I just make
fun of the traffic okay exactly the
traffic that's what I was gonna say last
time we were there I think you didn't
stop complaining about the traffic the
entire time we were there yeah it was
awful uh I feel like car culture ruins
Society but if you ask me where I could
live full time
it's I I Danny I I it's close man it's
my whole family's here but if they were
all over there I wouldn't mind if it's
sunny all right so I guess I'm
misinterpreting your La hatred just for
trafficking which I agree with you
traffic deserves to be hated on but okay
Levy doesn't like traffic news flash but
there's a lot at stake and if you go to
La you're competing in a live POG Champs
IRL final me not you love it you can't
no you you can't play
um
yeah
all right well um I'm ready I don't know
if you guys have noticed I've had enough
caffeine to uh to jump to jump over this
desk uh waiting for this to start Levy
had us has had enough naps to um and
enough caffeine yeah you know you
probably made the right call so my wife
told me that the worst nap to take is a
half an hour nap apparently 15 minutes
is fine like longer than that is is okay
but you don't want to take a half hour
nap it's bad for your REM cycle this is
my wife says this I I never know I've
tried it all like sometimes I wake up
and I feel like I got hit by a truck by
the way we do have chess uh we do have
chess and I think we're just waiting for
for Cutie to do the screen crop or
something she has a pen why does she
have a pen I don't know if she's taking
notes she's trying to remember what
Gotham she has taught her before is she
notating like is she writing the moves
of the game now first of all that would
be prep for the LA finals are we gonna
make the players write their moves down
I think the answer was no because it's
rapid chess
um but I think I think we should do a CF
rated why not get everyone USCF ratings
I'll cover the membership fees why not
yeah you know it's funny although some
of the players don't have their real
names known publicly so we'd have to
register them under their I don't know
how that would work so never mind
um
yeah
well David Jones has moved and I don't
think cutie knows that the game has
started
uh Danny um just sign her up for us
Chess Federation first name cutie last
name Cinderella you think any of those
geezers are gonna be able is your real
name or not I think that's what I'll do
I will literally do that looks like she
did figure out her crop and the game is
on and uh here we go
um oh Danny you know why she's Disturbed
because he played D4 he doesn't play D4
she probably prepared the same Gambit
that I showed sapnap and I was like hey
sapnap you should try this Gambit maybe
it'll work and he was like you sure and
I was like I don't know but it's worth a
shot anyone anyone in six moves but
Danny now she's playing the same Gambit
because normally daily dose plays the
bird but uh that only now she's playing
an England game but does she know she's
playing an England game I don't think
she does I don't think she does you
should show white no but Levy go back to
the bird we gotta show this because the
Trap is it's the same she's doing the
thing oh my God yeah the Trap is you
open the dark squares and in this case
it's potentially lethal as we saw daily
dose lose check okay Levy is
highlighting exactly what you need to
see sign up for Gotham chess videos
um but this is exactly how you can lose
chess games quickly when you play it
opening as risky as the bird but
sacrificing a pawn in the center when
it's not the weak and dark squares is
probably not the best way for black to
play so we'll see
yeah and he's he's he's doing this very
intelligently he's immediately blocking
the bishop uh and he's trying to go
Bishop here and you know she can still
get a lot of oh my God I hate that this
is the way that he plays chess but he
gets done somehow Danny Danny Danny I
Danny you know how much accuracy he lost
with this move 24 of accuracy
literally it went from 92 to 68 I saw it
in real time crazy
and the reason it's so bad is because
black can just immediately start
hammering down the center like but
because you know players are are new
like look at what she's doing she's just
but this is she's the wrong approach you
can't break a pawn wall with a queen
I mean you could try
yeah like he could go H3 and he's losing
you know like uh no obviously I'm with
you
um and if black could somehow Drive the
age Pawn maybe that works out but
overall I'm with you I I this is
fascinating
oh my God
you you crystal ball gazing you know
commentating you know what and you you
just jinxed him you just did the
commentator's curse
listen I love daily dose like I love his
videos uh and uh and he's also like a
super nice guy you know if I was more in
La I'd consider him a friend but my God
if I have to hold him by that hoodie and
scream at him to slow the F down I mean
it Danny it's the same square where he
made a fatal mistake again set that he
played H3 boom it's the same thing he
played H3 hung the G3 Pawn this time oh
my goodness
I'm with you on every level
let's see what Cutie's saying uh on her
stream over there she is she is live to
her fans and uh that's fine does she
realize
[Music]
I think
today
I want to move but I'll keep this pinned
okay that's pretty good
mm-hmm
crazy but I didn't feel like it but
here's a free Pawn right here
so we're just gonna yoink
I'm just gonna slowly slowly slowly
cut away that's my goal today
slowly cut away
now the computer hates that move she
can't see the eval bar but it's plus
four right now because there's a trick
no yeah but is this queen here good for
her he didn't see it either
I might take but then I put
spoilers so he might take
we're seeing her board not the analysis
party I actually think she's calculating
you can show it on the analysis board if
you want but I do agree with you I think
what you were gonna say is it's a decent
idea by her even if it was a blunder
because I don't think either player was
gonna find that
yeah she just took the pawn uh and in
this position actually just looking at
checks capture's attacks uh you have
things like an attack here on the queen
and then you have to realize that the
bishop can take the pawn on B7 uh and
the Queen no longer is able to pin it
that's very tough in fact that is the
best move again in this position it's to
play Knight to H4 uh it's like the best
move in every position because it
attacks the queen and you can go here
but Danny she's in great shape and uh I
think she's gonna try to Castle
queenside and
and what you're showing is why when we
were I mean I was literally talking to
my seven-year-old daughter about this
yesterday she was 200 chess kid tactics
and I said when you're solving puzzles
checks captures and then Queen attacks I
think when kids are young you don't say
Tempo moves because Tempo moves
eventually is what you learn which means
you attack a more valuable piece with a
less valuable piece gaining a Tempo but
I think at the beginning you teach kids
checks captures Queen attacks and then
you look at Knight H4 because Knight H4
is your saying Levy would have been a
queen attack that led to really good
things so checks captures Queen attacks
Pro tip and by the way love uh Judy's
killing he's doing great oh I looked
away for a second oh my goodness let me
just instant replay that it was a attack
on the queen he walked the queen into an
attack and she is cooking she's cooking
she's up in exchange and the
compensation as our buddy yes or Sarah
one might say black is up material and
the queen is great this position is bad
for white it's all good
yeah this looks all good in the hood
this looks tough for her oh my goodness
uh for him not for her not for her uh
well there's enough pieces on the board
to lose a queen in one move but
she should just keep it safe
oh
yeah uh I'm trying to think of how this
goes wrong for Cutie right besides
stalemate that's a that's a long story
down the road but um
yep I think I think the simplest plan
bring pieces to the center is probably
good you've got Rooks on the open files
but there's there's still enough here to
go wrong because as long as as long as
daily dose can get his pieces active
maybe get the King on H1 unpin the
bishop there's still potential tactics
here
yeah I mean literally no chance in a
million years he plays King H1 ever uh
but uh but I do like this plan you know
I like the fact that he understands that
okay I'm I'm down a bit but there's a
king over there we saw sapnap yesterday
come back from a whole Rook down and
it's not it's not outlandish Rook here
Queen here black could lose like see F6
look how much you value uh how much
Advantage has gone with the move F6 and
yeah Danny it's just a matter of time
she's gonna like that that's it and she
she's winning I mean he was winning
Queen A6 check well also it comes back
to the queen attack it's still available
if Knight H4 is spotted checks captures
Queen attacks and white is instantly in
business on this long diagonal yeah I
mean she she just drastically weakened
her position now he rushed uh he he just
plays too fast I mean he just plays but
anyways we got to analyze just show real
quick and then we'll go back to cutie if
we back up a move Queen A6 check the
king moves and then Knight D4 I assume
it just lights out yup yeah yep the
queen and the bishop and it doesn't
matter that you're pinned the bishop is
still defending so Knight takes you
don't take back you just win
and uh
that was that was it I mean that could
have been the match right there she
plays the best move but now he blocked
his own Queen
so it's funny they're both playing fast
and they're doing that thing where chess
players get on the same wavelength where
they're they're agreeing on the right
idea here and you and I are just in a
different Universe because
uh the moves we're seeing to play are
not the ideas that they're going for
um
actually does he know what he I don't
think he knows I don't think cutie
remembered on poisson oh hell oh no oh
my God oh my God they're just their
accuracy is dropping seven percent with
each move combined combined they are at
80 they're playing too fast they're just
not a queen F3 Danny Queen F3 is like
made soon oh my God it's a fort but Rook
tasty two Rook takes D2 is is lights out
on the spot and that's going to solve
all of her problems because then worst
case scenario she misses one of these
queen of three moves and she just
sacrifices The Rook on G2 I think she
sees it let's go to her stream real
quick she's drawing an arrow he's doing
more time walking away from the board
for theatrics he's got to stay at the
board oh she took it already yep he
takes oh he takes that
or is she double checking up a fork
anywhere with my queen involved
no
yeah she's behind a bit but she's gonna
take and then
you know uh
check oh look at that she's she's doing
great I mean if you take back the A5 and
the lights were blunder this whole thing
with the B6 and A5 Levy she's playing
great
absolutely she could still lose though
that's the problem like she's got to be
really careful I go here with her King
being open he goes there I go there he
takes so then he's up I don't love that
um
yeah you're right this isn't this isn't
non-blunderable yet that King is wide
open on that diagonal you think she's
gonna find Queen G2 Queen G2 Rook D1
King H2 Rook back to D2 real quick
that's a combo that I didn't see until
you pointed it out now given I wasn't
looking I was looking at messages from
Ludwig over here which I hope I hope
hold true about a certain player who
might show up and play today
um if I come here yeah that's a combo
that's a combo right there you just
showed and then there and I'm still
she's kind of
oh my God oh my goodness
I mean it's a better trade for him
that's what I don't like oh but she's
focused on G2 yeah but dude what if she
plays it and then accidentally sees Rook
takes D1 next okay that combo would be
insane yeah there's gotta be like a
combo of the tournament right there if I
go here I I think she's gonna talk
herself out of it though yeah he takes
she's she's got the right mindset though
like she's looking to simplify and get
pieces off the board because she knows
she's winning everybody sometimes that's
not the best
but but I like where her head's at
it's crazy what if I just go like this
oh
and moving her night out to attack that
night F5 is the best move in this
position according to stockfish but
Queen takes Bishop is the second
in Queen takes Bishop is the uh a move a
human rights okay if she goes for Knight
F5
that's the top engine move and it's the
only one with a mate in the evaluation
bar
uh she's about to find it something
weird though
I know I'm doing something wrong I'm
just gonna go here Knight F5 wow
cutie Cinderella
coming to play
with the guns in in the holster oh my
God and it's on the board already daddy
Knight F5
and he took the Rook Knight G3 and he
resigns oh my God he resigned he
resigned King H2 Knight takes F1 the
best move is not to take but it doesn't
matter where you go
because it's just me it's mate and cutie
takes away a one to nothing lead oh my
God that is crazy
wait that made me feel bad she was
impressive
don't resign oh that makes me feel bad
oh I love daily dose I feel bad I feel
bad that I celebrated but that was
that's that's the other reason why she
she doesn't get as many wins as she
could because she genuinely feels bad
every time she gets a win but there you
go she gets the dub she's up one nothing
over her friend and uh daily dose did
not look like he was handling that
defeat very well off camera we'll say
that in fact he's already off camera I
don't know where he disappeared to but
Levy let's quickly show that we'll go
back to the analysis board because our
our timing was a little off show just
how impressive cutie was with this
Knight F5 thing
yeah so her first thought was Queen
takes and then she calculated all of
that and and at the end of that she she
gives up a rook for a bishop she's still
winning because of the material but then
there's a something called an auxiliary
idea which for people who don't know is
the first move of your idea is correct
the second move is wrong and so
sometimes you need to work out the
second move and make the first move
correct and the entire idea correct and
the point is that she could have played
Rook takes first and then the king would
go here and then she would come back and
win the queen so she would win
everything so at the end of this she
would be up a rook and the bishop so her
auxiliary idea she just missed it that's
a concept that's very tough for chess
players to understand so she went back
to the drawing board and went Knight F5
because she realized she couldn't go
here so she wanted to attack this
instead and threaten this and that is
the top computer move she found it and
he just resigned on the very next turn
because Knight to G3 is lights out uh
that was ridiculous super impressive the
fact that she played 95 Levy but then
the fact that she played Knight G3 so
fast like she saw the whole idea already
she was all over it
yeah that was and he yeah he resigned
and the thing is Danny
he's a competitor and he does get
frustrated when he loses and a lot of us
are like that but I don't think he's
setting himself up for success in the
best way right so it's like if you're
not going to set yourself it's like you
know you have kids they go to like uh
Athletics all the time if you don't
train like you're gonna lose yeah it's
just you can't be mad that you lost you
have to train the right way he doesn't
break his bad habits fast enough he has
to break his bad habits he's gonna think
he lost this game maybe because he lost
the queen but that's not what he lost he
was losing anyway too fast he's lost
because he played too fast and he played
this dark Square Gambit again on the G3
square and I think
um anyway I agree with everything you
said and it it is hard because I think
when we're competitive we get frustrated
but did we really put in the time in
order to hold ourselves to the standard
of being better often the answer is
maybe no and I think he needs to slow
down a little bit top priority if I was
his coach one tip one two and three slow
down
it's a Stonewall on Stonewall action
because this is the opening that he
likes to play he likes to create this
grid uh and she likes to create this
grid so they are going to play an
identical symmetrical position against
each other which is very funny uh he
loves this stuff he loves this stuff he
plays F4 is white I'll uh I'll say the
Cutie's been playing The Stonewall
really since her first appearance in POG
Champs 2 back in back in 2020
um she loves it it's not necessarily the
best for the critical thinking she needs
to develop at the next stage she likes
it because she gets to play the same
thing over and over again but it is it
is a good opening if you get the things
you're highlighting which is she gets
the dark's work rip and she gets a
knight to E5 and we'll see
yeah exactly right and he's gonna do the
exact same thing okay she's doing this
which
is she gonna go the opposite way and
launch like a that might be crazy I mean
that's that is one way to play chess
just oh they castled great I'm gonna
attack them that's a great move now
she's gotta finish up the uh yeah so now
you got to play C32 because C4 otherwise
C4 happens and
we know what happens then you can't be a
real Stonewall player and not play C3
here
I mean this is like building a house and
not putting a window I mean you gotta
you get oh
I can't explode the thing why can't I
explode the thing I can't either we're
fighting each other's mouths there we go
that's why oh there it is okay she
played him
yay yeah it's like being a general
contractor and not finishing the house
now she can go here but he might just
keep going he loves pawns FIFA
I know these players better than they
know themselves you really are you're
you've predicted everything today to a
fault actually for daily dose because
you predicted he would lose on G3 again
and you were right
um
although cutie was right like I said I
guess you can attack Pawn chains with
Queens you just have to do a Cutie's way
and know that your opponent's gonna
blunder
she might be experienced enough to know
how to break this down like she might
know that G4 is the right idea you know
King H1 G4 which is just something you
build up that's a great move uh but that
G4 plan is something you build up with
experience again it's just it's the same
thing anybody that does any sport
you know when you get to a certain spot
if you've been there before you know how
to handle it that's all it is people
just don't train the right way so they
just get upset when they're losing but
you're not setting yourself up for
Success kind of like me in tournaments
so I uh you know I stopped because uh I
don't know if you're saying that because
you saw the person in chat call you out
about that or if you're just saying it
um that's funny no no I I literally
literally you were on a rant about it
and someone in chat was like says the I
am who doesn't prepare before he goes to
tournaments and I was like wow
that was oh Stone Cold roast right there
oh no no it's uh it's the truth you know
I feel like Danny three things could
make me a Grand Master number one making
it a full-time job number two getting a
sports psychologist number three paying
random 75 year old Europeans to lose
games to me on purpose uh I have
strongly considered number three but I'm
I think I'm too big for that now I think
they would figure it out so uh yeah uh
there's a C3 Pawn hanging by the way I
jumped a little bit in my chair when B3
was played
um
but uh daily dose has not seen it yet I
also don't recommend you know paying the
old the old Europeans to lose you know
the internet finds out everything these
days so even more reason to do the right
thing
um all right
c3's still hanging we'll see if we'll
see if he sees it yep they just they
just hate puns it's funny though because
in a closed structure it's easy to like
the Optics of the position I think he's
just not realizing that the pawn is
undefended and probably at some point
she will take the Knight on e4 and he'll
have missed his chance
at some point you also will figure it
out I mean you're going to look at Pawn
takes Pawn throughout this game you know
you're gonna look at Knight takes Pawn
uh one of those moves could could could
appear
I but he is a fighter and I I I do
believe in his ability to to overcome
the good news is there it is wow he
found it that's a huge move
that's that's huge because I mean that
Poland Levy is not just a pawn in the
structure it's potentially a lot more
for black right you get this past C4
Pawn as long as you don't do anything
silly next you bring the Knight back to
safety you've got yeah Leslie Levy's
highlighting there's a lot of good
things about Black's position now when
that C3 Pawn disappears
absolutely Knight to E4 is uh inviting
Bishop takes Pawn takes and then there's
going to be a pin here he's got to just
go back he can't over complicate things
but yeah the problem Danny in a lot of
these positions right for these for
these kind of advanced beginner players
is sometimes the best thing is just very
subtle you don't need to overdo anything
and they really overdo stuff right yep
yeah the uh the whole process of letting
the game come to you for lack of a
better Sports cliche is something you
learn with time right and in fact most
games you and I have seen are lost at
this level by people trying too hard
they're forcing a tactic where it
doesn't exist or seeing ghosts right and
I think you're totally right but on that
note I will say this his position is
accidentally stopping Cutie's biggest
plan we saw her be Jenny Levy with the
whole Queen H4 kind of plan that's not
gonna happen here because the queen on
d8 is guarding everything so there is
you know
his position is is hard to lose as long
as it stays how it is
yeah for sure
unless he starts going totally crazy
with something like Ponte chief
what is your ability today you literally
said that in real time and I can confirm
you weren't cheating there was no you
had no you had no board that they
couldn't see
foreign
calls I think uh that was wild these
these players kind of like I I kind of
understand that a lot of their brains
it's probably why I got to 4 million
subscribers for like beginners of
intermediates right but I I just
understand his style and his style is
like I should push here but there's no
King here so I'm gonna push here but as
you get better you just go like I'm
throwing punches where I'm not stronger
I should not be bullying my opponent on
this side of the board because it comes
with it for me too but he's still better
Danny it's still minus one so
my ability to predict Mini Cooper
psychology and your ability to predict
the ELO for players under 1500 you know
my skill is not as useful in the world
as yours is but um yeah this is this has
been impressive I'm not gonna lie
somebody said that's actually annoying
that I keep doing that that's
interesting that was a new one um all
right let's let's yeah let's take a look
at the Cutie let's get Levy off off the
mic here for a second so he can't
predict any more bad moves and see what
Cutie's thinking but potentially he's
going to move down here
which again is annoying he's really
annoying with pawns
he's annoying she's annoying I'm
annoying I can also just pull this up so
then it forces him to come here that way
it's normal
unless he just says oh I'm just going to
put pressure there to avoid all of that
doesn't stop it at all but
he could overextend
okay
hi Raiders sorry I'm in the middle of a
game
this one is are you ready for a little
more this one's intense
Taylor Swift reference
I I think we established yesterday which
I got roasted pretty hard on Twitter by
Ludwig and others about choosing Miley
Cyrus over Taylor Swift they both make
good music the best but they're they
they both cannot hold a candle to the
greatest individuals definitely doing
that who is the weekend
weekend is the best solo artist the
dream for modern Generations that down
for some reason that's my that's my hot
take Danny when I get this big wow the
weekend has like a 120 million plays
every month on Spotify I mean like it's
no we I I'm I'm a weekend fan I'm not
gonna lie so no real disagreements there
I was trying to pretend that's
interesting by the way the G5 Pawn is
gone which is why you don't overextend
Pawns in front of your king oh she's
she's about to take it
and she does
yeah yeah and and he put it there and uh
yeah
um now
the tough thing is that White's top move
according to the computer is to play
Pawn takes Pawn
what
what and what happens if you lose your
night stock fish oh right E4 with a
discovered attack
followed by C takes D5 and then and and
then e takes F5 with a counter attack
via pawns and Bush is shut up this is
why nobody likes you stockfish this is
why nobody likes you because you say
things like that now this is a more
human move it's a more human move and
that's why it gives gets a big fat
orange question mark and I'm gonna add
my own will it go to the other side oh
it doesn't go to the other side it would
be really funny if I could just put like
five question marks on it
um yeah Queen E7 now pins the Knight to
the queen
and that's Black's way of Defending but
we'll see what he does
yeah there's no way that we can hold
stockfish's move against QD or really
any human being to be honest I I don't
know that Magnus Carlson plays B take C4
there legitimately
um
I I uh okay you think maybe Rook takes
G5 E4 is spotted but it's it's a very
unhuman move Queen H4 though would not
have been played by Magnus probably just
a retreat of the night would have been
or even H4 because now daily dose has
found Queen E7
yeah uh in bullet I think Magnus just
goes back to F3 that's kind of what I
was saying yeah yeah
uh title Tuesday maybe but like I think
he would stop his thought that takes
takes
whatever you know he I I always say
stuff like that and then I wonder if
he's ever watching this broadcast didn't
go man this idiot doesn't know a damn
thing about me so uh
yeah
um
hey Magnus hey Magnus watching from the
World Cup in Baku
um
the uh the move Queen E7 has been played
Cutie's in a little bit of trouble she
does find E4 now though that's
interesting I know it gives it a big
question mark but that's a nice idea
opening the bishop can we go to her
stream I wonder does she understand what
she's doing like does she understand
she's getting her Bishops open let's do
it let's go see I think she does I think
she saw she didn't know how to defend
the Knight so she did it with E4
whatever
all right good thoughts from her he
might not give me an open file of course
he might go there
which is fine
I mean
smart
if he doesn't take this I go here
right correct
the real problem is she defended the
Knight but she hasn't solved the pin
problem
and I think she's about to learn that
the hard way let's keep watching to see
what she what she thinks this could be
about to go really bad
and now he can't go there actually
he could go here though
which is an annoying check
but he doesn't really gain anything from
it
if I actually okay so right now this
Knight Bishop yep you can go here no I
can't
here no we can't
hear yes he can
hear no he can't
hear no he can't here no he can't so if
I were to do this wait that's an l oh my
God I lost all my L's okay that is
she does see it though she sees the
check it's not that bad though yep
yeah Bishop D2 is reasonable pressure on
his Knight or do I want to make a
different move
I feel like I should make it looks
different Queen all the way back is the
best move in E1 it's which is which
is actually a great move it would attack
the Knight and guardi too
I don't think she's even considering the
queen though yeah that's a tough move
ah whoa sheep
why why why why why why why why why why
why
I don't know because uh my brain I don't
know neither does she she played it
before although if she sees Bishop okay
like that's not a bad idea again it's a
bad idea it's like Wreck-It Ralph you
can be a bad guy without being a bad guy
okay it's a bad idea but it's not a bad
idea you get what I'm saying I think
he's not at all no okay no see look no
look that was not a bad idea even though
it was a bad idea because she should
have lost the Knight if he takes the
Knight here but it was a good idea to
get the bishop on a good diagonal you
get you can make you can play Bad moves
without them being a bad move do you get
it yeah and he might not take the Knight
and he did there you go just like that
easy
good ideas pay off
Danny the way you talk you could be a
politician
I don't even know what you talked about
but I think you aligned with my
political views there you go it's uh
it's it's it's it's enlightening when
you learn that it's just the where you
put the right emphasis on the right
syllable can change how someone feels
about what you're saying thank you Paul
Danny I feel like I feel like that was a
that was a big Transcendent moment and I
think I think I'm looking forward to
your term and I'm looking forward to you
addressing some of these very complex
issues you know I really feel convinced
that yeah man for the job so all right
yeah let's let's head back to analysis
so Levy can show all the bad ideas that
we found even if they weren't
necessarily bad ideas okay the last
eight moves have been better
um this move attacked this uh this lost
the pawn but it had an interesting it
was a good idea which was a bad idea
which was that maybe she would get the
open file uh and then he did this which
apparently was not the right idea and
then she went here after addressing this
this is winning now because you take the
bishop and the bishop guards the Knight
so you take the knight uh he took this
instead she went here attacking the
queen and forgetting that it no longer
defends the Knight and then so did he
and now she goes here which is another
bad move now he goes here and now she
plays Bishop to D1 and and and and the
computers I think overdoing it Danny I
mean every move is fluctuating oh no
that was such a powerful piece Danny
know what the top engine move here is
for White Knight wait I gotta show it
dude
Knight takes E4 with the idea that you
don't take this and you go here and if
takes you have Rook to have eight and
you win the queen
dude this is the immortal game thank you
Chad in a moral commentary by Levy
Rosman this is you are watching the
magnum opus of pogchamps right now
um yeah and I and I kind of mean that
look you can play for a lot of good
ideas even if okay I will keep going on
the on the story of difference between
bad ideas and bad ideas and this
position a lot of things are about to go
wrong
yeah but I'm having a good time she
might see Rook f8 by the way it's not
difficult as an 800 player to go I'd
love my Rook there how does that happen
well they could take me oh but they
could go here as well so
it's there it's all there it's a closed
position it's very tough to break
through so you start looking at ways to
break through and then
I I actually agree and if I had to
predict I think this position is way
more dangerous for daily dose than cutie
despite the past pawns and despite the
objective evaluation the black is I see
the eval bar don't yell at me chat but
Levy D5 is coming for Cutie the queen
side has still not developed if we want
to highlight that the rook and Knight
are out okay he plays C3 but look
there's tactics here there's there's D5
as you pointed out by the way she just
played Knight takes E4 are you freaking
kidding me and again
she's about to hold this game
do it play Rook f8 show that you were
brilliant
come on oh my God come on oh is she
gonna get greedy Danny she's gonna get
greedy and play Queen F6 and try to mate
him
dude that's also awesome but Rook f8
that was the idea she freaking found it
oh my God
what
she panicked
but why did she play Knight takes E4 if
she didn't see the move
no
zzy come on
we just lost our proverbial bleep on air
with Knight takes E4 and now it's like a
it's like a movie where they set up a
brilliant plot and then fail to deliver
on oh she found good if you dude oh my
God
she's a genius she's a genius
play for it
oh my God oh my God oh my God did she
see it
no she's highlighting the wrong thing
that's not what you played that move for
no queen of Fate oh my God Queen f8
queen of Fate she has no idea no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no okay
oh I don't
I don't I don't know I can't even hear
Levy anymore
oh
Danny oh my God what am I doing what am
I doing
oh my God
Danny she's never dude I've never seen
someone so accidentally brilliant failed
to like seriously and it's not over
she's gonna move her Queen to the side
he's gonna take on D4 with the rook and
there's going to be made again
dude if you call that
if she moves the queen
oh my God I don't know how to win this
I don't think it's possible
she doesn't she doesn't see it though
Levy so it would it would have to be
truly accidentally brilliant title of
your autobiography
accidentally brilliant accidentally
brilliant
she she's just I don't think I can win I
don't know what I'm doing she's doing
the xuc school of Chess just jiggle
every piece one time
my God
I was so convinced we were going to see
the most brilliant finish of all time by
cutie Cinderella that's oh that's okay
she's attacking the bishop
D5 is a really nice idea actually that's
crazy that she re-centered her chakra if
you will yes and found that that's nuts
I don't know where I screwed up but I
screwed up so bad I'm gonna I'm gonna
give an omelette here stick the bishop
she's gonna get the other Pawns
dude she's she's on path to being
brilliant I'm gonna stay in a Zen State
he just showed his butt to everybody
you want to watch the game come here
come on
I don't know what he wants season he's
been annoying today my foot's asleep
dude
Queen takes Queen takes oh the bishop
isn't there anymore I was gonna say
queen takes C6 we have four takes C6 and
queen of four oh the queen yeah free
text is uh
no oh no oh no she just doesn't see that
idea she's just not even looking for it
that's a good skewer skewer everybody
it is a good skier that's a good ass
skewer I don't care who you are that
that's a good ass skewer
and she's still gonna win the game I
think dude okay okay he can't take he
can't take it because he can't take it
because she takes his Queen he's not
gonna take it he'll see that like the
I don't think so I think he plays too
fast I think he's gonna take it okay
with that or maybe he'll take F1 first
he's gonna take he's gonna take
something for sure
did you go here and he comes here then
he takes Danny I don't want to be right
man I don't want to be right okay she
doesn't see that the queen is hanging
she doesn't see that the queen is
hanging look I don't have time to get
down there as a queen no oh my God is
hanging
yeah oh God right dude I do I just have
to I don't know no oh no no
she's losing Queen takes Queen oh my God
there we go oh my God oh my God
foreign
maybe that'll make us play better oh my
God that was my only choice
by the way
for some reason the eighth grade the
eighth rank was just like invisible to
both players in this game like neither
player saw the eighth rank for any
tactic all of that said Levy
uh yeah yeah she's probably still going
on to win this game at this point like
she's gonna clean up the pawns and The
Rook is gonna get open
Danny I don't know I mean queen and
Knight
and uh like walking onto the f file
loses my Discover check
so she might go to the corner and then
he might play Queen F4 or queen C7 and I
mean I'm just saying it's not
okay that's fair that's fair all right
God
okay but here's the deal if queen of
four she has to accidentally find the
only move on the board which is like
Rook takes C2 to guard I mean she's
gonna see it you're right and she's
gonna accidentally open the files and
then the rook and Queen Are Gonna
accidentally deliver remaining net on
the back rank that's what I'm calling
I'm calling it I'm learning to think
like you watch this Rook takes C2 she
played it and she's gonna accidentally
mate on the over files Yep this is a
draw after Queenie for guarding the pawn
from this check and then this but that's
not findable he'll go Queen G3 and he's
gonna be losing by accident but only if
she if she fine yeah and and now now but
he you know we might get Rook C7 and
then this so we might get Queen B7 Danny
and then the king runs to safety like
she has to go here that is not easy
okay you're right we did get Queen B7
okay all all king's gone running King's
gone running
oh my God she's gonna play Queen she's
seven and check the king into G3 oh no
she found Rook F2 okay brilliant but
he's coming with the pawn Danny's coming
with the pawn oh my God
this is insane this is insane because we
literally can't predict we can and we
can't we can't predict anything here
come on he's gonna guard his Knight with
the pawn and then it's game on she has
to be cerebral she has to realize a draw
is good for her a draw wins that's
that's true that's true he's gonna keep
pushing he has strong tunnel vision and
queen G7 might lead to mate King here
Queen takes Queen H5 somehow
oh Danny okay and also it could lead to
rookie two mate yep yep Queen G7 King G3
Rook G2 oh my God Queen G7 King H4 Queen
H7 kg3 oh
[Applause]
he's playing too fast he's just playing
too fast it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable it now it's over basically
because
dude she made it herself and he and he
played two although he only has a minute
so uh 30 seconds so I'll forgive him but
still you're right he just plays too
fast he plays too fast though he has to
play King G5
see what's he thinking now
yeah
Queen h5a will she trade the Queens will
she trade the Queen's massively if she
sees the draw Queen G7 is just over
right she just takes look she might she
plays Queen G7 all she needs is to draw
to win yup does she know that a draw
does she know
[Music]
um
check
okay as you know
how do I what is this we need seven is
also good queen h8 queen H7 wow Queen E7
oh okay she find it oh yeah he has to
block it now let's make Queen H7 Queen
H6 but you could also just trade Queens
okay will she see Queen H7 or she looks
like she's about to take the pawn yeah
okay she does also it's also pretty good
she's getting it
yeah now Queen H7 is made by accident
because it's also the only check trade
Queen H7 is just
Queen G3
cleaning up just cleaning up
Judy Cinderella is gonna be taking a
free Uber ride to the live finals in Los
Angeles what a message one second
he lost it's over
wow
that 11 wonders bro what
11 wonders
sorry cutie yes you might actually have
to have been like four
she gonna see she had Checkmate oh she's
gonna see she had a brilliant move oh
we're not letting us see it all right
she's gonna see she had a brilliant move
and that's what's gonna be phenomenal is
I can't wait for that content anyone
watching her Channel
um Judy Cinderella as I said
um gets a Lyft or Uber whatever she
whatever she prefers uh uh covered by
chess.com to the off-brand Production
Studios where we will have a live final
for the consolation bracket of pogchamps
five who will she play we're gonna find
out
there you go
there you go that was uh that was a very
fun round that second game was
unnecessarily chaotic but I feel like
that's
that's fitting for a consolation bracket
semi-final and she is the first uh she
there she is she's the first finalist in
the uh consolation bracket let's let's
uh let's see it live if she has moved on
cutie Cinderella Cinderella apparently I
can't speak today where are we good uh
whiskly wabbit cutie Cinderella Waits
the winner of virtual and squeaks she is
in the live final our first ever live
OTB that's over the board chess for
those who don't speak French
for the POG Champs 5 finale
um like I said she'll take a free Uber
um and uh we'll make sure that it's real
nice
real nice Uber we'll make sure we get a
five star Uber Uber black right it'll be
Uber black which is what you have to get
in LA because they're like 200
yeah so we're gonna give Judy an Uber
black and uh she will be going to the
live final are they serious these Jokes
Aside that was one of the most
accidentally brilliant games I've ever
seen in POG Champs what a great time
there she is celebrating cutie
Cinderella is coming up for an interview
with daily dose don't go anywhere it's
more pogchamps five when we return
yes
foreign
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carlsen and vichyana
this course is generally about exambers
like this common knowledge that's used
on on the highest level
intuition comes from knowing a lot of
examples from having seen examples
thought about them and perhaps tried to
implement the principles but under
different circumstances having thought
about it having tried to implement it in
a way having debated it so that's more
or less what I try to do with this
course
basically puts the foundation for
positional understanding positional
intuition you will see in in many
players
foreign
oh my gosh she just resigned Hikaru we
got a resignation it's going to the tie
break
take the pawn oh boy boy it's the winner
you won by the dirty flag the question
is does hafu take the Grand Master
approach here and just take the
Perpetual for the championship doesn't
matter
we gotta listen and she's about to
deliver the goods
[Music]
hard work pays off but now
um
holy let's go
[Music]
let's go
thank you
[Music]
hog Champs 5 continues to roll on we
have our first player who has secured
her spot for the live Final in La it's
IRL chess over the board for those who
speak
OTB
and cutie Cinderella cutie
I don't know if you know this but you
just earned yourself a free Uber ride
We're Gonna Get You Uber black a free
Uber
I know right I know stay where you've
seated We're Gonna Get You free Uber to
the live final
wow I'm so I'm so blessed
so blessed
it could be a helicopter ride I don't
know I mean we should that's no okay
Uber it is for for cutie Cutie uh Jokes
Aside that was obviously a wild match
there you take a 2-0 and how are you
feeling you're the first player to get
to the first ever live pod Champs
um the the that last match was
terrifying I forgot how to play chess
no it was it was good it was chaotic
yeah it was a lot of back and forth uh
you you had a chance to pull up the game
review I don't know if you took a deep
dive there was like a missed Checkmate
on both sides I I don't know it was uh
wow
did you also feel like that last match
was was was there for the taking a
little bit like it there was a lot of
chaos back and forth yeah I had an
opening yeah I had a couple openings but
I think she just kept locking them so
yeah well you were you were saying uh
just to reveal our our quick off-air
conversation that you struggled with you
struggle with white is that something
you just haven't had time to work on
your wide openings or what are is it a
go ahead I only have like one opening in
white and that's the only one I know how
to do but since Gotham has been like uh
you know making fun of me for it I'm
like I'm gonna do something different
that's totally screwed me over
I see I believe Levy for all the
problems on these shows too daily dose I
agree with you this is Levy's fault and
uh I'm sorry the reason Felix is this is
asleep uh you know he I just my content
puts everybody but puts everybody to
sleep daily dose that first game you had
a good position you were actually pretty
okay in the opening chess games are one
and lost in the middle game and the end
game
I hate openings I just want to just put
me in a situation that I'm much better
like just put me in a comfortable
situation much better but like I only
know that one wide opening that's it but
um that opening that it was specifically
for you you were in my head the whole
time
no Gotham oh Gotham because because of
the G3 square and unfortunately the G3
Square haunted you again because that
was the move that gave cutie the
advantage right when you played H3 to
attack your queen and she took the pawn
were you taking notes
the pen in game one
yeah you had like you had you had a pen
oh before I started
yeah
oh it was because it's not very cool I
so I was uh studying I was watching your
videos all night last night with the the
England Gambler Gambit because that's
what snap map used on him but it
I don't know how to annotate chess so I
don't know none of my notes make sense
literally my note is like he moves Pawn
then he moves horsey and take Pawn with
horsey and then uh so I'm sitting there
trying to review my notes and I'm like
wait none of these make any sense
so yeah it didn't it didn't it was not
as you saw my England uh fell apart very
quickly
well daily dose despite despite what
Levy you know did to ruin to ruin that
experience overall how was your I'm
kidding but how was your pox Champs five
tournament did you have a good time and
what are your what are your takeaways
from this as far as things you might do
differently or what you would you know
do next time well obviously yeah I would
I would train because I did zero
training for this
um so that would be nice to do next time
offer an apology with a puppy
if I was to get
if I was to give any advice I will say
like you seem you see tactics faster
than your brain can calculate whether
it's a good idea to play for it so if I
was to give you some coaching advice I
would say slow down a little bit in the
opening where it's your toughest stage
because you actually did seem to have we
were highlighting a lot of the ideas
that we thought you were seeing and most
the mistakes you made you seemed like
you were just playing too fast
I'm good at that yeah no I totally agree
it's my biggest weakness that I play too
fast so
all right um Judy do you want to talk
about your biggest weaknesses or we're
sharing on that yeah my biggest weakness
is I forget which direction the piece is
go sometimes when I sacked my night I
was like this is a totally safe spot and
then I was like wait no black moves
towards me uh yeah I'm dyslexic so it's
it's I forget I forget directions
turns out it was a brilliant move to
sacrifice your night and you had various
ways of checkmating him a few moves
later so we were screaming about it
being brilliant but then but then you
you did something else so it was a crazy
moment you'll see did you know you had a
brilliant move Judy sorry to interrupt
but you had a brilliant move like the
brilliant the brilliant symbol was on
the board and we completely lost it you
were it was an incredible idea but you
didn't follow through but it was a great
it was a great move
then I'll tell you what it was an
accident and not a an idea
but exciting very exciting fair enough
we're uh we're gonna let you go but we
have one question uh cutie because you
we have another match coming up today
between virtual and squeaks I I'd like
to get your full unfiltered thoughts on
who you would prefer as an opponent uh
in the in the constellation bracket
final
uh I would prefer squeaks
uh mostly because I think virtual is
better
um and so I hope that uh squeaks takes
like Vyvanse today or like steroids or
something like some drug enhancing
things I think it's the only way he will
be virtual so
but I would prefer to go against squeeze
because I think it'd be easier for me
yeah I I appreciate that well all right
uh congratulations no matter who you're
playing we will we will see you in La
after that incredibly Posh Uber ride
that we get you um thank you for saving
us some money you know one less flight
to worry about
um and seriously it is it is pretty
awesome that you'll be playing in a
final given that you're kind of an OG of
the Pod Champs community so David Jones
not that we were rooting for her but it
is kind of cool that Cutie's playing I'm
just saying
um I think I think
she's much better at the streaming stuff
than I am so
well dude it's it's great great to have
you here I hope you had a had a decent
time and if it happens again in the
future we'll hook up some training and
uh thanks for playing
of course thanks very much
bye bye everybody
hi y'all all right Levy there you have
it that's how cutie Cinderella made her
way to the live Final in La awaiting the
winner of virtual and squeaks
we're spitting there that's how that's
how she made her way to the live Final
in La hey sometimes I accidentally hit
the rhymes on the mic you know when it
feels right
they're tight
there you go uh it's another matchup of
players I didn't really want to see
loose and it was nice to hear that
they both watched some of my content
because I criticized some of their stuff
and then so it's my fault they didn't
but it's funny if you if you replay the
tape of how you and I were talking about
this match you were literally called it
you're like she's trying to play the
England Gambit just like I taught uh you
know uh I'm sorry I'm blinking sapnap
but it wasn't even the right it was a
different it was the whole thing was
different it you know it was the from
Gambit versus the bird it whatever
um it was good I I enjoyed I'll take the
L you know
maybe we should we should show cutie in
La is how to take just notation because
she was saying she didn't quite know how
to make notes and that might actually be
a really useful tip for the future if
she's watching your videos
I uh I I think it is a useful tip and I
am more than happy to uh to share some
wisdom and you know maybe we just we
just book virtual or squeaks on a bad
flight you know like a really bad
Airline you know seats don't recline
maybe they get lost speaking of virtual
and squeaks let's let's remind everybody
that it's starting right now here we go
with two more matchups scheduled in the
next hour plus we start out finding out
who Cutie Cinderella will play squeaks
or virtual after that of course we have
I did a thing versus cdog VA Conor
versus Alex it's gonna be epic that the
chess and that match is going to be
maybe not quite as accidentally
brilliant as what we just saw Levy but I
think it's going to be high quality so
everyone should stick around for that
and here we go it's time for squeaks and
virtual are you ready
yeah yeah I'm ready
um I really hope this is not a match
where you are picking up a mouse and
putting it in a in a box to be attacked
by a snake
I
I had a fifth grade teacher Danny that
showed that to the class my fifth grade
teacher had a python that she would feed
a snake for science class
that sounds really weird to do in front
of kids just to like have one live
animal kill another live animal
right I I you know now that I said it
out loud I I must have had a really
weird childhood
um yeah here's a match-up card where you
could triple squeaks this rating and
he's not 1094 or or they're about it's
very close
um yeah
this is going to be rough Danny I mean
squeaks really better yeah here's what
I'll say here's what I said here's what
I'll say Kuno was the heavy Underdog
against virtual and got a good position
as black a little bit of confidence and
focus might have gone a long way the
difference is I think squeaks really
wants this I think saikuno was almost a
little checked out assumed it was over
so I'm not ready to just anoint virtual
as playing in LA and that's not just
because it'll be an expensive flight
from Norway I actually think that
squeaks has an outside Fighter's chance
here against that guy that's that's my
thought I don't disagree
but if squeak speeds virtual it will be
the greatest comeback in chess history
so well don't don't call it a comeback
he's been here for years that'll be the
best offset yeah then not not come back
uh it will like make no mistake
it would it would be wild uh it would be
well but again here's what I think as
much as we've been talking about how
virtual doesn't belong in the
consolation bracket he's in the
consolation bracket and that's no shade
necessarily to him or or Anna krambling
as the coach we know that they worked
hard there was extra IRL chess lessons
but also he he messed up a lot of
positions so he's got to get the job
done and I think squeaks I think squeaks
is uh is capable of squeaking one out if
you know what I'm talking about huh I I
do know that was a very very good pun
and good to see virtual showing at least
five percent respect to his opponent
today and not going for a wayward Queen
attack
uh you know yesterday he went for Queen
H5 today hopefully he will go for ah
yeah he likes to play the ponziani
that's right that's right so yeah and
that that opening is very good and
hopefully
Nemo taught squeaks something against
this because this is all virtual plays
uh hopefully he's got something in the
bag I agree
I think we're gonna get some good oh he
plays the best move with D5 let's go
what let's go okay if if virtual knows
Queen A4 yo um oh my God man
I mean that's crazy
that is crazy Queen to A4
okay
even more impressive if squeaks knows
the best move here let's listen into
squeaks because he seems to be
entertaining his fans and I'm a part of
the Dorito chip gang let's listen in
now if I bring this Knight out
[Music]
uh
what if I go like this no no let's just
bring the night out
[Music]
I mean
Levy the E5 Pawn is hanging but it's
actually still Theory
Knight F6 is one of the best moves now
Knight takes E5 okay is the
justification what
that's not the best move
uh-oh you're supposed to do queen takes
he doesn't know what he's doing he
doesn't he doesn't know the whole point
of the opening oh my goodness this is
the danger of teaching you know kind of
like new and returning players your
openings is that
he already thinks he's messed up I mean
it's unbelievable
if he takes it the queen he's in a great
spot yep does he see it
he's forgetting his Queen can take the
pawn oh my goodness
he's he's already panicking I mean it's
insane I mean he's just forgetting the
queen can take
come on if I take okay take with the
knight at least okay he sees it
is that a snake on his desk what is that
he's gonna take this
okay he took it's not the best move but
it's life now taking is actually a huge
mistake Queen E7 is winning for black
can I kick my diet I mean I'm sorry I'm
blind it's just headphones that's me any
Hooters yeah um yeah but he's gonna go
yeah yeah I think I'm okay oh my God it
could be worse
put it down put it down put it down put
it down I just want to show this on the
analysis board White had to do this or
move ago
uh because
because Knight E5 the e-file was still
closed by opening the e-file Knight E5
just loses the game now with this pin
because you have to defend it and then
you just lose the knife six wins a piece
crazy but this whole thing implies
either a little bit of theory knowledge
or tactical kind of awareness that I
don't think actually either player has
here they are they are roughly beginner
players but virtual is the guy who's
supposed to know this opening better and
like you said he doesn't even though
he's getting away with it here oh my God
after Knight takes C6 squeaks better not
play Queen takes and loses Queen to
Bishop to be fine oh no stop it Levy you
shush your mouth when you're
commentating on POG Champs if you bring
that to life your premonition you shush
your mouth when you're when you're
talking to me right now I'm not I'm not
let's go see what virtual okay he plays
D5
which is fine which is funny oh man
these uh that was huge Levy Rosman
almost spoke another blunder into
existence he's the one champion
after this and this
now my Bishop can come into play too
yeah
is a good control
okay
if he plays Pawn up I probably just
capture and simplify it
is your true facts so now okay I don't
think there's any need to be fancy I'm
up a pawn
I can just trade here no squeaks don't
take with the queen don't take with the
queen now you do not want to play Queen
captures he has to play Pawn capture
because of this move
he sees it and you know
oh my God
and I think I just play here preventing
any tracks anything weird
I'll have to take it
Castle
gotta develop these pieces
Queen can always retweet it's all good
this Pawn is going to be a bit of a
nuisance to the final I think
especially after I get get my my pieces
out I forbade you from speaking
um but good fundamentals doing good
foreign
if virtual wins this match and then if
virtual beats cutie he needs to play the
winner of the consolation brag of the
Champions bracket
that's that that's the surprise reveal
at
the park Champs live final
that's actually a great surprise reveal
thanks for ruining the surprise
well if cutie wins she's not going to
want to play anybody so she'll be done
and she'll take her cash in the Uber
home
so yep
my dog is disgusted with what he's
seeing oh he's doing a stretch there he
is there he is downward dog that's
literally downward dog right there
um dog's out of here he's like I've had
enough of these of this ponziani
paziani okay uh castles there's nothing
better than dog puns like Paw Patrol
you ever watch PAW Patrol and I haven't
but I know it's a tick tock filter
yep
um
all right look at look here's the deal
regardless of how we got here with a
little bit of a broken ponziani this is
pretty decent chess yeah both sides are
developing look at that castles castles
look whites booting White's much better
with the extra pollen and and the pawn
storm that you're highlighting on the
board
um but this isn't this is not over at
all this is a
Tony this is better chess than what we
had yesterday to challenge virtual and
the time is also close to even this
isn't like a dominant performance just
yet
definitely not but you know squeaks
might like it's never too late for a
beginner to go oh Pawn trade and then he
loses a pun and then it's a fork so he
loses a knight
is that what beginners that sound like
into your head oh Palm trade yeah well
well the thing is the beginner thought
process goes I'm gonna move my Bishop
there because if he takes me I take him
that's it like there is nothing else
after that it's a cavern yeah and uh
right it's actually true yeah you know
Bishop C4 is uh is a reasonable move but
you're right like if virtual just
realizes that he should Pawn storm then
that's it like it's going to be bad
shape for black
yep
okay and here he does he's Pawn storming
it up and squeaks has taken a sip of
more alcohol disguise the chocolate milk
before he was drinking whiskey and he
said it was tea that's clearly uh a
White Russian or some other type of
drink and he's saying it's hot chocolate
clearly
I miss hot chocolate I want like a good
hot chocolate I feel like hot chocolate
quality decrease that every Cafe I've
ever been to it just tastes like machine
hot chocolate
yeah
who makes fresh hot chocolate anymore
like is that even a thing like it is but
but then it's always made with some Uber
fancy chocolate that's like bitter and
like I I there's no winning you know I
had a hot chocolate at a Yankee game
last year it was like nine dollars all
right but I was so cold it tasted better
it was gross hot chocolate it was like
the last remaining package it's just
Swiss Miss Swiss Miss so they just like
take it out of the packet hot water it
okay A4 is looking great
uh virtual's looking good why don't we
listening again just get a little bit
more a little more content here from our
streamers yeah let's do it I don't think
squeak is talking much but let's see
what virtual's saying
okay so he wants to connect
if that sounds like he's in the room
with you it sounds like he's in the room
with you with that mic your mic is you
know
Maybe
A5 I like I like talking about
positional 1000
um I don't know I I don't know uh this
move I'm just kidding your mic is great
you've got a great New York I think I
want to play this you ever tell you your
New York Yankees comes out when you tell
stories now let's do it oh no is that a
good thing it's night here he's in a lot
of trouble after clean up your attack I
get told I I speak like an Eastern
European apparently I have a Eastern
European
spice in my voice
it's a spice you know
um A5 is played virtual is continuing to
show why Levy is better at predicting
where he's threatening this Pawn
is
I think he's gonna give him a check
hmm I don't
think he'll realize but maybe not I
could push up
but that's okay he can't go in with a
queen yet
and the night a lot of this bishop to
put the players to the instructions
do I mind if if it takes and
one thing I haven't heard yet is a plan
I've heard a lot of reaction moves let's
think a little bit about but what's his
plan here
I don't think he has one
Chuck King here
there isn't really a follow-up to that
after the night there this move he takes
and
this move I don't like
because this file is I mean as Bishop is
literally stuck so it's gonna take him a
little bit to attack it but
while the Bishop fuels instrumental it's
like how Magnus thinks basically
go ah you can't really go there this guy
really gonna play a backwards bishop
move in POG champs this night up like
wow
Danny I need to show this on the
analysis board
let's do it this this
I don't I want to ins can I insult the
players I'm angry he's in this bracket
Denny Bishop D2 is the top engine move
like
Queen A6 was the third choice B4 was the
first choice this dude just undeveloped
a bishop to remove it as a target from
his opponent because his opponent
doesn't have enough time to conquer the
e-file and in that time the Knight will
not be able to take the bishop so he can
launch a successful attack why is this
dude in this bracket that is the top
line of the computer there is not a
single player in this tournament that
would play Bishop D2 there Danny this is
this is and look and look he blunders
immediately oh my God I hate this I why
am I doing commentary today it's gonna
raise my blood pressure Danny
do you need a hug do you want me to hug
you why is he in this bracket how does
this happen well because he lost and
also here's what he has done he's made
he's made some big one move blunders at
times he's been good and then made one
move blunder so hopefully he doesn't do
that here but you're right this was a
very very very well executed plan that's
is that my I'm translating what you said
it was a very well executed plan by
white translate it that was a crazy move
that was like exactly how chess is
supposed to be played can I do something
forcing no what's a move that improves
my position long term Bishop back one
square that's so that's sick like he
found that that's well for the record
his group might not even been the
strongest group I have a lot of people
in his group lost in round one right
you've got Alex and Sea Dog so anyway we
had some really great players this year
I I honestly don't even know what to say
I'm very impressed by by what he's doing
now he's getting the Queens off the
board trying to simplify it's high
quality chests here yep honestly
well he definitely he definitely had the
best I mean like sapnap we didn't know
though like that's the thing you don't
know you you going into the tournament
you never know who's gonna train and
who's gonna not train like we didn't
know gasly was going to be a killer we
didn't know sapnap was going to beat Sea
Dog and virtual I I it's funny I think
of all the players in that group I think
ghastly was actually the one I was most
impressed with because he he really he
really surprised everybody with how hard
he grinded so shout out to Andrea for
getting him in the tournament because I
she was right I had no idea but anyway
yeah so you know sometimes people go
full sardosh and they commit to chess
and then there's nothing you can do
yeah that was uh I I would I Danny I
wouldn't have played Bishop to D2
Bishop D2 was a high quality move I'm
not gonna lie
um I would have went Queen A6 and like
Knight A3 uh Knight D2 I mean it's
launched the attack yeah just lose the
pawn like why do you need this Pawn you
know and and yeah the computer just
takes and tells me I'm an idiot but like
I would you know
this actually looks pretty good for
white by the way this is what I would
have done too it's a good human approach
um
I gotta say though I'm gonna come back
to applauding squeaks he's not doing a
lot of talking right now really focused
another hot chocolate hot chocolate here
we go but he's holding his own against
the by far best player in the
consolation bracket this is not the
worst chess game that's all I'm saying
no it's not at all
it's not at all he he made a mistake of
course he tried to be a little active
uh but uh
we're gonna see how easily virtual
converts this like if he just plays B4
B5 okay maybe he plays Knight C4 B4 B5
and just
what more can you say
let's see what Screech has got on his
mind he's finally given us some language
some words the lips are moving
and then I go here
okay okay
[Music]
um
let's see wait it's actually fine I'll
go here
it's not a bad idea at all from
squeezing look at this line we are
creating
a sword
if I go here
boom boom boom just like the simulations
I'm creating a sword
if he doesn't see this Massive Attack
it's game ogre
he has to he has to threateness right
are you gonna check maybe right now
ogre
I don't know but I will say this
regardless of how flawed that line of
thinking was it was actually really
great again that's a really good example
of a bad idea it wasn't really that bad
of an idea
yeah because you know what he sees he
sees the background the aerial attack he
sees the idea of using all those pieces
yep yep yep yep
[Music]
if he goes here
bad I like that game I'll just take yeah
that's the best terrible idea I've seen
all day I agree I mean he's a good chess
player that's a good move act oh not
really
actually no cuties cuties bad idea best
idea was the best idea but yeah
yep
[Music]
what if I
okay if I go here
okay
he takes I take
is he gonna go rookie one
I don't know we appreciate squeak's
music for a second
I think this is the thing I'm scared of
he doesn't see that virtual pinned him
boom boom yeah when I take oh
oh now he does
don't take it he didn't take it though
he missed Queen takes Pawn
wait did he take me virtual sees really
great ideas and sometimes plays too fast
and makes blunders that's been the one
thing I can say about his chest
like look the dude sets up Levy he sets
up Queen H3 and rookie one and then
doesn't play Queen takes F5 yep it's a
free pawn and and all the benefits of
the position
oh there was a way for boyfriend there
can I just show this on the analysis
board real quick he's scared uh
do I still want to sack a piece
so squeaks Was preparing actually
something very clever he prepared this
move Rook to E1
which doesn't work at all uh it it only
the point is you if if everything
happens like this then squeaks is a God
uh but even just capturing once by white
and not a second time is good enough
however if white doesn't take for
example and plays A6 now suddenly you
can take that rook and the point is that
you create a gap between the king and
the rook and you win
it's made so squeaks was almost almost
brilliant but yeah then he got pinned
and now the King has a left and
where she was gonna kind of like it's
kind of like Almost Famous great movie
by the way super underrated yeah that's
the stats that's my autobiography right
there that is a film Almost Famous this
game almost brilliant but again it does
show that a lot of players are are are
starting to see tactical ideas they see
a back ring Checkmate pattern putting it
all together is the next step um so
squeaks had a bad idea but it wasn't a
bad idea it just didn't work and now now
the question is
look at that night by the way that night
is that's a nice night hey you you
looking at me I'm looking at you hey
get over here
is that from The Goodfellas or something
you what am I funny to you like a clown
um anyway the Knight on E5 that's there
you go there you go
what you mean like I amuse you like I'm
a clown
like I amuse you yeah oh my God so good
great movie
I uh I was on a plane and they had The
Sopranos and I've never seen The
Sopranos because it was before my time
it was great um
my dog might bark because my wife's
coming home so he's very frustrated he
cannot leave oh no no there is oh there
was open there you go okay he's out
he's out he's gonna jump all over Lucy
it's gonna be adorable oh he lost look
at this virtual's put on the hurt
brutal putting on the hurt Putting on
the Ritz
um
let's see virtual for the final moments
here yep
little 90 accuracy game from from him
just a casual 90. put up a casual night
casual casual eight seven point five yep
rounds it up just like in school never
could though
okay then I can just gobble up these
probably oh
oh wait
this has to be a blunder
he doesn't even know it's a blunder this
late it's so silly there's a Checkmate
here probably
well I mean strict pull-ups are you know
not a lot of human beings can do that so
I'll applaud him for that
um and I'm also going to applaud him for
his chest
I mean
Danny we worked out in Toronto you you
saw me do like 15 of those in a row
oh more than that you were hitting more
I I I wanted to stay humble but
um but but in all seriousness we did we
did go through a workout together I I
did like 90 of your workout let me tell
you Danny wrench works out all right
that this man is in shape I mean my
goodness we had a great workout you no
you crushed it man and Levy got
recognized in the gym by two random
Canadians we're just working out and
they just come up and they're like here
you Gotham chess we're in the middle of
a ciabatta Levy's busy he's lifting
weights but they wanted to see but they
didn't even know my content one of them
just saw my Lex Friedman episode which
is so crazy that's right that's right
yeah
here's the deal here's the deal virtual
this dude this dude's good at chess now
squeak just gets white so I'm hoping for
something
you know squeaky to happen if you know
what I'm talking about but um
I don't know that it's going to be the
case because virtual seems to be getting
better as the event goes on and Levy I
think you were right he's uh he's
destined he's destined to win the whole
thing and then maybe challenge the
winner of the championship bracket live
in LA twist ending it goes down Gotham
chess commentary in a world
sorry
what what is happening what I don't know
what I'm supposed to respond to that so
I'm gonna get time I could sip of my
coffee and let you touch take a sip of
your coffee Levy Levy Gotham chess Levy
Gotham
is uh it's harder I will say this you
predicted less moves in this one because
the chess was better so you were because
he's better than I am
virtual is a better chess player than me
well virtual is now black will squeaks
be a better chess player than he was in
game one we're gonna find out
um by the way thanks for being here
everybody we've got we've got another
match after this and maybe more we can't
officially confirm just yet
but we may have a lot of Chess ahead
today so don't go anywhere Danny and I
might play a game or two that's right we
could just play that match I'll be frank
you'll be xqc whoever wins just
uh that's actually that's actually a
good idea we'll just we'll flip it we'll
flip a coin for colors and we'll just
dive in yeah
a lot of people going live right now
because title Tuesday has just begun but
stick with us right here a lot of Chess
happening in the world and guess what
we've got an Italian of four nights
Bishop C4
H6 from virtual to avoid the uh the the
move Knight G5 and and squeaks has his
biggest Advantage he's had all day you
think virtual is familiar with the new
kind of like hyper modern approach to
playing the Italian Danny where you
allow white to Castle and you play like
D6 and H6 and then you play like a
little G5 action is that what he's doing
if he turns H6 into that I will just
walk out I I'm not kidding like if he if
he doesn't Castle short and plays D6
here and launches the modern sort of way
that a lot of the top Grand Masters are
playing this G5 move I'll lose my mind
I'll lose my mind I think he's gonna
Castle probably but I I yeah G5 would be
insane and it's it's not easy to deal
with with white
um you have to be sophisticated you have
to like prevent the attack then you have
to capitalize on the weak central
squares before black is able to just
quickly Castle queenside I've played
like this with black a little bit
because I I don't like E4 E5 so I try to
be deviant I try to play and he does
Castle but
um that would have been so basically
H6 was played for the reason that most
Mortals play it which is to stop Knight
G5 and Castle short and as Levy's
highlighting and or Bishop G5 but yes if
those of you who are watching are maybe
ambitious about your chess goals and you
want to look into that there's this very
modern sort of backed by the machine
learning AI overlords that govern the
game that shows that black can play this
very accelerated H6 G5 plan anyway all
right here we go back to back to normal
chess Pawn champs yeah that trade is bad
for black uh because it allows white to
have too much dominant control of the
center and opens up the f file it's it's
bad for black at this level I mean it's
about equal but I I wouldn't have I
wouldn't have done that um
kind of as you get better intermediate
should learn to rock back and keep the
tension but the squeaks know that his
best idea here is to go out and then use
the f file put the Knight on F5 I do not
know we are about to find out
I like how you said that as beginners
come in intermediates they learn to roll
back you know like lean back you know
like that's like a move like a dance
move you learn is also the right move in
in in chess yeah lean back like in
boxing you know you don't just have to
put your gloves up you know you can
slide out of the way little distance
management you know he'll duck under hit
him with the uppercut who much has
boxing Danny where are you chest boxing
or I mean we should talk about this uh
soon
um because I might have a chess boxing
date
when when things are announced we're
gonna find out um we'll see we'll see
just a little teaser I don't know I
don't know who knows let's go let's go
see what squeaks is saying
it's great oh my God
yeah what's he saying
he was talking a second ago he played
Knight D5
[Music]
slowly marked her way up
this would make this hang though so not
that way
the classical music continues
[Music]
interesting
I don't know if that was correct
don't I take with my Pawn or my Bishop
probably my Bishop because then I'm
threatening
[Music]
I take with my Pawn
no Bishop because even if he moves here
yeah I think Bishop's correct I'm not
sure
control Etc you have
the lights what would Yoda say about
this position Yoda would say something
side leads to attacks attacks lead to
hate and hate leads to destruction
yeah
I like that
sounds like an average
[Music]
no
I I was gonna say something but this is
a PG program maybe I would say it on my
own stream
um yeah no
um
if I go here he takes
don't open the center when your piece he
thinks I'm gonna move my knight
right
no one's thinking that nope
beginners fall for that a lot they think
oh he thinks trust me nobody thinks
about anything at all
it's the same mistake as if chess well
if he does that then I'll get this and
so you base an entire plan on the big if
and uh
you know as a wise man once said if my
dog was a cat how good next move would
be this I think Danny if my Grandma had
Wheels she would be a bike
I can never say that and keep a straight
face it's just such a ridiculous thing
out of here oh yeah there's a more rated
R version of that but we'll let it go
um the uh my Grandma had Wheels okay
okay Bob let's go back to that
chessboard here we got uh yeah yeah I I
uh I love this position and actually if
uh if Bishop takes Knight like a virtual
bass is this whole thing on a what if
and accidentally gets himself into a
position where his f-file is just
open for business F7 can be that's a
terrible move that is
oh my goodness I mean already Bishop F7
is possible
I I don't think squeaks will see it but
that is a move that is neglectful of
everything Levy was highlighting that
the f file is about to be a real problem
and there you go if he sees Bishop takes
F7 as Levy is showing this is a it's a
party yeah I don't think he will but
there's also moves like C3 which
even that's I don't think this isn't a
bad move at all yeah I don't hate that
Tate a little snap take little F7 Action
Pawn C3 White is you give Magnus this
position against any top 20 player in
the world and uh and and they tap out
Force win and look at the clock and look
at the clock so I know we're applauding
virtual for good reason he's a player
virtual is a player who's here's here's
I think I will describe it I'm actually
learning how to figure this out almost
at the end of POG Champs love you yeah
virtual ceiling might be the highest of
any player in the field not just the
consolation bracket his ceiling when
he's playing well but he's also I've
seen it I I've actually commentated I
think on more of his matches than others
I've seen him just weather through
playing too fast or neglect so while his
ceiling may be high here's a game where
squeaks apparently much lower rated is
up a minute and a half on the clock in a
fantastic position and there's a reason
we've seen him lose some games so
obviously squeaks can be his Own Worst
Enemy here and start falling apart but
that that's what I would say virtual
ceiling may be the highest but his
consistency is what is what landed him
in the consolation bracket or his lack
thereof yeah well he he lost two
playoffs right so the the less time you
start with the like if he had two more
rapid games against those guys who knows
right that's that's the crazy thing and
uh yeah I I think virtual didn't make it
out of the group because sapnap and gas
they were just incredibly clutch
but uh and he and and squeaks does take
and now virtual has to take with a pawn
yeah I I agree oh see oh
will squeak cd5
will squeak cd5 and just for all the
beginners in the chat D5 is an extremely
easy move to spot in every single
position a move happens you go what's
their threat Rook takes Pawn
he didn't even have to he played it he
cut me off
um yeah you you don't guard this you go
do I have checks captures or attacks you
don't react to this
you go do I have checks captures attacks
no checks no captures how can I attack
something boom look at chat stealing my
line Fork Town population virtual
virtual is it virtual or virtual spell
it correct let's listen in it's it's
virtual he has a w in the beginning to
indicate that he wins a lot but not this
game maybe
oh that was stupid okay
I think I'm doing it
Let's uh let's try to play faster
that sounds bad but I'm I'm serious
because uh I want to put him in a
pressure
down a piece up a pawn or two I believe
I like this move
and since these are connected and
they're in the middle it's not that
terrible actually
but I gotta make a pawn storm
the entire idea is if you're up pawns
you have to make them novels
go drive the car into the office
once
I just don't want to show people you got
them you don't want to show people the
Lamborghini Urus right that's you don't
want them to get jealous I should just
advance I think no no it's that's a Ford
Explorer with excellent gas mileage
we've got that Ford Flex Fuel right
family car look at that that's DJ got
something that I can push yo DJ Gotham
[Music]
I wanted to
wait sorry did he just hang his oh no
he's playing C5 he's playing better than
here but it if squeaks plays there he
could get his Knight trapped
so virtual on to a good idea here Queen
D5 after oh my God's crazy
that's true
can I drop it you can go here
he's almost trapped
he has one Escape Square
or he can protect it
it's from Hotline Miami the game I just
found that out myself nobody told me
nobody told me that Hotline Miami
he sees Queen D5 that's ridiculous
starts to get weird that's yeah like a
squeak sequence D5 let's go let's go
back and listen to squeaks if we can we
make a Switcheroo yeah I'll have to
change my
yeah yeah we'll change back to um Levy
with other glasses for classical music
Miami's popping off they got messy
that's gonna be a crazy City over the
next few years
so annoying
that was so annoying
I really like squeaks I don't know why
he's got an adorable dork brand going I
think I relate to it it's kind of like
me he's just like an adorable dork
remember I love it
I somehow go like this doing the shows
[Music]
who says cablamo besides dads in the 90s
it's a kablama moment
I believe
oh man
it's like if he set something up and
he's not precise it's game ogre
yeah Bazinga might as well say bazinga
kablamo
Chad chat gets it or sometimes Chad gets
me most of the time chat doesn't really
get anything but today they get me
if I go there he's gonna move here
okay so he's not game ogre
oh all right well I gotta I gotta do
some analysis I really hope he doesn't
play Knight B7 that will be extremely
tragic he he still can survive his
Knight is actually not trapped if black
tries to trap his Knight like this uh it
is trapped but white has Queen D5 and
it's not trapped and isn't Knight
trapped if it's trapped but not trapped
and there's only one way to untrap the
Trap Knight what do you think if if a
tree falls in a forest
how much wood could a woodchuck chuck if
a knight could get trapped in a corner
four
wow that was the correct answer by the
way he played queen of three look at
this though this is well timed moves
from squeaks pressure yeah here you go
Rook D1 you've got you're hitting the F7
Pawn
I'm digging it for isn't it Rook D1 has
a very stealthy threat of Queen takes E4
and that is what the kids call a cablamo
the the kids are the dads from the 90s
but yeah we get it kids
dads Rook D1 little rookie one let me
see that let me see that this is what I
call bring in all the friends to the
party you can't go to the party unless
you invite all your friends unless one
of them is an introvert and you have to
convince them a little bit and then they
lie to get out of it and then they
complain that they have fomo not
speaking from experience don't speak
just
wow that got deep really fast there okay
yeah
I don't know it was just a hypothetical
I'm just saying hey I feel you on that
um
the uh the move Knight B3 threatens a
fork on C5 that would be a big forking
mistake
the virtual misses it we might have to
change his name from virtual to Virtual
you see how I replace the W with an L
yes it yeah because the W implies he
wins but the L implies he loses and you
know since his whole name is predicated
upon that yeah that makes a lot of sense
you know my first name starts
that's what I'm saying he has the
capability of the highest player he has
the capability of the highest player but
this is why he's here I'm just trying to
I'm trying to defend the bracket because
I feel like a magnifier you know you
know what I think I think he kind of
reminds me of of the of the the Warriors
in 2016 was it 15 2016 14 LeBron LeBron
the three one three one yeah
the great the greatest regular season
team of all time yeah finals
but we'll see Danny Danny it's not over
it's it's not over even this game's not
over
yeah
Knight takes C5 though what a fork we
can listen into either one of the
players if you'd like production take it
away roll the dice pick your flavor I'd
move my queen here
does he realize how winning he is
I don't know
does it realize
move my queen
yeah he sees it he's highlighted on the
boys
he's not getting excited yet
dude I think he's focused he wants it
he's not getting excited because he's
like he's taking this seriously two and
a half minutes
I thought track Mania players are
supposed to go fast what's going on
it was gonna be easy what's going on
look at the dress truck is this virtual
that's right Mania player
I love this guy I love squeaks oh that's
what yep he takes
just take the Rook bro just take the
road just take the damn Rook think later
take the Rook
something that he didn't even consider
no don't do things he didn't consider
take the Rook
Jesus Oh Queen B3 Queen creepy three
queens are off the board if he sees
Queen to B3 this is why he's a
speedrunner squeaks has gotten better go
ahead it's the only check in the
position which is why you have to look
for checks oh
Queen
bazinga kablamo
thank you oh my goodness oh my goodness
Danny he's that's it it's a home stretch
he's gonna eat he's gonna eat the pawns
he just has to stop that pawn it's over
activate
two and a half minutes bucko
he's Ballin and he's trash talking oh
this is this is sick
then he he check he can't mess this up I
I don't even yeah that's a bad check
yeah but that's the only way he could
try to mess this up is is bad checks but
yeah you're right if I go here all right
let's bring us back to the analysis
report so we can show you the only
possible way that squeeze could throw
this game no and then pre and then it's
going to be a premonition the only way
he can lose this is if he moves this
Rook up literally and even then the pawn
does not sneak through because the root
can come back or this Rook can come back
and he would lose a rook he needs to put
the rook in front of the pawn and stop
this Intruder yeah all right that's what
he's got to do now virtual might help
him because he's going to go here and
that would be a big mistake by virtual
he should actually keep this Bond here
and Hope
that squeaks does something like this
because he's like oh I'm gonna go get
the king and then
your ability to crawl inside the mines
although there you go squeaks crawling
outside of his own bad beginner mind and
inside to the mind of uh I mean honestly
he's played at least 1 000 level in this
game squeaks is squeaks is absolutely
playing great chess oh look at him build
the Fortress so the black king can't
enter F5 but now he's gonna bring this
Rook back nope nope nope back to
beginner back to beginner back to
beginner oh my goodness King to G2 oh
God Danny
he better play King G2 and not give some
sort of useless check oh my oh my God he
called it I knew it oh no
oh my God he's going to win the game
he's going to win the game with the
other one this is so stupid this is
insane
[Laughter]
oh my God that the whole thing falls
apart that's why you don't give checks
don't give checks for no reason that was
a stupid check
so Ma and it's over it's just over F4F I
mean it's unbelievable it's just gonna
push the pawns not even complicated he's
gonna play F4 F3 Danny
yep that is absolutely insane you called
it you said he's gonna give random
checks and now now that's it I mean it's
still a draw it's still a draw but but
it's he's blocking his own Rook he's
blocking his own Rook I mean it's just
when Levy has to walk away agree chat
you know you know you've done wrong this
is insane but you could see it coming
and this is where amateurs like H4 was a
useless check helps the king Rook A4
useless check he literally lost this
game by playing useless checks let it be
a lesson to you all
I want to hear what he says though
because I want to know that he I want to
see when the moment comes
how do I stop this you think you can't
stop it
if I go here
[Music]
his next move is going to be here
oh my God wait he can check me at me
like this
[Music]
oh my God Rook A3 is actually probably
the best chance he goes here
I can't take
it I can go there
[Music]
it's the only move I think it's if he
goes here
[Music]
well okay let's yeah let's come back
maybe
um
he found it he found it yeah
yeah I just want to show this the reason
why Rook A3 is still losing is because
black can play E2 but black cannot play
F2 because of the pin which is why it's
actually a really clutch defensive move
but the winning move by black is Rook D7
because you cannot stop Rook D1 or F2
and if you do this with the pin you
still get mated it's absolutely brutal
virtual might find it but he might stop
himself and go wait a minute I can't go
F2 so let's see King G1 and and and will
virtual basically just be like oh Rook
D7 if takes I have made
let's go to Virtual virtual and see
let's see Judy just found Rook D7 dude
just we couldn't even get there fast
enough he found Rook D7 we're gonna see
it in real time from his View
right so now
I think the move is here
I think this is the move
wow does he see Rook take spawn
oh might just be accidental genius
but the pawn is pinned
yeah I don't think he sees it but it may
not matter I'm threatening this if a
rook here can I still play it
no I cannot
like if he goes here I can play this
move again
yep you see that that's the idea yeah
now I think I can play this
King has to move
and at least win one Rook back what's
the what's the status line
one two three four one two
three four okay I can at least secure a
draw I think this move
King has to move
takes
he'll find it yep Rook takes squeaks
through
King here I think that's it
he threw hard everything there Rook D1
all forced everything is forced every
every one of white schools is the only
legal move now
make a night
yeah
he's king of two oh even even better
than Rook D1 I mean it's not Rook d1's
better but still just fantastic chess I
think I win
dude this is this has been the
condensation
he plays so well he's still coming
through next move Queen but poor squeaks
oh my God I think that's us going to La
this looks so good
but my God what a game I think this is
winning though I don't see how he
defends
oh my God
oh my God I think that yeah okay he's
gonna try if he moves one more I capture
I can take now
yeah okay let's make it simple
wow
wow wow
and just like that
hog Champs Goes Up In Smoke
just a matter of time
I'll put more checks and a mate will be
the Classic Lottery
yeah yeah I think H5 Queen F5 made one
is there amazing one Queen instead
go find him wow oh my God
we're going to
[Music]
Los Angeles
to play the over the board final what a
game I was so far down but the pawns
were Unstoppable
oh my God guys we're going to the way
I can't believe it I thought I was
throwing this entire game when I blended
my pieces
I've never seen someone so excited to go
to the city with the most traffic in the
world the worst traffic in the world but
he is pumped Jokes Aside you got to be
happy for him
virtual I tried to replace the W with an
L it didn't work out virtual is virtual
for a reason he gets the dove Levy and
he's headed to LA
listen I'm not even gonna say I'm biased
against every one of his opponents it's
no disrespect to him I'm supposed to be
a professional commentator but I'll be
the Charles Barkley I'll sit here and
say we all are cheering for squeaks we
were all cheering for saikuno and we
will all cheer for Cutie Cinderella
because this is a travesty this man is
too good at chess Danny he had his dark
moments and he still managed to win a
rook end game up he was down to Rook
Danny he was in a rook end game and he
had one less of the Rooks and he won the
damn game it's it's not supposed to
happen like that he's too good
oh I agree let's look at the bracket
let's see where he's at as you know
already he's joining cutie Cinderella in
La you can look at both of these players
in the path they took to get their cutie
take down Ginny and daily dose virtual
takes down saikuno and squeaks and there
you have it the consolation bracket
final will be live in Los Angeles this
time next week we will be there it's
going to be epic
um no not this time next week it's in
like 10 days
I like to say roughly this time next you
know I'm a big I'm a big approximate
kind of guy
um that's true you know
all I know is it's in La you don't want
to miss it just like you fans don't want
to miss your chance to take advantage of
two weeks of diamond membership status
on chess.com all you have to do is use
the command drops if you've been
watching chess during POG Champs then
you already did what you need to do
you've already watched two hours of
Chess in the chess category so now if
you use the command drops you link up
your account on chess.com with twitch
and you get two weeks of diamond so do
it do it right now use the command don't
go anywhere as well because we're going
to catch it with the players but don't
don't do anything before you activate
your diamond and connect your account on
chess.com there's virtual doing the
pull-ups he did
he'll be joining us along with squeaks
for an interview don't go anywhere POG
Champs 5 returns in just a moment
[Music]
this is a very sad story
oh
my God
oh my God why am I trying to get all
this is where I was just about to say it
and it happened so fast oh my God today
we're gonna go down into the New York
City subway set up a table on the subway
platform and see if we get some
strangers waiting for their trains to
play chess with us
foreign
[Music]
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good got the chess.com app
give or play on your phone oh yeah he
said he barely played I'm a teacher what
do you teach chess I'm just kidding
self-defense how do you stay sane I used
to do a lot of meditation
take medication
what's like lesson 101 of self-defense
one what are you listening to right now
train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran what is the meaning
of life it's funny because like what I'm
doing I feel like doesn't align with my
philosophy on what the meaning of life
is but it's like obviously spend as much
time with family as possible the best
person you can be get closer to God not
to be evil to each other
[Applause]
I'll see you in a self-defense class
enjoy Harry Styles
foreign
[Music]
Highway
s
[Music]
foreign
Champs 5 our second competitor who will
join us in Los Angeles is now known to
the world he is right there virtual
defeat squeaks by a 2-0 score but man
was it close those push-ups those
pull-ups were pretty good form though I
will say that so uh virtual let's talk
about the pull-ups
um where'd you learn that form
I mean
that was it was actually part of my prep
so we didn't prep that many moves but we
prepped the pull-ups to intimidate
squeaks on the break so like okay well
oh he's doing pull-ups like he's he's
way too confident and then squeeze I
don't want to ouch
squeaks I don't want out you but you got
a winning advantage and you started
talking all types of mad trash it was it
was first of all it was adorable when a
guy's dorky as he was talking that much
trash it's like me because I'm also
dorky and and you were talking so much
trash and then you completely threw dude
what happened
Danny first of all speaking of dorky
there's no jobs when we're playing chess
all right like why are we acting like
there's like some sort of Varsity
Letterman's jacket we're all dorks and
weebs here and I'm not gonna be
intimidated by The Jock of Chess By
doing pull-ups like I'm pretty strong
too I don't want to brag but you know
I'm working uh I'm working with uh you
can show guns on camera no guns on
camera
wait true so I mean
is shaking in his boots he barely won
that second game I was getting all types
of stressed I was very confident then
you started playing sick moves and I'm
like this is this is falling apart this
is going I'm going under
yeah that was exciting end game really
exciting game how dare you here you did
you did play phenomenal chess dude that
that game is white literally until two
moves you played a dumb check with your
pawn and then you checked him with the
rook and you literally walked his King
into a winning Advantage you were
winning and then you walked his King
into a winning advantage
I mean honestly Danny it came down to
reps like I just started playing chess a
week ago and I haven't practiced with
like very few pieces so oftentimes
something I need to work on is I find
myself in like those late games the
massive advantage and all I'm thinking
in my brain is like don't be cringe but
sometimes the cringe just creeps up on
me and I can't help it but to throw it
all away uh so that's something that I
definitely have to uh practice doing I
did notice that virtual is doing the
ponziani so I'm guessing once again that
you watched it that was also impressed
you knew D4 or D5 was to move there move
three he knows the prep
listen the best move it was played by by
squeaks and then and then a lot of
questions questionable moves replace
squeaks for example actually virtual
accidentally got a losing position in
five moves with the ponziani I saw I saw
that I saw that
it's okay
chess is won and lost in the middle game
and end game and we saw that today and
it was a uh it was a beautiful fight
virtual I I I saw you at the at the
streamer Awards was that your only time
in Los Angeles because we have cutie
Cinderella your your next opponent she's
saying La is dangerous like there's a
lot of crime cars are being so she's in
the chat right now yeah she won so oh
she won so she's confirmed the opponent
that's gonna be interesting I've been to
La a few times but it's often like if
it's twitch cons or streamer boards and
stuff like that so
um I'm gonna be back but then there's a
trek manual like two days after so I
can't stay for long so hopefully I won't
see any of the dangerous stuff
they'll just be come through play Chasco
home efficient yes tournaments are some
of the most dangerous places known to
man like I'm I'm ready to tell you with
cutie there it's going to be next level
um
squeaks I do want to I do want to
complete the circle in our relationship
because I feel like I've made fun of you
in some of these interviews I want you
to know like I actually have become a
huge fan and I'm just giving you a hard
time I've been no I've been really
impressed you got a lot better over the
last few weeks and you really were this
close to sending this thing to tie break
so thanks for doing this and I hope you
what are your final thoughts
um on on your pogchamps five campaign
I think I a lot of people underestimated
me okay both xqc and tyler1 said I was
the worst chess player in the tournament
and here I am sitting in the hot seat
and where are they you know what I mean
so in all intents and purposes I'm
sitting further than both of those bozos
so frankly I'm very happy with my
journey I went really far and I hope to
continue my uh chess uh Adventure
who do you think wins it all who do you
think wins it all in the uh consolation
and the overall
oh without a doubt work drool because
cutie said I was bad at chess
a lot of resentment and also cutie
saying that La is dangerous like guys
this is a threat
like you don't understand Judy is going
to attack virtual but I'm rooting for
virtual because I Harbor so I never
forget and I never forgive
what about champions championship
bracket or or do you not you don't care
about them because oh the Champions
bracket wait who's in it probably uh
yeah
exactly sure all right
here's the one we care about exactly
well
um virtual we didn't necessarily budget
to bring someone in from Norway like I
said I'm gonna hit up your DMs we'll
figure out a way to make this work don't
worry we'll figure out a way to make it
happen you know are you saying you
didn't think I was gonna go this far
Danny are you are you there we've
already got my team looking on the
discounted route it it sends you through
Dubai if you're okay with that you go to
Dubai it's not a big deal we'll get you
here as long as you leave tomorrow we'll
get you here by next week all right but
Jokes Aside squeaks you were awesome
thank you so much I hope you continue
speed running chess uh virtual we'll see
you in La bro
we'll see you it'll be exciting I'm
looking forward to it
all right so guys thank you all
appreciate it
good match thank you so much guys
[Music]
thank you
Christ God damn it Connor why are you
why are you making this so hard
dude this entire thing has been pressure
I put it on myself man come on
[Applause]
what we can do Tyler is if I were in the
next round and I get into the finals you
just turn up to the finals
that's great it's uh it's win-win
wow certified
eliminated
[Music]
two matches are in the books and guess
what boys and girls we have two matches
ahead not just the one you know you were
waiting for with I did a thing in Sea
Dog but we can confirm that Felix is
awake he's alive and well and we're
gonna have xqc versus Frank at some
point today Levy
yes we will but first
but first we've got Sea Dog and I did a
thing Connor and Alex that was a great
setup man I almost missed the dunk it's
like you gave me such an assist that I
almost missed the dunk that I recovered
we've got two great matches ahead thanks
for for being with us everybody we
already know who will be playing in LA
from the consolation bracket it's time
to find out who will be playing in the
championship bracket I think it actually
kind of worked out I think Felix did
this on purpose I think as you see
overslept just so he could be the
dramatic moment of finding out who the
final person is going to LA
yeah
yeah that was the that was the plan the
good news is that this is a very
exciting semi-final this is like
football World Cup style all four teams
have a chance no idea literally not a
clue what happens in the matchup between
Frank and xqc and if it happens today
and hopefully it does uh and I did a
thing versus sea dog is also very
unpredictable because I did a thing can
play up to a very high level and CDOT
can play up to a very high level but
they're both human beings there's a lot
of pressure on the line and we are
actually looking in right now at there
he is that was Alex and here's and
here's Connor so I agree with what you
said they're both very good chess
players probably the best two chess
players left in the event but they're
both humans and this is rapid chess and
it's POG Champs and anything can happen
it's also early in uh in Japan and
Australia respectively with where these
two guys are at so uh so we'll see if
they've brought their best just this
morning for them they're already in
August 9th Levy they're playing from the
future they literally are playing from
the future we're in the past it is
August 9th for them August 8th for us
how does that for for a mind trip you
like that that's crazy it's like it is
lit it is literally crazy that there are
people on the planet that are 13 hours
ahead like how have they not made all
the right investing decisions and
lottery numbers I mean it's it's
completely insane and the thing is you
know Danny um I did a thing could be
could not even be in the same time zone
if he's in Western Australia he is in
the same time so if he's on the other
side it's another four hours he could be
like 17 hours ahead of New York it's one
of the wildest Things that the the World
Turns and it is round for all you flat
earthers facts uh any Hooters there's
Connor he's playing um he's playing from
Tokyo I believe and let's let's compare
these two guys because I know we still
have Frank and xuc and they'd both like
to have something to say about the fact
that whoever makes it out of those two
might have a chance but I think I think
the winner of this matchup is the clear
favorite in the final Levy
well maybe that's the thing maybe I I
mean uh I this this also might be the
tallest matchup because I think Frank is
over six feet tall xqc is like six seven
I did a thing just looks huge and
Conor's like 511 and if the shortest one
in the group is five eleven six feet
tall
this is going to be a terrifying over
the board matchup no matter what happens
Danny I mean they're going to be
intimidating each other
well we uh I agree and and you know what
okay we're going to talk about xuc and
Frank in a little bit we've got Connor
and Alex starting I was uh
I was uh wanting just to do a little
more of a breakdown of these two players
like we said they're the two highest
rated players at this point
um I've been saying I think Felix could
win the whole thing from the beginning
so I guess I shouldn't back off on my
bet but I do think the way these two
guys have played Conor and Alex I I
don't see anyone playing the quality of
Chess that they have so far so here we
go we're off couldn't agree more and and
chat was claiming I you know I don't
actually know excuses I've seen xqc in
person multiple times and I'm short but
he he is close to seven feet tall he
might even be 610 Danny and and
yeah he's uh he's an intimidating guy
he's intimidated not just because he's a
former professional OverWatch player as
we keep talking about no I'm kidding um
Here
Comes Connor with E4 Here Comes E5 by
Alex now
uh Sea Dog revealed that because these
guys are friends Alex reached out to
Conor was like hey what what are your
openings well that's not a good opening
by Alex yeah what
he's going for some kind of trap with
Queen age awesome Connor might not take
Connor might be thinking
he played that too fast this is some
sort of Gambit I'm just gonna play four
nights if I know anything about Conor
this would be a big character
development if he took this pawn and
then was like I don't think this works
let's let's tune into his stream because
we're about to find out yeah Conor is
thinking about it right now will he take
on E5 hmm
[Music]
hmm
that's interesting already
he doesn't believe it I don't know what
the
I don't think he's gonna do it
[Music]
yeah I tend to
agree with you I think he'll be a little
too nervous at all let's try this
okay
show me some Sea Dog you were right but
it's also not a bad move right it's a
principled move develop in the center
all that stuff yes of course taking the
pawn is 10x better but
literally it is 15 times more seconds
however that would be it would be it was
a 1.50 evaluation
um but this is just a scotch now oh
that's nervous
we're fine let me just enjoy the game
yeah just enjoy the game uh-oh all right
nice oh now we're gonna see was this
part of the master plan is he gonna
bring his Queen out if he plays Queen F6
we're getting close to uh
xqc moist critical clock James one oh my
God no no all right it's too soon Hikaru
it's too soon
we never even reached the climax we
never even reached a climax it's too
soon that's what she said oh my God that
is what she said it was one of the most
insane moments of all time 19 c6's
played oh God oh God
no he's it's okay on to C3 Queen F6 is
literally xqc versus moist critical
yeah I think this works out okay
Connor's gonna take now okay if Alex
plays Queen F6 here
yeah then we lose our
Minds
foreign
[Music]
what's he thinking about I I I I don't I
think we're we have we have too much
knowledge and memories of this position
and we're afraid of of xpc moist
critical Deja Vu I think he's just
literally thinking about how to take
back the night some people don't even
know that that game happened which is
incredible we've had so many different
chess explosions in the last few years
that some people don't even know of xqc
moist critical
we could see it on the live board we
just gotta show it he just played queen
of six
if you've never seen xqc moist critical
stop what you're doing and Google it
right now
who's got this here now
okay
oh my God
he's not gonna choose one thank God
everything's gonna be okay Dan
but it's gonna be okay we did reach a
climax Levy today you and I reached a
climax Levy that you can't say stuff
like that man you can't say stuff like
that man that's not what that means man
oh my God Danny I don't know what you're
talking about there's all kinds of
climactic moments that you and I reach
together this is the only move I have
what's the big deal
uh yeah yeah you're right nah you're
right what would even Robert has say in
this spot I'm used to watching stuff
like that with you and Robert has I
think this is yeah
Robert's traveling the world we love
Robert
um
tracks me maybe they uh
um by the way the most insane thing
about this position is that the position
I'm gonna I'm gonna just show this this
is a real line
um this is a line that comes out of the
scotch Danny you play the scotch Knight
C6 D4 take take
uh and then there's a line Bishop C5
Knight takes C6 where white tries to
play uh BC Bishop D3 in Castle but black
sometimes plays Queen F6 and now the
best move for white is to develop the
queen because actually this Pawn
structure is better for white in the end
game somehow yeah with yep
it's like the
but none of that happened and now this
is the position and um as far as I'm
concerned Danny uh
uh Conor is worse because of this
diagonal three yeah I agree yep but the
game might end after D6 Bishop B5 so I
was gonna say objectively koner is fine
but in the in the in the game of of this
one here the dark squares are really
weak for white so I agree with you but
okay yeah you're right if he plays
Bishop F4 Bishop G5 we we have a chess
game to play
he might he wasn't smart yeah I was
gonna say he he's smart like he's a
smart guy he's gonna go well I can't
Castle this way so
you know let's go that way or he'll go
Queen here Queen here and trade the
bishop he he's a hundred percent either
playing this this and this or trading
the bishop uh
let's let's heat up the volume on Alex
if we can I know he's sitting there
talking to himself but he's been very
entertaining for someone who doesn't
stream he only zooms good
but let's crank up the volume Jerry
come on Alex
Tykes
if I move here
if I push this Pawn
um I mean he's up that side a
little bit but well now we can barely
hear him today
is do I want to open that up and then
Castle the other side not really
um that's what I'm hanging he's thinking
about D6 so he's thinking about G6 it
could be the game
eat is not an option
I want to push it on a castle
so I just ignore it but go up I can't
because I'll block that Queen off from
eating that
castling here
up two or do I just kick the the bishop
kick the bishop
it's weird to kick the bishop
it's not the worst
great move
yeah well wow
taking's a terrible move like yeah
that's positionally speaking very bad
move now this bishop is just a god of
the dark squares
yeah that was a very quick decision from
Conor I wonder what his plan is
is he gonna put the Knight on D5 and
what do I have I just could get wild
yeah and a good way not to play a move
like this just can we bring it back to
the uh big screen you you don't trade
the bishop for the night I say don't
trade the bishop for the night unless
there's a good reason and also don't
trade the bishop for the night if more
of your pawns are on light squares you
have five out of seven pawns on light
squares it means your dark squares are
weak so that's if you showed that move
to like a Soviet chess trainer they
would have a heart attack yeah they just
die on the spot you know this is uh you
get sent straight to Ulen Bard for that
um Knight to D5
is played which by the way is a fork of
the queen and the pawn let's highlight
that because while you're highlighting
Queen takes B2 Alex has to have you know
he has to have the guts to to laugh in
the face of danger of Knight takes C7
yeah Queen B2 and this yeah I don't know
if it's which is the best for black you
give up the rook and now the dark swears
just absolutely fall apart it's like a
mating net here and here at the end of
it you have Queen seeds oh Queen C3 yeah
yeah oh and so nasty if this it's mate
and if this then you take and then you
keep bullying and what has happened by
the way he did go back to C6
uh and now
if Conor finds Bishop B5 I'll do
whatever you want
right here
is Mega bat
uh
I don't know
I'm pretty happy you're not into that
I you're pretty we already
I mean what more do you what more can we
possibly I feel like you just Pat you
pass the test you passed the test you
know
um
what more could could you possibly ask
for
oh my God
he found it
now the crazy thing is that by process
of elimination his opponent is going to
be forced into playing Queen D6 and it's
actually not a good move if Bishop B5 is
not a good move but let's show why he
did it it's crazy if Queen takes B5
this is the idea is the fork on C7 this
is called that is attraction
unbelievable
but as you said Queen D6 is going to be
played and the reason it's so bad for
white is because now there's a threat of
C6 wait we've seen bad moves
Bishop B4 he's trying to deflect the
night the night so Queen takes and
Connor fight he's winning now Connor's
winning Connor found the best move C3
double attack the old-fashioned way the
bishop is attacked the queen is attacked
and you can't defend both pieces oh my
God he got this he got him spooked in it
he got him spooked it was like a boxer
he fainted the punch and there was an
overreaction and he's capitalizing he's
just completely winning now
you missed your chance dude you could
have had me do anything we're talking
like cat mate outfits which I already
know I already owe Andrea one
um so Andrea tried to make make me get a
tattoo of hikaru's name and she doesn't
even know I already have one so it's
like I mean seriously
I got it right above my right right
right like on the on the back side like
you know right on my leg like the target
the target area where like you're you're
you you wear a tummy shirt and it leans
up a little bit and people can see your
sexy tattoo and pink cursive that's what
I'm talking about
all right let's see what Sea Dog's
saying because he must feel like a like
a five head right now dude's playing
like a genius
Bishop
is it with the Knight not the pun yeah
he's got it with the Knight otherwise if
he takes at the pawn then we're right
back to although actually there's a
weird tactic right if you take with the
pawn and he plays C6 there's Knight F6
check I know we should wait because I
don't want to get too far in the head oh
wait no there's nothing tonight no he
doesn't check me and that's defending it
oh oh oh he blunders the fork
okay all right one big threat
nice clean clean
now I just gotta not this up
56 Alex season all right too late
because somewhere we can around
with this and find out
uh no no you only do one of those you
don't okay
you really don't want to do both
right move from Alex some way we can get
out of this I know it
this is great yes by both of them
we just take the pawn huh
uh don't do that
all Advantage gone if he takes he's got
to keep the bishop
okay
gotta keep the bishop you gotta know
here to keep the bishop but he already
gave one up
no respect for the Bishops
uh this could be some of the move
okay he's right back
he should not give up the bishop he
should don't give up the bishop oh my
God
talk about his Turtle room it's all
Advantage gun all of it all Advantage is
gone let me let me let me show this on
the big screen uh first of all Connor
hates Bishops I mean just the heinous
disrespect to these incredible creatures
which just can snipe the entire distance
of a board
and
he had to go here or at the very least
he had to retreat the night so that he
could take back but the way he's done it
is that now he has to retreat again and
he's going to lose a pawn he's not going
to have any material advantage and black
is going to Castle and have no
weaknesses Danny well plus he took on C6
which helped the bishop develop right so
at this level taking c6d takes CC
exactly so it's like you you help your
opponent double with that move
um and there's a reason the eval bar has
gone from White's winning to back to
totally unclear so it you know it's not
over but the thing I'm most worried
about now Levy is the fact that he's
down on the clock his Advantage has
completely evaporated and uh that I have
a feeling this match is going to give us
tiebreakers though I feel like no matter
how we get there these two guys are
destined for a lot of Chess they are
very close
correct I completely agree the position
is also no longer congested I mean he
snapped that so fast that's that's
ridiculous but you know he's Australian
he's got 20 20 eyesight you needed to
Spearfish the way he does uh no Danny
it's still complex like Queen here in
Long Castle but
Queen here's public in the short Castle
I don't know
as long as he doesn't hitting B2 though
it's still complex enough to say we have
a game so okay good he played Queen D2
if if Conor had hung B2 he does not
deserve to go to La like let's be
serious 11 1100 you know you got to
guard that
um yeah now castles Bishop E6
is that's it this is game on and black
is better
black is Castle black is better
will which side does White Castle too I
mean the safe decision is to Castle
short and not risk the bishop coming to
E6 in the attack but
uh I don't know what Connor wants
well knowing him he'll spend two minutes
and 50 seconds to figure it out but he's
just made a move
okay the castle
oh this is going to be Black's next move
he's definitely gonna play Bishop E6
that's a sign of like uh early
intermediate player just getting out the
bishop
and because you know you know that's
what you have to do like you don't need
to give these checks
yeah
good move he also the one thing for Alex
dude is he's playing fast
playing quick
good stuff I think he does know that
Conor plays slowly and he's just
trusting himself you know who did this
Eric Rosen did this against me he just
played fast it was extremely frustrating
because I I had a feeling I was having
good positions but all of a sudden I was
down two three minutes on the clock in a
five minute game and that's what sea dog
is doing right now he's pulling a Gotham
and you know you don't want really want
to do that sometimes so damn you Eric
Rosen damn you all right let's see what
Alex has to say
to the check isn't the worst position
because at least he has to respond and
he can't do much he might just move his
Queen
down I think I'm gonna do the check
across
do what he does if he just means he's
King back I'm coming Rook out
dude night dude Queen across isn't he
eating the worst here by the way good
chest here I kind of like Queen across
maybe I just bring Castle across first
piss him off then Queen across
then we're going Queen across
I would love to draw what he's saying
but he doesn't speak in coordinates he
just says a cross that could be there
there
look at that though that's like uh oh
you just drew it sideways Right Moves do
it again yeah
sideways Triton
I don't know Chad I don't know how to
move my queen is sideways beat right now
shot
I don't know oh dude that was a great
impression Danny uh con responds are
excited seriously sideways peaked
sideways beat he's low on his low
on time Todd is really low on time
Queen across
isn't the worst
um
could go Queen across I'm not really
threatening anything yet because he's
Queen's there
I think that's what he's saying but I
don't know
I mean yeah
or I could just start pushing this up
but that doesn't really do anything
either
going across it's crazy if he's thinking
of F5 that's pretty crazy Queen across
here
getting his other rook in the game I
would have played F5 that would have
been my move like in this position
because it just seems very natural and
uh it's kind of nice if he doesn't take
you you can always play F4 after which
you have a nice space control what's
crazy though is in the live position if
Connor sees F4 himself now dude F4 F5
yeah he's nice just like that
yeah I push but Conor's getting low on
time this is all going to come down to
Conor versus two opponents I did a thing
and the clock
I don't know if we can go check in on
what Conor is thinking but it would be
great because he's gotta go fast he's
not he's not talking much but he's
thinking a lot probably a bad
combination and he's just played a move
Connor is oh no that's not losing that's
okay let's let's push this Pawn will
Alex hold on
we're going to counter here
we'll see if Alex finds Rook T2 I'm
taking too long
oh gonna hurry up
damn I had this
wow it's funny is he's kind of rooting
for Conor to play faster
I know
huge moment Rook teacher oh he sees it
himself
oh oh he got lucky Rook D2 wasn't played
yup now he's Gotta Move Knight G3
crazy
2 was a crazy move
foreign
[Music]
all right let's bring it back to the to
the big board here
um he did avoid disaster but he does
have 49 seconds on the clock uh he gave
a check
and
now Rook D2 is no longer a thing but
Bishop D3 is is I would not have pinned
myself that yeah that's actually huge
for Connor
did you play 51 quickly Knight G3 Rook
D1 like okay I love this movie did he
play it or did you highlight it did no
no he played it he played it okay I
think this is a great move stops Bishop
D3 grabs the default Rook F7 was a
really bad practical decision to
self-pin that is a problem
the very good news for black is you
can't exploit it even if you trade and
black plays something like Queen F6 to
enable the movement of his King again or
his Rook afterward there's no way to
exploit it Rook D7 rook d8 and Rook D6
don't work B7 is protected by the pin
Rook it's really unfortunate but yep I
think the momentum is swinging back to
Sea Dog
I have no idea these two guys are super
evenly matched
yeah Queen F6 would be a great idea as
you're highlighting to guard The Rook
but we'll see if he realizes how much
danger he could be in if he doesn't
guard The Rook
because everything you said is true
there wow he just played queen of six
wow yeah he played Queen F6 and uh that
that just spotting that he might also be
oh oh Queen B2 Bishop B6 and Queen B
six is winning
four was not ideal
he he he's yeah Jenny I'm just gonna say
he's trying to get aggressive but
subtle defensive movement that's it it's
the time pressure too the problem with
G4 is it reflects Panic
Tanner not Tanner not Tanner Connor is
down on the clock so he looks for an
aggressive move which is a reason why
all you viewers the reason you avoid
time pressure is not always because
you'll lose on time but you make worse
moves when you have less time because
you panic and this is it look at Alex
plays Bishop B6 he's gonna win the game
one this is a very bad spot to be in
so what am I doing here do I do a queen
trade no maybe not
uh let's do something let's do something
here do I kick his Rook away
do I kick his Rook kicking The Rook is
not the worst I don't know what he's
talking about no that was done that was
not ideal that was not ideal I mean
we're threatening you oh
I hate endgame
immediately oh we're we've gone to eval
bar heart attack mode oh my god oh my
god
dude I went from applauding these guys
chess skill and they have been very good
to just this has been a blunderfest uh
Conor's gonna win Conor's gonna win very
easy Knight F4 push the pawns Danny two
Pawns in a night it's just a fortress I
mean you just play Knight F4
and oh my God Danny Danny H4 King H5
King G3 Knight F4 made King H5 King g394
mate oh he's gonna beat him he's gonna
bait himself
that's fine for me maybe I just push
another Pawn
okay but luckily he's he's still gonna
lose I think yeah I think so
all right let's see what Conor's
thinking now that he maybe has survived
the worst blunders he's made in POG
Champs oh my goodness yeah the Knight
and two pawns are too strong
yeah he's just dead silent dead focused
he wants it he
he sees it any experience any
experienced player knows that the
configuration here the Knight and the
two passers are just completely winning
just H5 don't even think about it it's
H5
become a queen when he gets to the
eighth rank only the pawns can become
Queens come on H5
I mean okay he's still winning but it's
it's he's he's gonna make it harder for
himself if he doesn't get the pawns
rolling yep
oh you can't get his King in it's not
possible pawns stop the king yeah B5 oh
God Danny this is not over
do not play Knight E5 oh my God he
almost just wondered his Knight will
move
yeah keep your king off lights course
please as the ship can only play on the
light squares
black should not let in the king like
she just
nauseous if black sits tight here Conor
doesn't seem to have the right plan just
don't play C4 check
yep just let him in just let him in now
it's easy
it's actually the same lesson that
squeaks learned against uh virtual these
these these don't check without a
purpose everybody
because those are often moves you can't
take back
and that's it I mean the bishop cannot
touch any pawn every white piece is on
the dark Square now
yeah there's almost nothing that Connor
can blunder into anymore every piece is
on a dark Square
yeah he's just gonna go to B6 and gather
the pawn
and and black can't even push his pawns
are set up in such a way that that you
cannot Advance at all so
just gonna go go get him
Conor's not giving us a lot he's he's in
the zone
by the way
you
you know what's hilarious
about what could happen if Bishop C8
King C7 happens unfortunately we have to
go back to the analysis board
because if he plays King C7 like he's
about to do there's a hilariously
instructive idea Levy
oh it doesn't matter he belong to the
bishop yeah there was A5 King C B4 and
actually uh black is winning
can you imagine
oh my God and then that wasn't out of
the question because Alex almost could
have accidentally figured that out but
instead instead after King C7 he
panicked and gave up his bishop and now
now it really is over Conor's gonna get
the dub
yeah
that would have been this is it actually
is instructive I know that seemed like
hard engine stuff to find in end games
it doesn't matter how many poles you
have or sometimes how many pieces you
have what matters is who gets a queen
first so that A5 B4 idea is really
instructive to not be not ever fall
asleep on past Pawns
it's over now no no it's it's over the
only chance we have a stalemate uh which
could happen in some weird configuration
as the king is surrounded by the pawns
but um
that was crazy Sea Dog was actually
staring at a 0-1 deficit and a loss with
white
and it looks like he will survive
Alex hasn't shut up the whole time and
Conor's the One streaming and I don't
think he said a word in five minutes
so that's how it would be
that would be there's a pawn there it
goes
yeah Alex can't believe it
I wonder where he thinks it went wrong
because he seems very devastated but
it's been tough for a very long time uh
the the solutions of in between move
Rook takes D1 was
unreal
well it all goes back to like there's a
reason when you hear your chess coaches
out there viewers say checks captures
Queen attacks it doesn't go captures
checks Queen attacks you start with
checks first because the reason Alex
missed that is because he instantly
recaptured instead of looking for the
check every position your order of
priority the hierarchy of moves is
checks and then captures
and Alex did not follow that plan by the
way okay
okay can we turn off Alex because he's
kind of fist this is sort of funny
Connor doesn't know how to mate with the
king and a queen but what happened there
either that or he's trying to torture
him he's gonna make a knight
oh
no okay I wanted to hear what these guys
were saying but we missed this is
stalemate by the way oh okay yeah he
he's he's gonna go for it okay he did it
is it over it's over that's it
that's it good work
oh my goodness what a heart
attack of the game holy moly I need a
coffee
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
I don't even think he knows what a heart
attack of the game it was that he was
losing in one move multiple times yet he
somehow comes away with the dub takes a
1-0 lead over his friend I did a thing
Levy
that was Sensational that was a uh a
fantastic cutaway as he yelled holy moly
what the
I need a coffee
that was that was pretty awesome
um wow well let's unpack what we just
saw there I mean
um two very good chess players the two
players we've been applauding as as
maybe the best two left
played high quality moves Levy until
time pressure set in and it all fell
apart and let's just show the series of
of eval bar craziness if we can I'll let
you take it away good sir
yeah it's kind of crazy how if you just
follow that protocol of looking at
checks looking at captures and looking
at attacks this obviously won't be a
good move but attacks and attacks from
top down Queen Rogue Bishop Knight just
look at a way you can attack your
opponent's Queen just in case and that
would have been a winning move because
the queen can't go here to defend the
Knight that would have been a win a
couple of moves later we had the
following let me keep going I'm grabbing
some water you got the hey Levy you're
so good at this you could even consider
doing YouTube videos for a living I'm
gonna let you do it I'll be right back
thanks Danny I mean I'll consider that
that's that's cool
um
so there was a pin on the rook and in
this position Queen F6 defending the
Rook enabling the movement of the King
was play which by the way is also a
ridiculous move we were talking uh and
this was a mistake this was a time
pressure mistake it was a forcing move
and it was just veiling the fact that he
was kind of panicked forced his opponent
into a discovered attack battery on this
Pawn which is basically just fatal
Queen B Queen C3 was played and then
here
I did a thing said should I trade Queens
with him no let me go here which was
actually brilliant because instead of
taking this first Conor played Queen
takes Queen and now there is the German
word
which before you take this
you play a move that puts your opponent
into a forcing situation and Rook takes
Rook was just game over Rook takes Rook
on takes Queen this is the only check in
the position it didn't happen then they
decided to blunder yet another Pawn for
absolutely no reason and then I did a
thing accidentally got himself into a
completely lost end game because that's
chess and it's awful and
we all play it and I don't know why we
all play it but we make other people
play it like guinea pigs and then
they're low rated and Danny doesn't have
his headphones on
maybe I'll be the next CEO of Justin
town that would be kind of kind of cool
right Danny I accept
hey Danny that's whatever you said man
whatever you say goes
um
what's going on now we've got game two
coming up now Alex gets the white pieces
so he does have that going for him
yep and we're off to see the wizard
E4 uh Connor asked me before uh his game
today said is there anything I could
have done like better is there anything
I can do better to guarantee that I win
the tournament kind of a thing uh and I
said Connor you're the man
uh play a little faster and just avoid
Central Pawn chaos in the Sicilian so he
completely failed the first piece of
advice but he still won and I told him
to avoid putting his knights in the
center if he's going to play the
Sicilian uh because he's gonna get hit
with a center Pawn so let's see if he at
least follows that advice in this game
it wasn't really advised Danny it was
just more like you know you wanna yeah
it was confidence building you're giving
him a pep talk right yeah you were
trying to help him
yeah yeah makes sense
um I agree with you on both pieces of
advice by the way I think he just he he
really just needs to play a little
faster because getting yourself in time
pressure is how you play G4 in that last
game and blunder it away right so if he
if he doesn't get himself in that type
of time pressure he doesn't play that
kind of panic blunder we'll see what he
does
uh we have the same situation as we had
yesterday this was the exact same
opening except sapnap played F4 because
he played uh yeah Viennese Viennese
Sicilian
and maybe I did a thing we'll play
Knight G5 but the Sicilian is too strong
for that nonsense
you did it this is not
that's not a good move he's cheese and I
think Connor I think Connor knows how to
handle this yeah you did it yesterday in
fact we see it Connor already played E6
we'll see what Alex's reaction is now
now Alex has to play D3 if he plays
Queen F3 he's just gonna lose his Knight
that would be a really tragic end to his
campaign
the horse is hanging now so I gotta
yeah
horse is hanging now
now horse is hanging now Conor's gonna
go here here and here what am I doing
what are you doing
nice
maybe he'll go here first well
done this
let's take him there look like
it's taken that's not gonna
maybe just castling straight away did I
Castle late last time
wow
Bishop H6 that's Bishop H6 is a deranged
movement I'm losing that isn't the worst
for me
I was gonna say he got the coffee but he
didn't if I take the pawn he didn't
drink it Connor
let's not do that
what eight
eight go back
go back pushing with that
it's like
when I take my dog to the dog park it's
not bad she tries to escape if I open
the door back like get back in there
go back street is this way don't go that
way go over here pushing push push I
mean is that pawn push there a bad idea
is this Pawn push he's getting Alex to
take a lot of time with that with that
move as you said don't just go back it's
not it's not a good move because you
would never want that Bishop to be
anywhere but word Levy said which is
don't trade on C1 back up the bishop to
its home
what have we talked about Connor Connor
hates Bishops that Bishop is gonna die
it will be a development Arc for Connor
if he plays Bishop to G7 if Conor plays
Knight E7 by the way sticking to
development and hanging this bishop just
book the plane ticket for I did a thing
like I I don't even just don't even make
them play a tie break like Conor needs
to have a coming to God moment right now
and go why is my Bishop out here that
was a mistake you know we all make
mistakes I agree if he if he Retreats
the bishop it will be a real
tournament Arc which is the event that
Connor made his debut in the chess
Community he doesn't do it
um would have been a real great story
arc but now Conor partsways and look at
the eval bar shoot up a little bit
everyone this isn't just drama you want
that Bishop on the dark Square this Levy
has said now you have a bunch of Swiss
cheese show the holes highlight it give
me some holes
[Laughter]
no holes everywhere he shouldn't yeah he
he's um
this is like one of these moments he
knows what he's supposed to do but he he
is getting a little bit distracted uh
and um sometimes we get very passionate
chat members that debate things with me
there's a person that's saying we're
being too harsh on them uh and that his
move is totally justified because it's
just trying to overpower a piece that
that's completely wrong that's why we're
here and you're there
um this should be being attacked by
minimum value you should not be putting
the bishop out here almost ever if
you're gonna feed in Kettle with Bishop
which is the whole point of the opening
99 times out of 100 the best move is not
going to be to move it there so and
Conor knows that he's just and Danny
he's gonna lose the game if he castles
like he's going to get mated
he's on track to get sapnap remember
what sapnap did to him made on the dark
squares he's on track to invite the same
thing and again everything else about
what Conor has done for the record looks
great except there's a missing Bishop on
G7
that's the problem yeah just Ludwig and
chat saying what okay Queen F4 I
wouldn't have played that because you're
now indicating you have a queen the
whole point you know in battle is that
you keep the secret weapon back here
okay it's like in that movie where that
baseball player got subbed on and they
pretended he was 10 years old and there
was a paper and it said I am 10 and
there was like money what is that movie
called it was like a it was like some
specimen baseball player who was like 30
years old uh anyway I I forgot it I
watched it in my childhood this is
essentially what you're keeping back
here Danny you can't go Queen F4 now he
knows you have a queen you had to Castle
so he'd go oh that's a good idea and
then he loses
question this is why it's a bad idea
because with the bishop gone
as I've been saying it's holes it's
whole city it's good movies oh
by the way holes holes wasn't good
movies sounded to Shia LaBeouf before
his career
um anyway
um D5
good move uh good move except your
entire Pawn structure indicates that you
need a dark scored bishop and you're
also leaving your king in the center so
Connor knows how this is like if oh oh
oh oh look for checks oh oh oh oh it's
over he's gonna win a piece
if Queen A5 check is played Knight C3 D4
although he won a piece last game and it
wasn't over yet so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say no to I did a thing just yet
but um
yeah Queen A5 check that's a loose
Bishop
that's just the only chance that he has
then is some Queen F6 crazy stuff
does he see the check can we can we
let's let's listen into Conor maybe
we'll get lucky and he'll start talking
he's been so serious all day it hasn't
been the most uh I'm not calling out
anybody watching the Sea Dog stream but
it hasn't been the most entertaining
Conor today let's see
what's he got
he's not looking he doesn't see it
he doesn't see it at all always over
checks he's trying to open up the
position always and for sure that's why
we give this advice oh dear me
oh dear take take
oh dear this is oh sorry
this is open now checks checks
this will be here this will be able to
push
yeah I'm gonna do it
damn but then I don't know I don't need
this here anymore
this is gone now
oh what
wow
check made on F7 now castles would be
good for Black by the way yeah now
castles gets the king out of Dodge
guards mate and unpins the Knight all in
one move
but yesterday he castled and he got
rolled so he might
be scared uh I think we just Castle this
is a huge moment done deal
somehow
maybe he'll move his Rook instead of
castling
I think he's gonna Castle though Castle
there he goes he sees it
he's doing it if I Castle removing the
threat takes takes takes
eggs or takes with coin maybe mix with
queen I'm kind of in trouble with this
yeah wait wait wait if it's a fight
Castle he takes what
then takes my dude just got scared of
something in his seventh dimension
alternatively could you push this
all right that's better I think right
they're not pushing F5
is that better scared the crap out of me
when you grabbed it
Castle baby
no he'll see it I think he's just double
checking tactics look at that let go oh
there you go you did it
castles into the defense
choose what to eat for dinner
he likes to read every word of the menu
I know guys like that you know
um you still know guys like that are
used to know guys like that who you no
longer associate with but you know you
just don't take them out that often you
know
um right but he does he does get castled
he gets out of Dodge and I did a thing
and goes for the attack but he forgets
yep the night isn't pinned anymore
Knight E5 is game over and that's that's
uh we we better booked that five
thousand dollar round-trip ticket from
from Tokyo to LAX
what's funny is he had a great idea
again Alex up Connor season he had a
great idea but he lost track of the
night being pin and now we see him drop
enough bombs down there you don't need
to be a professional lip reader or nor
do you need to speak Australian to know
what Alex just said
yeah he said rats
he said oh gosh darn
he says man I can't believe
well
well we know we had Ludwig and chat
hanging out we're all waiting to see the
same thing will xqc show up and start
streaming
right now we're uh where we were told he
was gonna be here he said he would and
we'll see if he is this one isn't over
yet but it's looking like Conor is going
to be the first player from the
championship bracket going to La if we
stay on track
will xqc show up today
prime time will some of White's pieces
show up for the attack by the way
because Knight E4 a b Knight G5 is
insane
oh man is this going to be another snap
nap little snap wait snap snappy snappy
snap nap snap sappy Napper sappy napper
yeah I I don't even know but
he this is Danny this is the only shot
he has
the night going
94 and go for Knight F6 check and cross
your fingers pray to whatever chest Gods
you believe in or you gotta hit him with
the o o
for show
oh oh X Glam oh he does it oh oh for
show Beaufort show a born Bostonian
um would be crazy this man is
that's crazy he played it that was a
great idea
Danny if he finds Knight E4 Conor might
think he's going to G5 or something and
then miss Knight F6 Queen H7 like
it ain't over it
although if he plays Knight E4 it's I
mean how do you not see
I'm not I'm not saying in like a
judgmental way I'm saying like you can
see Knight G5 but anything you would do
to stop Knight G5 inadvertently stops
Knight F6 like Knight G4 would stop
Knight F6 Knight F5 would stop Knight F6
F6 would stop Knight F6 so and so the
point is I think Conor's in good shape
because it's hard for me to see how he
tricks himself into a blender here
maybe rookie one maybe a little bit of
like I can't save my Bishop anyway
because he's gonna go here
let's see what is he thinking
and can I get some Aussie please let's
get some Aussie Aussie Aussie
volume volume
is trapped I'm ignoring that
oh my God
this is a great timing now he's gonna
eat
delicious
let's go to Sea Dog let's go to Sea Dog
does he see it
oh we don't even have to do it we don't
have to go to Sea Dog no no operational
board aboard aboard aboard he played
Knight F5 he played Knight F5 he is
kicking out the queen
and that was what I was saying is it
guards it kicks the queen it guards F6
that's the main reason is it unleashes
the queen to guard F6 and so
inadvertently Conor stops every threat
whether he saw every threat or not he's
in great shape
yeah the and now the only chance that
you have here is F4 G4 and it's still
not over actually because Danny F4 then
you take then you play G4 you give me
this position against 1100 I'ma find a
way to win you just
the attack is dangerous if he just
starts throwing the whole kitchen sink I
don't know if they have that expression
down there down under they probably have
like a throw every wallaby you got
I could honestly hit him with a back of
one of these yeah every room with the
Tucker throw it right throw it in the
outback um that's probably there they're
saying down there instead of you know
the kitchen sink
I don't know I I I I I can actually see
that being a thing like a thing give
them every wallaby you got boys
um okay Bishop B7 what a move by Conor
by the way the discipline the Poise he
doesn't take A4 he goes after the night
uh oh that's it
right there the attack is gone the game
is over as long as Connor sees it let's
listen into Connor before we see whether
he plays it let's do it yeah let's do it
let's go
Connor Connor we don't even see that G5
yet so we caught it there it is
I see will he see it
so now he's a check made him one he
doesn't see it I don't know if I miss it
it's like a it's like oh my God
yesterday
okay same as yesterday he doesn't want
to move oh
this is so this is so Jehovah bro this
is Jehovah
Jova
this is a joke is that like
Jabba the Hutt and it's over had a baby
Jova
I don't know
Jabba the Hutt it's over had a baby and
it's Jova that's a great name by the way
like Java but Jehovah I missed the boat
on that could have named one of my kids
Jehovah you still got a chance lovey you
got any kids plans what's the plan you
guys should be dog people you guys gonna
have kids or what is that too personal
to ask in front of a lot of people oh
it's super personal but okay but I feel
like it's a uh it's a good setup and you
know everything's good it's gonna be
some spicy where it get some pressure on
uh I just don't have enough friends to
pull it off there's also a lovely kind
of sack I could do here
my my queen is so strong I think I just
take the free material
just take yeah he'll take he'll take the
bishop because he yeah he's in a Zone
Sea Dog we can just take it for free
he likes
minor just get rid of it let's let's do
this
yeah he's gonna be in a uh he's gonna be
in a seat all right headed to L.A oh
yeah he's in a Zone he's gonna be in a
seat oh yeah he's gonna fly that so
Japanese first class baby Japanese first
class so
uh uh well I think we can borderline
call this one not because it's totally
over but because of how good Connor has
been throughout the event he's up three
miners which again
for those who don't know Knights and
Bishops are called miners it's not that
she has miners he's into minor pieces
and that's what he has on the board can
I can I say that
Jesus Christ oh my God that's that's the
thing that he's blunder right he's he's
up to three months
oh my god um I and and for the record no
we we don't want kids until we travel 50
countries really that's a lot of
countries that that is that's a big goal
well you know I I hadn't traveled for a
few years and then I went on summer
vacation we went to Italy we went to
France I went to Paris and it was great
and I was like I gotta travel more I
work too much just takes it
um I got like 10 minutes to do you know
okay any given day but I want to travel
I want to do a Gotham World Tour maybe
for them because I like my fans
so
Maybe
that does sound fun actually Gotham
World Tour
I'd be into that all right Rook takes E5
Alex gets one piece back but it's not
enough still down a night a bishop two
minor pieces are better than not having
any and black is crushing yeah that's
kind of what I was worried about
yeah we're talking about okay liking
minor
pieces and reproductions and um
climaxes it's it's it's it's been a good
time this isn't this is a this is a
totally peachy show look if anyone is
looking into jokes that aren't there
that's a them problem I've been saying
that for years we haven't been making
anything we haven't no any jokes okay
Queen takes G2 yeah
um okay I just wanna I gotta simplify
this game I got no time left
yep
at least he's speeding up that's
actually really good because that's the
one mistake Conor has made throughout
the whole event
somebody in the chat said come to Sweden
and I'll embarrass you in chess but
their username
[Music]
which that might be that might be a
really good username actually oh it's
about it it's a great username no way
we're still on Conor's stream I feel
kind of disrespectful we're talking over
him he's saying some good stuff he
hasn't said too much today it's okay
yep
um you know people in the world have
emailed me and and if I've ever
mentioned going to a country they've
been like hey I heard on stream you said
I'm going to you want to go to you know
Switzerland well
you can sleep on my couch
and don't get me wrong I I would love an
all-expense paid trip I'm still 16 sec
how that felt like two seconds how is
that 16.
but actually you know I sleep on Danny's
couch
yeah I mean you can first of all I got a
really Comfy Couch like some couches you
can you can take a great nap on other
couches you can't take a great nap on my
couch you can hit it hit a grade now I
have a seven-seater couch which is like
a L shape so you could just oh adults
could lay flat on it
[Music]
that's a dream man yep that's oh wow
look at look at this Connor finds Queen
takes F2
he's on a roll
we're here to talk about the game but
Conor's winning and now we want to rook
and now it's really over Conor is headed
to Los Angeles unfortunately for his
good buddy Alex Alex really had it in
that first game Connor is it Connor Levy
I'll be coming I've always wanted to be
Connor I'll be lovey I'll be loving have
you get rid of his Queen
this is just clean clean stuff
I just gotta get rid of that goddamn
Queen
okay we're trading we're trading pieces
here
okay
I was waiting to see who would talk
first
you lost the bet that I had in my own
head I just missed it I was betting that
I would talk first that I would break
the silence but
so he just did he just yell an expletive
why is he he's winning what is he so
upset about I could get the queen I
could have got the queen I was playing
too fast
oh he's doing great he's worried about
the clock yeah but it's over
I'm trading the queen now though
you see over here with his King we still
don't know right away
[Music]
whether xqc will be here or not I'm
waiting for word I see nothing I hear
Fred coins he's
playing from a plane
I have just been told in my ear
what
could you do you have strong enough
Wi-Fi to play on a plane all right first
of all if it's Delta Wi-Fi I know it's
not that strong all right Delta Wi-Fi
goes out all the time I hope they hear
that it is spotty AF and as the kid said
that it's as funny as you think it is
and Delta Wi-Fi no good is it his plane
is it his plane let's go wait yes
Connor has a
over 10 point material advantage
[Laughter]
beautiful
incredible stuff all right this is it
right here you don't get it often enough
apparently
yeah
wow
[Music]
okay well so were we just yeah that was
that was the first song of Pop Champs
five are you serious
wait
I don't know who brought that stat out
but if that's the truth that is
yeah I don't know this is fun this is
where the game gets fun because I can do
poop okay second on Persona 5 sounds
apparently shout out to production
second one is the first one
okay there's five wow wow not of all of
them
not of all time but okay
Connor is on his way to winning we're
gonna catch the final moments on his
stream here
on croissant
leaving this Pawn alive because I don't
give a who's out of your leak to
where I don't know Productions talking
comments maybe we're not supposed to be
hearing oh my God we've been here in
production so we thought it was for us
lol
um
oh
does Connor know trust.com Jesus Christ
what a game dude holy
Jesus dude
oh my God
one blunder I'm gonna get his autograph
yeah I know what the blunder was too
God I played really well aside from that
one move eh
there it is Danny it's a 2-0 win which I
honestly didn't see coming you heard it
earlier I predicted tie breaks because
these guys seem so evenly matched both
played great chess in this entire park
Champs 5 tournament but only one
can go to La and that person will be
Connor Sea Dog VA flying from Tokyo
Japan to Los Angeles
the City of Angels
the City of Angels and he needed an
Angel Today to save him in that first
game but in that second game he was he
was clutch he was good defensively and
he gets the job done and there you have
it that is our first championship
uh finalist
and he awaits the winner of Frank and
airplane Wi-Fi
Frank and airplane Wi-Fi will be going
at it to decide who faces Conor in Los
Angeles Connor didn't seem that thrilled
about making the journey so we have to
ask him about that you know we'll make
sure we put him you know in the in the
storage below next to the um the
chickens and the goats in their cage
we'll give them we'll give them a real
high class seat Danny I know we have to
go to break actually let's go to break
and then I'm gonna ask you a tough
question about this upcoming matchup
when it's done so I'll keep everybody on
their seats
well don't go anywhere everybody we have
interviews coming there is the pit fist
pumping moment from Connor Alex knows he
let it go Connor is headed to La we have
an interview just around the corner we
will be right back
[Music]
click the Subscribe button see if it
says subscribe free and purple and if it
does you're golden Ponyboy anyway let's
check on who's priming right now
oh it's my friend
[Music]
um
Willis hey Willis can't wait to grab
lunch later catch you on the flippity
flip
anyway back to the chess content you
guys have a good one this August engage
in a battle of Epic Proportions against
some of the most Bodacious artists
history have ever seen
behold Raphael the prince of painters
doth seek a fresh Apprentice Dosh thou
possess the prowess to impress him
Michelangelo a true renaissance man
painter sculptor architect and poet doc
possess a myriad of artistic talents yet
one wonders can his creative genius
translate to Brilliance upon the board
of chess
prepare thyself for a game as dramatic
as the Baroque paintings of Artemisia
gentileski one of the most expressive
artists of the 1600s
I ran out in sculptor Donatello stands
tall as one of the most important
artists of the early Renaissance his
unique blend of creativity Aesthetics
adaptability and patience maketh him a
challenging foe Lo Leonardo da Vinci
known for his artistic talents
scientific curiosity and innovative
ideas is the very embodiment of the
Renaissance he is not only among the
greatest artists to ever live but also
one of the greatest thinkers May a
fortune smile upon thee create thy
Masterpiece on chess.com cowabunga
[Music]
ah
foreign
[Music]
Champs 5 is back that man right there
the pre-tournament favorite in a lot of
people's eyes continues to deliver Sea
Dog gets the job done 2-0 over his
friend Alex I did a thing and he even
did it in Style by bringing us
apparently our second POG Champs of the
entire our second on passant of the
entire POG Champs tournament Connor take
us through the emotions and the feelings
of getting on poisson
while I still hadn't forgotten when
Jarvis and onpassant had been it cost me
everything in that game uh and so
obviously when the opportunity arose
itself I mean I you have to do it and
and the best part was that I would have
done it if it me over but uh it
actually helped me so I was I was I was
ecstatic and I'm sure Alex was so
pleased
I I was I would that was so dirty like
the the scream that came from my mouth
when you did that it's like you had
hacks the game and under the legal move
I was like and also you were winning No
need no need
so dirty
I was so scared for a moment because
even though I had I had so much material
up on you I had one minute left and I
felt like okay I blundered my night and
I was like oh this is all falling apart
now and I've got one minute left to
figure this all out and I just wanted to
I wanted to swap my queen with you and
you weren't having it I was like just
take my goddamn Queen
it's the worst thing
Alex in that first game you uh you were
winning on a couple of occasions did you
sense it did you sense that you were
winning or I said I sensed I sensed on I
haven't done the game review yet but I
sensed multiple times I could see if I
did things right the Checkmate was maybe
coming or getting getting something
great out of it but I just didn't follow
up properly I think I got too fixated on
a thing in the on on doing a certain
move and then when things changed I just
blundered a piece
um
the second game when I was launching the
well it wouldn't have been Checkmate but
trying to bring my my horse across to
thread and Checkmate and then I just
placed my horse in front of your queen
forgetting that that was there I was
just like no I'm gonna do this move I
gotta do it and then just did not look
I thought it was some big brain strategy
I was waiting for the game to like
implode when I took it I was like how am
I going to lose my queen in some
fantastic way
well that's what when you hug your your
knight uh to my Rook I was like I was
almost too scared to take it I was like
nah there's got to be a reason being
here there must be some crazy fork or
something yeah no actually can I say I I
was so disappointed in the first game I
like offered a free Bishop for you and I
was like please take this because it was
a fork with the queen and I was like no
give me this
I love the accents I'm listening and
learning this is what I'm doing here I'm
just taking in the accents and I don't
mean to objectify you guys you guys are
both you know you guys are both human
beings regardless of your accents but
I'm just into it I'm just gonna be
honest to me gentlemen you you are you
are more than accents you're you're just
you're just spoke for itself today it
was it was a beautiful thing it was a
great match I uh I feel like Conor is
like the challenge in every single match
and that first game was uh was very
intense and I I appreciate the fighting
spirit in the second game I mean it was
uh there was a couple of moments I don't
know if you guys are going to watch the
tape back or if you have better things
to do but a couple moments we said this
is not over if Alex finds a couple of
resources and he did he kept finding
them so I was trying I'm always that's
it I I hate going down to end games so
it's like I'm always searching for a
potential Checkmate or something I could
come back with hoping that Conor will
get confident and and not see it but
also Connor why do you even want to win
you don't even want to go to La I feel
like this is neither of us wanted to go
now I don't I don't want to win I don't
want to go to I want to win but I don't
want to go to La but I think my
inability to I'm too competitive and I
want to win things but I'm also just com
I have to go to I have a European tour
in like three weeks and I have to go to
La and I have so much stuff to do this
is absolutely ruining my life right now
uh so thank you for that we're gonna be
we're going to be we're gonna have so
much fun in La though Connor it's gonna
be great so don't stress too much about
it Alex
did you really only start playing chess
a few weeks ago because I'm not gonna
lie like I know this didn't work out the
way that you wanted it to but it has
been impressive to watch you over the
last few weeks and this is a guy Conor
who's been doing things on chess.com
here for a few years and getting better
so I just want to applaud you and ask
hopefully did you have a good experience
overall here
yeah so my chest rating I think when I
started this was like 600 550 something
like that so yeah it proved a lot in a
couple of weeks
um but yeah I I love it but I also hate
it at the same time not because it's not
a great game but I I get such a
one-track mind with it it's like a virus
it consumes everything I think about I
see chess everywhere and I I've been
unable to make a video on my channel for
like all I think about is chess so I
have done nothing but the play chess for
the past two weeks and I'm a little bit
glad it's over so I could you know do
some work and make somebody
your videos are like a plague man you
watch one and I swear to God YouTube
refuses to allow me to see anything else
in my recommended I knew you were going
to do the fried liver attack Alex so I
watched one video and I woke up this
morning and it was like 500 Levy videos
what is this what are you paying off
I'm annoyed you watch that because
that's what I was going for in the
second game is the fried liver I might
have I might have looked at your account
and seen that
listen guys I I just make the videos you
know I I think uh we should end it on a
positive note and say that uh you know
chess is Ageless and Timeless and you
could play it if you're 2 or 102 and
that's why YouTube
feeds it to uh to everybody a lot so
I don't know yeah that's that's a
positive spin I can give on it so Alex
uh this has been awesome man sorry it
didn't work out maybe you got lucky you
saved yourself a trip to L.A Connor get
ready we're gonna put you on a real
great seat next to the uh the chickens
and the goats down low in the baggage
you'll have it'll be super comfy they
won't be too loud we're gonna save some
money on that round trip for sure right
and we'll see you in LA
you got this fantastic
um thanks man you got this
see you gentlemen bye guys see you later
thanks for having us
and just like that there was one match
left to determine who the final spot
in Los Angeles will go to xqc and Frank
are about to play xuc just took to
Twitter and said hey just.com I'm ready
for my matches with a with a tweet that
shows him about to get on a plane I have
no idea what we are about to be in for
here Levy will xqc connect will he stay
connected
uh
yeah no he he didn't just get on the
like he is on the plane he is sitting
next on the plane a window and it just
looks like a regular plane it doesn't
look like he's on the PJ uh which got me
which has me a little terrified Danny I
thought planes didn't have Wi-Fi
problems anymore I just flew like seven
hours recently and my plane had no
internet uh yeah
like I said if you fly Delta it doesn't
work half the time
um you know
um I'm just trying to be honest here uh
oh
Danny I know we got to start the games I
want to complain about something real
quick in-flight entertainment is trash
on planes the chess bot is garbage this
is a public service announcement we can
tweet this from chess.com I am offering
to partner with an airline to help them
build an interactive in-flight chess
mobile system that will teach them chess
and they can make play little games and
they can play anybody on the plane it's
going to be a beautiful thing Danny I
want to partner with an airline that's
my official public declaration to do so
you heard the man you heard him he's
ready uh let's let's take a look at the
man who's also ready apparently throwing
up the peace sign xqc the most watched
man on Twitch whenever he goes live will
obviously not be streaming because we
know that that's not a thing he can do
from a plane uh but he is going to be
playing chess apparently as long as it
holds up and we're gonna determine who's
who's all going to La no matter what
today come uh come hell or high water or
whatever they say I don't know if I'm
allowed to say that that's a phrase I
think you can say I say a lot of things
you're not allowed to say but this is it
that's plenty that's plain QC wait a
minute wait a minute Danny this might
have been brilliant this might have been
a really strategic play from xqc allow
me to explain why Frank never streams
this late he never streams this late
because he lives in the UK in the UK
it's late night right now it's late
night right now which means his family's
asleep his family's asleep means he
can't yell
wait the game already shows that Frank
won
I wonder if I wonder if xuc is being
disconnected somehow what
I I have no idea Frank one and one move
we're working on it and uh we're gonna
find out what happens here in just a
minute Frank is Live on YouTube though
what's his YouTube again
it's kind of it's goofy he's got to
change his user I don't know it's
Frank's is here or something like that
Frank is here I guess not he's just
nothing
um
do I just wave your hair I'm guessing I
just wait here
okay the plan is to just wait
why does it keep on going I don't know
why it keeps on going that blurry thing
okay I don't know why it keeps on doing
that
um I I literally can't type this guy's
name Franks is here yes
game was aborted does that mean
that doesn't mean I win
laughs
sorry he's so funny he's got one of
these just things where he's just just
him being himself is funny Frank is
hilarious
um
apparently xqc went offline which means
as predicted
that the plain Wi-Fi is not holding up
um actually I was going to ask a
question about this
uh my question was going to be obviously
if he cannot play because he's on a
plane and that's like out of his control
if he was traveling today let's say he
was delayed he expected to be home
that's fine reputation aside
um what if he like played 10 moves and
disconnected is that an official game
you know
a lot of things that happen in POG
Champs are um groundbreaking you know
they are Trend Setters the first time
someone dropped an F-bomb on chess TV I
remember like it was yesterday they
proceeded to talk about things that
I can't even talk about
um
I danced on the edge of inappropriate
humor but there are people who say
things on the show that I thought would
never happen there are people that do
things on these shows pogchamps is a
trendsetter
I'm literally delaying answering your
question I have no idea we're gonna
figure it out because it's xqc my guess
is we're probably going to delay this
whole day and you've never seen her run
a show more organized than this because
if I had to guess we probably will not
be able to continue given what we're
seeing
but despite being the chief chess
officer of chess.com I am not in charge
of this show I am simply talented they
they they blame you for everything man
this is like a 600 employee company it's
not fair this should be our therapy
session you don't make all the decisions
hey I have a real therapist for a real
reason
um and um and I have a work therapist
now too I won't say his name but uh he's
a fantastic coach
an exec coach I'm an exec coaching and I
call him oh wait we have chess moves
let's go yeah what
what is going on
um yeah yeah that's me
let's move out why not let's go there
all right
we're quite nice to Vienna
it's Vienna and xqc
um okie dokie I'm gonna go there with
that night next
all righty then do I just Castle up here
maybe go there
try get some okay boom boom I Danny have
you ever played chess on a plane go
there okay uh never I played on the Bots
I played the bots on the app obviously
who hasn't done that okay but I've never
played live chess I I've played some
live chess but you can only play Blitz
because I just hope I can beat people in
20 moves and not lose on time
this is definitely a massive Gambit by
xuc and if I had to guess it will
backfire because
even if I think he's a better chess
player than Frank at this stage of their
career the lag the delay the drama the
plane the turbulence
the cabin pressure
snacks how do we know he didn't give the
phone to the person sitting next to him
what if you sit next to Magnus in
business class
what if Magnus is playing them he's not
because of the opening but just just out
of curiosity like what if I was seeing
his next game he was like Hey can you
play this game for me okay lucky lucky
for us the heavy lifting of the
chefs.com fair play algorithm is not
actually people being on camera so we
usually can tell when someone's DNA
changes that said you're not wrong
you're not wrong we don't know what's
going on besides it is xqc logged in and
I think we might just be listening to
Frank all day
the hypothetical legal team no I'm just
I'm just posing the questions Queen E2
is a not a good move because you can
still take that pawn I can't even
commentate he just never stops talking
okay I like that movement that movement
is quite nice do you think he does this
in schools or do they find a way to make
him not talk
like he literally of all the human
beings I've watched all right you're
right you're righty this could this
could still turn into something nice uh
um
it's like he's running an auction he
never stops talking like never stops
like literally I've never seen a human
being this capable of speaking non-stop
it's impressive oh okay
okay I'm gonna go
okay I'm gonna go there
pretzing the queen
I don't know about this porn takes that
I'll take there
okay okay
how old is Frank by the way I think 16.
he's 16 years old like like he's
wow is he the youngest participant we've
ever had in POG Champs is it even legal
for us to try to fly someone
from the UK to L.A okay I hope we get
parental consent on this geez Louise I'm
gonna go uh I mean he's literally a
minor like he's 16 years old
yep um I I I legitimately am learning
that for the first time
yeah yeah Frank Frank is a teenager
unless it's a really well kept secret
and he's 45. defended oh goodness me
I've left the porn under okay
stop
[Laughter]
and defend okay I'm gonna defend that
pull in there Bishop's defended okay I'm
going to look to Castle right now
I think I I think I think people are too
mean like Frank's biggest complaint that
you can have about Frank is he talks too
much there are people literally pranking
old people like throwing paint on
people's skin you know doing things
there's so many worse individuals that
I've ever been on camera
we could give Frank a pass for just
being very animated I I love I love
frank I will admit I've never actually
watched any of his content outside of
since he started playing on POG Champs
that's just the truth I'm not I'm not a
tick tocker I don't consume the reels
kids I just pretend to be socially epped
on TV
it's fine look at him like but I can see
why he said I'm getting the appeal this
is the first Frank experience I've ever
had I'm getting it
are we the same volume as he is I don't
know
if I'm what
was he doing is he actually gonna put
the bishop there I mean come on Frank
just keep oh no no
oh no
oh Lord that was that was bad that was
oh I've just
oh no
oh
that was bad
okay I think I've said enough today I'm
just gonna listen to these to these guys
I think xqc just screamed out the word
free in business class yeah a bishop
he's like boom boom boom
cranky old man just uh that man won't
stop yelling can you please respond that
was that was that was not good oh sorry
[Music]
the wooden Shield the wooden Shield okay
people are are spamming the xuc emotes
I'm not a subscriber so I can't do it
okay okay okay
boom I'm gonna go
whoo maybe push a pool he's gonna win oh
oh he's gonna win his fans show up even
if he's not streaming the xqc emote Army
is real
our chat is about to become a screaming
noise of xqc
um I feel it coming
position to be in uh no no it's it's
definitely not a great position no okay
boom go there
um
oh it's not even gonna be that good okay
can't go there really oh Lord
oh Lord Oh Lord Oh Lord
[Music]
um
I'm gonna try to analyze there's nothing
to analyze here we're just gonna listen
we're just reacting that's what we're
doing Danny literally we're full xqc
right now we're reacting to content
I can't even talk he talks too much it's
the
reaction content
there I take that goes there I take okay
okay
I say we just listen to Frank I mean can
we just turn up Frank for a minute I
mean I'm just I'm just gonna and then I
go
and trap a knight
xqc takes my Bishop
there's still objectively objectively
Levy I think it's still more likely
Frank wins this game the next QC yeah
boom I go I don't know what that Bishop
does right there
uh I don't know if they can still hear
us
he goes down there I'll just win a
bishop but I'm looking this night could
you see disconnects are still very high
nice he goes down there he's down to one
bar down there okay I'm looking down to
one secure myself a knight right here
I'm looking to secure myself tonight
okay okay oh Bishop there staring at a
knight pawns could look up with maybe
could be doing juice it could be very
juicy oh okay
uh it's there and I'm looking okay boom
I go there quantity G4 is better but I'm
gonna go there the knife building we saw
this idea coming several moves ago yes
okay the knights trapped I can okay Pawn
goes there I'll have to take okay but
that point okay right there all right
this is good this is good this is good I
think I think the Knight is trapped I
think the Knight could mess with me this
could be wonderful this could be
wonderful right here oh this could be
delicious this could be absolutely
delicious the night could very well be
trapped instead of watching Master Chef
okay we're up on time we're up one time
which is always a delicious sight to see
very delicious like to see
[Music]
they'll never know okay the night
literally okay the night definitely
can't escape right boom
oh okay
play E6 you can push the pawn he doesn't
actually have to take it he will wait
if he takes there
oh do you want oh okay cd1
boom boom boom
boom could that be the plan of action
okay boom I go there he takes I take
then could that oh my goodness okay okay
we're gonna threaten that Rook
I'll take
back he might beat him
he's the moment right here oh my
goodness
oh my goodness
it's actually Unstoppable
right here it's Unstoppable he's winning
excuse he just threw the game there's no
way to stop Checkmate y'all rookie 8 is
Unstoppable
he goes there oh take he can't even do
anything then he's gonna win I'm
covering that old man oh my God what
happened while I was gone check mate
holy
holy holy Frank is a snake and xqc is on
a plane Danny
sickness oh my God
you just referenced Samuel Jackson and
maybe the most effective manner I've
ever heard on a chess stream
look at it Frank knows that it's crazy
[Music]
oh my goodness of me oh my God the facts
you see disconnects right now does he
get a replay
no no
the game
oh oh no no what no no no it's me okay
okay he doesn't see there's a bishop
cards I've been winded
it's me I go oh no oh no it's just
oh yeah okay okay
that's checked mate oh my goodness okay
I thought it was a Checkmate for a hot
minute there holy I found it though I
found it oh that took me a minute right
then that took me a hot minute but I
found it
what is this guy on oh my God
I have never watched I thought xqc was
Peak
Peak uh just befuddle you with the
things that that are said but this guy
is next level I I'm fascinated I've
never watched Frank before Levy how have
you ever given this kid lessons it it's
actually a totally different experience
during collabs I I feel the same way
that that I'm sure Tyler won like when
he goes to the DMV doesn't scream that
he would you know throw people around
the room and and he would be the best
driver of all time and so on like I
think you know when these people are day
to day in their lives uh I think Frank
takes some breaks and some pauses uh and
uh that was a very well deserved win it
was a good fight I wish we could have
like analyzed a little bit but we're
scuff man there's a guy on a plane
there's boards breaking left and right I
don't know the fact that we're here is a
miracle on its own Levy Rosman alongside
me I don't even know what's going on
here and the fact that we're here is a
miracle like the Miracle of Life but
also the fact that xuc is still playing
chess here I'm
I'm I'm blown mind my mind blown
um and we're gonna start the second game
and there it is and as long as this
doesn't abort in one move uh like the
last one then we will have a dynamic
board that we can analyze and maybe this
game hold on we can't hold on just
analyze some stuff
don't speak don't speak Gwen Stefani I
know what you're thinking it is there it
is we have I don't need no two moves
[Music]
no no no what's big what artists are
banned do you know the most amount of
music from
what artist or band do I know the most
amount of music from
like just like can sing every lyric kind
of thing yeah or yeah or like know of
their songs
um both
good question
um
um Linkin Park for me it's Linkin Park
yeah
wow that was that was my Peak teenage
years right there you know
um
is my jackia
but I'm gonna go Adele
okay
like by your own doing or by the big
adult swim in here my wife loves the
devil listen to Adele Adele's great
feels good I mean who's not an adult fan
have you ever seen Muse live do you like
muse no
oh I've never seen Muse live not that I
don't like them oh
damn you don't like
miss little two pawns two knights from
xqc left to see it maybe Frank going for
a Philadelphia which he hasn't ever
played in his life but literally never
doubt Frank he'll play a Philadelphia if
he wants and
can't stop him
Frank um tank Frank uh tank I know
that's probably not a nickname he plays
the stoner filador I don't know what
this is
this is just loud yeah yeah just loses
the pawn for free he's just he's playing
The Tweak and fill it or I I don't know
man he's just down upon after four
months are you allowed to say tweaking I
I it's it's just come after dark and we
we've crossed we've crossed the lines on
the show I once had an interaction with
a with a with uh never mind I'm gonna
stop talking about this I'm gonna stop I
can't I can't do it
um but okay uh excuse me wins a pawn uh
and and Frank is Frank is tweaking on
this street I think it's just a one and
done I don't think there's we don't have
to hammer home that we know of that word
you know we should just
it's one in the morning in the UK like
you know uh and the
the uh is it one in the morning in the
UK it's like it's 12 40 we're rounding
up
all right xqc needs to win this game to
keep his hopes alive to be in the POG
Champs final remember that everybody
it's winner go home I think this is the
first time Felix has trailed any match
right because he won the first game
against Papa plot
so this is the first time Felix has
trailed in a match
it's true it's true it's definitely
because he's he's playing his strongest
opponent yet uh he's also on an airplane
uh which you know
um body gets swollen depending on how
long his flight is it's it's stressful
can you imagine xqc in the middle of a
plane and they're offering him like uh
like beverage service sir would you
would you like something
no exactly I don't know but again you
talked about how Frank is a little
different in collabs IRL isn't always
the same personality for a Creator I
wonder how Felix is on a plane how
reserved he might be I these streamers
you know Danny like we talk about from
the audience not having parasocial
relationships with streamers I have
power social relationships with
streamers because not in the sense that
I'm gonna like go to their house but
everything I see of them is online I
don't know what they're like in person
so I do wonder if if tyler1 gets a it's
a complimentary beverage on a plane does
he just like
give me another one
like you know you know like I don't know
how these people act day to day it's
no I'll say this Felix is playing great
chess here he played Bishop E3 to remove
the defender and you're highlighting
what he's playing
uh this this match is probably headed to
tiebreakers let's let's tune back into
Frank just because it's been as
entertaining as anything we've seen
today and see what see what he's
thinking boom I go there and Castle up
Bishop takes I'll take back with night
the knights there oh okay now I'll go
there
oh he's gonna pull oh no that's bad five
minutes behind us oh my goodness me that
is oh no
oh no oh Lord oh why would I do that oh
I just didn't think oh I didn't think
um
um I've lost that Rook okay just forget
about the Rook just forget about the
Rook you can oh that's bad oh this is
bad this is not good
oh this is this is a terrible situation
this is a terrible situation
oh no oh no oh this is terrible oh this
is so bad oh goodness me oh goodness me
I've lost sight I've lost sight
oh oh this is this is terrible oh Lord
Oh Lord okay I can give a check
oh good that's me this is not nice this
is not nice at all
holy holy holy holy this is bad this is
oh goodness
um okay now I'm gonna go
oh okay we'll go there oh
this is no what am I doing right this
has been a very poor game a very very
poor game okay yeah having played my
greatest right here have not okie dokie
[Music]
okay okay this still could be nice they
still could be nice
um all right boom I go then and give a
check there maybe
that could be an option that could
definitely be an option uh and I could
go that's a nice good Escape you're
eating some nuts
um okay
I got some almonds and cashews over here
um
put them in a big container and I can
eat them throughout the day this is not
good plus seven
those are like salted dry roasted
gotta be salted everything's salted like
people who eat unsalted butter
Psychopaths
I agree with it I agree with a lot of
things you say but I don't know that
anything all righty all right you're
right it resonates with me more than
that like okay okay unsalted butter um
why oh I don't know like if you've got
cholesterol problems just go exercise I
mean like how are you gonna eat unsalted
butter what are you eating eating just a
block of nothing yeah
what's he got what's he got in his
locker what is he got sodium's not even
realize I'm not okay okay
by the way as long as I'm promoting um
we're promoting so we're down to only 2
200 copies of Levy's signed book how to
win a chess I should be when I say we
you know we're in this together
[Music]
um
you can use the command book to get a
signed copy not just an Amazon pre-order
copy we're probably gonna sell out all
200 books remaining right here on the
show Levy so be ready
um let's do it
um yeah you get this thing it's
beautiful it's uh it's one of a kind
it's this is the first one I got the
first one I should auction this off for
charity that's actually really a great
idea yeah
is the first book that was ever printed
oh yeah it's not a bad idea maybe I'll
do that uh but yeah you can use the
command book thanks thanks Danny well we
um yeah the book will teach you to avoid
positions like this with black but get
positions like this with white there you
go that's a winner that's a winner
testimonial for the book right there
um yeah okay 95 I've like this has been
one of the wildest events weeks two days
I I cannot believe we're likely headed
to tie breaks here
Frank is Frank Frank can we get like a
if there was like a drinking game to
play on whether Frank pauses for more
than two seconds between any words
everybody here would be inebriated in an
inappropriate fashion
um because I he has not stopped talking
like literally watch him there's not two
seconds between words no no there's
there's not it it's it's it's impressive
and also slightly terrifying
but he's going to
win freaking out
yeah he sees that he's gonna win the
night you see him doing the thing okay
okay
oh yeah yeah hold on let me let me let
me let me show this okay we're gonna win
his night right we're gonna win his
night and then it's game on then oh oh
oh he's attacking my knight right so I
can't I can't take his Knight but his
Knight is still trapped all right and
let me get this Pawn okay we're gonna
get this pawn and then we're gonna take
his Knight we're gonna take his Knight
and if he tries to trap me I can move my
knight and then he's not he's still
trapped okay okay oh this is delicious
oh this is delicious I'm gonna get his
night and then it's game on baby then
it's game on all right all right all
right he's attacking my knight again
okay this is this is unexpected this is
not tasty this is not tasty but I could
go there and I can attack his Rook I can
attack his Rook but then he's gonna move
his Rook up and then oh that oh that's
not good at all that's not I can't go
there okay okay okay
all right
Danny I can't even Danny I'm losing
words it's so good my business content I
don't even how does he talk that much my
brain just ran out of words like it's
just it just stopped it that was
phenomenal that was phenomenal all right
let's go see how close you are Levy
oh do I maybe blunder my night by going
there so if I go there looking there
looking there looking oh he's gonna do
my thing looking that the Night Trap
gets trapped looking there oh goodness
okay I'm going to fall back yeah I'm
gonna fall back because I would have
blinded my knight by going head first
into that one then that's exactly what I
said going to go there
okay as you see it really wants my night
he really wants the night right now
he really wants my night game of chess
oh my goodness this is unbelievable this
is
impressions in the books
please just let me take the night I've
been staring at it like the past four
moves I just want to take that line
please I just want to take it it's like
there's dinner on the table and my mom's
not letting me eats it
does what that does
but I'm gonna finally take the Knight
now
okay maybe go there get some diversion
started don't know why I said diversions
but maybe you could get some diversion
stuff okay boom okay it just says words
and then doesn't we're looking at those
it's just incredible let's go there but
then I'll go
okay this game's getting Saucy it's
getting warm it's getting on oh I could
um
okay xqc no to put his Rooks on the
seventh rank together
um that would be huge right that's the
plan okay Rook goes there can take
um
yeah oh I see okay boom that goes there
okay I need to
okay
[Music]
boom
ball okay boom
boom okay look at this boom boom
boom boom boom boom Oh Oh Frank is all
over it
I gotta say gonna go
super impressed with Frank's calculation
um maybe also impressed with xqc's time
management because he's playing on bad
Wi-Fi it'll be the plan of action maybe
yeah yeah just got five minutes
still he's gonna get down there with the
Rooks though okay now we're gonna go
there make sure that's defended there
this is winning okay okay he needs to go
after the a pawn though and give up on
the seventh ring I don't know like like
Rook B4 would be great I can go there
and look for a fork there apparently
we're saying bye to Frank for now oh
okay okay we're gonna look
and I will not be doing another
impression because I am I was gonna say
at a certain point it's it's not that
it's not highly entertaining but I did
black out there for a little bit because
it was like okay same thing boom and
there and uh it was yes listen I I got
good at doing impressions by watching
people who are not American give
interviews chess and otherwise so like
that was uh that was probably what uh
what helped me to have good accents uh
Franco's here Danny he's gonna start
pushing
he's gonna start pushing xqc the Rook is
under attack so the Rooks are so much
better than the Knight when it comes to
these types of open board Pawn races but
at the same time whoever's pawns get
going first
that's uh that could decide the game if
Frank plays G5 who knows what xuc will
do
yeah that's not he doesn't well he's
defending his Pawn but um
really see it does he know on passant oh
my God he might but he's got a couple of
other moves if he knows on passant
that's gonna be that's gonna be frank
going to La I'm calling it
oh my God
Frank the Tank Woodley does he know
about a takes B3 on the pass home he
does it he does it oh my God
and he's delayed so we're gonna see it
oh
oh no
oh no oh no oh no okay okay okay
think think think think
porn move downwards I can take with
um
oh yes look at that look at that come on
back to Even Stevens back to even gosh
Dan Stevens baby this is how it is this
is how
much
Danny we got Danny we gotta go back
Danny Danny there's a cute oh Danny
there's a huge moment developing on the
board Danny let's go oh my goodness
Danny after the OM passant Felix walked
his King up Frank lashed out with G5
which was the critical move and here I
was about to predict that there's a fork
but there is a counter Fork on D3 and
Frank missed it oh
he missed the counterpork Knight to D3
was was that safe they would have that
would have been the end of the game
actually you see it would have landed to
wherever he's going but he would have
not been coming to La Knight D3 was was
game over and Frank misses it and now
it's back to game on
back to game on and back to xqc being
potentially winning because the Rooks
are I mean other than the forks which as
we've seen can happen any moment yep the
Rooks are so much better than the night
here Danny Danny you can't go here so I
can see xqc playing Rook E4 and then F5
Rook E6 Rook E4 is totally playable and
then he will miss Knight to C5
okay the best movies work A4 yeah you
come back with the other rook and you
swing okay C4 also playable
not as good yep but at least it doesn't
walk into the fork how's he gonna deal
with the pass Pawn he just rookie three
now yeah he's gonna stop it for sure he
might go rookie two though a lot of
people don't realize they don't work
yep and it's a result of him just moving
the C Pawn okay goes Rook E1 oh my God
Knight D4 Knight C5 there's a million
different things if he could play a five
maybe by the way like I I don't want to
calculate all of that uh Rook d8 Rook D3
it's back to equal
okay but is Frank gonna see to use the
Rook rather than focus on the pawn
that's the question oh my God put down
but now Rook G1 is oh but then there's
check and then King C3
92 Fork it's over Dude rookie Rook G1
will be played I think I think Rook G1
is going to be played and then the
question is does Frank play Knight D4
check and we get a fork and Danny it
doesn't matter Knight D4 there's King
c392 Rook g194 there's King before
Knight C6
look at that though he played team
before which avoided the check by the
night so he accidentally avoids instant
losing if your ex you see I don't know
if he saw that I think he played tv4 for
only the reason to push the C Pawn yep
he's trying to escort the C Pawn maybe
he also sidestepped the check Frank
doesn't have a lot of things he could
move he gives a check it's a great move
from Frank
you can put the King on a lot of bad
squares now the Knight Forks are
everywhere
yep oh okay that's actually
oh man
that's probably the wrong way to go
yeah but it's all good now Frank will
find a way to guard this Pawn though and
by a miracle he is no longer under any
pressure his King is completely safe he
could push the pawn he could bring the
Rook he just has to figure out the right
plan he has to make sure the pawn stays
protected he can't go for mate because
he doesn't have a mate yep
uh yeah the problem is will he get
obsessed with forks will he get us
obsessed with tricks rather than just
defend the pawn make Black's life easier
this is crazy he has at least a draw
with some sort of looking at our live
board and I'm looking at what Frank is
highlighting on his board and I'm just
freaking out
um he has played Knight C5
and Danny he's in time he's gonna guard
this Pawn
yeah and also the more this game goes on
the more worried you get about xqc's
Wi-Fi because in time pressure that lag
that lag on a plane no right you've
heard of Snakes on a Plane you ever hear
of lag on a plane no it's worse it's
worse it's worse it's worse than Stakes
on a plane
no like oh great move Knight E4 but now
there's rookie seven and then Frank has
to find F5 holding everything together
what's funny is if F5 xuc's best chance
might even be to just sack The Rook for
the night take the oh X you see found
rookie seven yeah this is huge only move
now you have to guard the Knight which
guards the pawn the only way to do that
is to play Pawn to F5 otherwise you'll
lose Rook G3 and then
let's go let's go let's go to Frank
stream let's go to Frank go to Frank
freaking out because you see F5
um
okay
[Music]
um at the moment
um um will he see F5
um
okay
oh my goodness oh my goodness gracious
me
um
oh my goodness gracious me
yeah I'm gonna lose my Pawn ah I'm gonna
lose my Pawn
um he doesn't see it um he doesn't see
it um not even thinking about F5 um I'm
gonna lose it okay I can go there them
and win his Pawn okay boom I go there
and I can he doesn't realize it's check
okay it's not it's not all right here I
can win a win a pun I can when a pawn oh
no it's check oh dear lord okay
[Music]
there for now
Paul okay yeah let's go there Wanna Give
a check that oh now let me just bring
this back yeah the oh the only move in
this position first of all great move by
Frank you gotta stay with the pawn you
can't go on the outskirts of the board
because you'll probably get checkmated
uh the only winning move here is Rook C7
which is not complicated because you
have to guard your pawn and your Rook is
hanging and uh yeah xqc is now winning
Danny but I I don't I don't know if it's
with that Knight on the board every
square is a landmine for the King right
there's Fork exactly there's Forks
everywhere I am I am just in the world
of uh any moment we're gonna see an eval
bar blunder and a heart attack both
moves are bad King C6 hangs the pawn
which he might forget about and King C5
hangs a knight which loses it he hung up
on he hung upon it's over he hung upon
oh my God he had to play King A7 oh my
God Danny Rook f395 Danny Rook f395 he's
gonna try to get the pawn back with Rook
F3 immediately and he's gonna hang the
fork
you are a hundred percent right with
your predictions I'm I'm telling you
you're gonna you're gonna this is it
this is it it's exactly the thing you
would do after you hang the pawn is you
would panic and try to win your Pawn
back and miss the fourth how clutch is
xqc will he find a move like Rook H3 or
bringing the king he probably sees the
fork but that is the way you throw away
your uh POG Champs finale right there
yeah Rook H3 would be a massive move
Rook H3 would be phenomenal yep it's not
over it's it's equal Danny but right
it's
the eval bar has turned to gray
everybody because it's a table based raw
with best play but best play is not what
we're probably gonna get here so don't
don't uh don't be getting any ideas
um with best play this position should
be a draw but actually you see is
moments away from blundering at all wow
he finds King D5 King D5 what a move yep
that's why he's so impressive and and
now xqc could walk his King over here
and if Frank keeps giving him checks
we've seen this this concept of
beginners giving too many goofy checks
although if King E5 rookie eight check
King F6 Knight D5 check you're
highlighting it as I say it so you're
right that too many checks loses for a
while oh he goes back to a draw
yep he has to know that a draw is is a
is a lost match for him yep uh don't
undevelop you almost never want to put a
knight on the back rank like this you've
got to keep active good now great move
by Frank yep xqc certainly well I could
see this happening now because this
didn't work right that's just sort of
how the mind works yeah you might go
here okay Rook H3 oh King C5 yep
interesting move
what a tough position for Black by the
way I know that there's Forks everywhere
for execute for xuc to fall into but
it's a weird position for Frank to have
to figure out coordinating the knight in
time pressure it's impressive
right as long as he gets it back to
defense like I can see King D5 Knight G6
Rook F3 yeah and uh you could even camp
on H A because you just you have a
bunker you just can't let your king
get taken out Danny you're right though
uh time trouble is coming
and time troubles coming which makes it
even more likely that Frank can get the
win here because that lag is gonna I
don't know how fast actually she's
playing he might think he's playing
instantly he might be playing instantly
but there's seconds that are going to
disappear because of the lag you play
King so far I almost had a four card
attack a forking heart attack
uh King D4 and now the Knight is
geometrically trapped this is why you
should almost never put your knight in
the Square at the edge of the board
that's also kind of a thing but King D4
and the Knight actually had no way out
which is a very yeah this is getting his
Knight he's getting his Knight closer
and closer to problems but at some point
Frank's gonna remember he has a rook
Levy exactly and he's gonna give a check
and he's gonna be okay
but now the night is too far now he
might accidentally check the king into
F6 and then he will lose so he's got to
be super careful here
oh God
I'm literally too old for POG Champs I
think this is like my last one I can't
do this anymore is that for your heart
f294 oh my God I never realized how
spoiled I was by being able to predict
the moves of the players
the inability to predict what's going to
happen next just is absolutely
mind-blowing
yeah there's It's So Random I hope he
doesn't move his Pawn that's another F6
loses to Rook G7 and you're just
stranded on the back rank
Roderick says I was too old when I said
jover jover means Jabba the Hutt over
I I don't even know what you're talking
about Joe ver I don't know what Jehovah
means Levy doesn't know what jobber
means either don't don't make fun of me
lud oh my God
yeah he found it Rook H5 okay Frank has
the movies came to the G file rookie
shade it's not made but you lose the
rook and then obviously you're gonna
lose the game oh my God I cast to go
here two minutes for Frank a minute and
a half for for xqc
oh my gosh how is xqc gonna play a
tiebreak game on the plane that it just
doesn't make any sense
oh my God he's wow Frank found King G7
he may not matter he may not make it to
tie breaks rookie 5 Knight G4 Rook G5
that's another way to lose I'm just
trying to find all the ways that you
could possibly lose
yeah rookie five if the Knight moves
somewhere else you can double Rooks on
the seventh rank again it should still
be fine for black but
okay Rook G5 check
now you've got to keep the King next to
the pawn
you cannot go to the H file
okay
okay wow
I'm too old for Paul Champs
dude I
at this point if we've got 16 year olds
playing in the event we're all too old
um I I ran two miles today and this is a
bigger workout for my heart
I'm not gonna lie this is this is
insanity this is insanity I don't know
why I elongated insanity but this is how
you know I'm too old because I my I want
to sit back and cross my legs and relax
because I'm too uncomfortable to be in
the proper gamer position
okay
yeah excuse he's gonna I think he's
gonna lose some time I was just I I
yeah he doesn't have the internet
connection to hold up and and Frank
installed this forever like as long as
Frank just keeps all his pieces close
together he won't lose this is
this is insane this is It's Gonna Take A
blunder by Frank for xcc to win this
game like straight up otherwise we're
headed to a draw or worse for xuc so all
right let's see what Frank is saying
listening maybe to the final moments of
pogchamps five before we go to La okay
I'm gonna go
all right I'll go there next oh I'm
scared 45 seconds left on the clock okay
okay Frank he hold it together 40
seconds
this could be it
oh come on come on 35 seconds 35 seconds
okay now down to 30 seconds all right
you're right you're righty like an
auction there I'm telling you can I get
35 can I get 35 I've got 30 30 seconds
on the clock here will I get 25.
oh we could just I could just win on
time right here
okay now I'm gonna go dude excuse is
losing that time with the plane Wi-Fi
playing with the pawn yeah
um you live by the plane you die by the
plane I could go there and threaten that
Rook you know
he's just gonna run out of time
okay very juicy I don't think he's even
seeing the position in real time this is
what happens I throw my princess it's
over here oh my god with point nine
seconds
now I'm gonna go give a check
okay I'll give a check there for now
there's no way he makes a move in time
the lag itself will get him it's over
Rook takes I'll take back all right
we're looking good in this position all
right we're on time oh yes yes oh yes we
won we won on time very nice very nice
and oh I did not expect to win on time
oh I thought I mean I've gave me one
oh delicious absolutely beautiful
oh okay are we I mean the fight
wow oh my God delicious as Frank said he
takes a 2-0 victory over
xqc the man on a plane goes down uh
let's hope that that's not ominous I
just knocked down wood I don't want to
say anything more inappropriate uh than
that but that was that was a
did I just lose Danny
speechless I don't know what to say
about what we just saw uh I lost you for
a second but you're back oh that was
Sensational I mean this this tournament
has had everything
uh xqc playing this match on a plane you
gotta give credit to Frank though
obviously an unfortunate situation there
for xqc running out of time but Frank
showed up uh to fight and it's going to
be a Welshman and an Englishman in Los
Angeles playing chess I I don't know if
Frank has ever been out of England I
mean this is going to be a huge thing
for Frank Danny now you got to look up
the laws of flying a 16 year old cross
guy across the world I'm sure we have to
accompany him with a parent so that just
doubled our flight costs I
I'm gonna talk to Ludwig and make sure
that we're still splitting this budget
50 50. you know what I'm saying shout
out to lud hanging out in chat because I
think we just added a person
to La I think we're now bringing an
additional accompanying a guardian
um and the guardian will have to
accompany Frank because he's only 16
years of age he is the winner of the
match versus xqc he is headed to Los
Angeles assuming all laws check out Levy
and I are going to be talking to him for
an interview in a moment unfortunately
for Felix POG Champs debut POG Champs
campaign comes to an end we'll be right
back
[Music]
for uh for for 10 seconds yeah yes yes
why to play and draw
oh but this this I'm pretty sure I've
seen
this looks so familiar
so he has to go to either H2 H3
I haven't been able to decide this one
but my 10 seconds pass fast yes yes yes
my feeling would be
definitely not H2 because H2 then maybe
E1 Knight that's really a problem yes so
I have to go to H3 H3 Knight F4 PH2 my
G4 check my G punch back then kh1 Knight
F2 check
very good
I know this one I'm just trying to
remember
so it's when the three nice but it's a
king H3 Knight F4 Knight or uh
King H2 Knight G4 Chuck Knight G4 King
h19 freaking G3 very nice now King E3
yeah very good
um okay let's
start with King H2
kind of have to like this
um would probably go E1 Knight
oh is this king of E1 light then Knight
F3
well yes but King H3 I will go Knight F4
okay now I have to go to H2 Knight G4
okay now I have to go to H1 Knight F2
okay King H2 E1 light
and uh
oh Knight F3 Knight G3 yeah yeah
Knight F3 Knight takes up three King G3
very nice
I knew this one I was just trying to
remember the whole detail look you're
the only one that's uh remaining perfect
after
five studies last one why to move
no I've seen this one okay this one I
think I've seen before Queen G7 look at
seven Knight six yes
but what's the uh what's the puzzle wait
to move
because you you saved the simplest one
for the last one this this is Queen G7
over here yes
yes
[Music]
how did you get in here
so Queen G7 okay seven Knight P6 made
yeah yes that's it we saved the easiest
for last
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
three two one here we go
[Music]
let's go
thank you
[Music]
POG Champs 5 has four people headed to
Los Angeles for the live final and the
last man to join them is that guy right
there Frank defeats xqc by a final score
of two nothing in fashion that was wild
we had people on a plane we had we had
things going crazy Frank
are you are your parents gonna be okay
that you come to LA
um yes yes I think they will be okay
I know okay Frank congratulations man
how excited are you about this match
Victory and uh and and going to the live
final
I am very excited although I know I I
don't know why I said although I'm I'm
very excited yeah
gonna go to the finals and I'm gonna I'm
gonna take my revenge on Sea Dog because
oh yeah that's what I'm looking out to
do that's a beautiful storyline is it
this is the top two finishers of group a
we missed that in all the drama of xuc
playing this match on an airplane
um
yeah he wasn't he wasn't a plane dude
that's why hold on just one time yeah
because of the internet yeah yeah yeah
he actually tried to join our call but
due to legal reasons of the Federal
Aviation as well as the fact that the
zoom call just wouldn't hold up xuc is
not here he's on a plane but uh yeah you
uh you beat xqc mid-flight man
a lot of uh is that fair I mean I mean
I'll take the it's totally fair
hey um you played great Frank you played
phenomenal chess you were down and out
in that first game and then you spotted
the Checkmate on the back rank take us
through that how excited was that
well when I blundered my Bishop I
thought it was all over I was I was
casting in my reins but then
out of the out of the corner of my eye I
see that Bishop
and I I I I pushed that I pushed that
Bishop forward and I and I see it and I
I didn't think it was a Checkmate I
thought xqc could Escape but it was it
was a Checkmate so oh
beautiful absolutely beautiful I I took
me a while to see it though but I did
see it
Frank if you travel to Los Angeles and
you defeat Sea Dog you will have gone
from learning chess in the beginning of
this year to the park Champs five
Champion uh what is going to be the name
of your sports documentary which they
make
um I mean uh I could come up with loads
of cool I've just I just called it Frank
you know like just
Frank
has anyone told you you might be the
most entertaining person on the planet
you uh do you do exercises for how to
speak and breathe at the same time
because you are a mile a minute Riot man
um no I just I talk a lot to myself and
other people all the time I guess it's
just
muscle memory at this point just talking
all the time
yeah yeah it's just muscle memory I
guess I I guess some training oh just
over the years of living if we can that
is training
it is training
um Frank this is awesome man I'm not
gonna lie what what a crazy exciting
match we had
um we uh did you consider yourself an
underdog going in against Felix like
take us through the match sort of
mindset the strategy and and what what
you thought you needed to do to get the
dub which you did
um well I know I knew xqc was strong
because he is obviously uh very strong
but um I was just trying my best put my
best foot forward and
you know be cheeky that was that was the
plan of action right there and I did I
feel as I did well before I was given
although I finished so I could have
definitely done better you know but
obviously
you can always do better so
that's true it's true well Frank you're
still standing it's not over yeah sorry
Levy going no I was gonna say uh I was
gonna say it's uh it's a it's a great
moment and uh my schedule is wide open
for the next eight days if you'd like to
do some intense training and win POG
Champs five so I'm just no disrespect to
see dog but
you know Sea Dog and I are cool but uh
you know Frank we've worked together so
if you got some time in your schedule
you want to train to win this whole
thing uh let's do it
I will take up on that offer I I wanna I
wanna win now I want my revenge
and I want the victory that's what I'm
looking for
Sea Dog's best I'm not gonna let invest
me again
I hope you do take Levy up on that offer
because I because I think I think some I
think Sea Dog is the favorite like just
gonna be honest let's put it all out
there transparent cards on the table
your your your talent though is very
real the fact that you learned just in
January and you played the level of
Chess you did in this event so I think
with some training this this can be a
real brawl in La so you're in good hands
with Gotham and um I'm I cannot wait to
see what happens in Los Angeles man so
are you gonna travel alone to La are you
going to be I mean everything good I
just found out today that you're 16. I
thought you were like in your early 20s
so now I'm in like Dad mode and I'm a
little worried about you
um well I'm actually 17 so you're a year
off then oh okay okay
um I don't know to be honest
um I might might bring my brother along
but
um other than that maybe I don't know
um well it's by myself with my brother
I don't really know yet to be honest
I'll have to have to see things 17 feels
way better than 16. 17 feels well you're
gonna be fine that's so that sounds
great yeah yeah you get more confidence
you know that's what that whole year
just boosts it so
yeah well Frank what else can you tell
us about Chess about your career what
are your plans with chess besides to win
every chess game you play for the rest
of your life
well
um I wanted originally did want to be a
grand master but
um apparently that is really depressing
to get and you have to do like a lot of
chats so I don't know about it anymore
but I I do want to become I want to
become a titled player that's my mission
get the red icon on chess.com that's
what I'm gonna do that's the plan of
action
that's that's a pretty awesome goal
pretty I think it's reasonable Levy
I mean he's 16 17 years of age and and
he's got talent why can't he be a title
player oh absolutely uh absolutely and
the good thing about just setting the
sights on title player is that you can
you can go to school you can get a
full-time job and you can slowly grind
chess on the side and uh
being a grand master you have to uh
study chess like a full-time job
probably get homeschooled shower once a
week wear the same shirt at a tournament
because you're superstitious there's a
lot of bad things about being a grand
master Frank I don't think it's a
Pandora's Box you want to open you want
to be you know
I want to open another Pandora box not
the Grand Master One the titled player
one and I do I preferably want to shower
every day so that is definitely a factor
as to why I'm not going for Grand Master
because me too
Danny also
me too yeah we're all just a bunch of
guys who never made Grand Master here so
that's okay you know um and you might
have a better chance I mean objectively
you might actually have a better chance
of becoming a GM than me or Levy I'm
just saying like given really your your
age your the talent I I think you
probably you know might have the means
to go after it really hard so I'm you
know I'm rooting for you
you really think I I have a better
chance than
you and
um the new Danny and the Gotham chest
what I'm I'm saying that because I don't
think me or Levy will really go for it
at this point in our careers I'm an old
has been you know my days are numbered
Levy's 10 years younger than me but he's
got a budding YouTube career you also
have a Creator career but you're younger
and you never know what what kids are
capable of can I if I can call you that
so yeah that's fine uh
I mean yeah you never know I guess I
never know either
I just have to wait and see it later in
life yeah
well
um
Frank this has been a great interview
I'm uh I'm I'm super excited to meet you
in person in La safe flight safe travels
and congratulations again for moving on
to the winners final against Sea Dog
thank you Daddy see you Frank looking
congrats good goodbye
goodbye Frank
and all right Frank moves on to the
championship bracket but we start by
reminding you that the consolation
bracket will be filled by cutie
Cinderella and virtual those matches
took place earlier the championship
bracket as we know was uh was just
completed we have Sea Dog who's going to
be meeting Frank and uh we'll we'll get
that up for you here in a second we're
we're recapping the day by reminding
everybody it was a wild one Levy your
thoughts before we get to I'm I'm told
some special content that we've just had
hand delivered to us by xqc from a plane
go ahead oh wow
oh wow uh yeah incredible day uh we we
nearly saw The Underdogs be uh beat the
favorites in the consolation bracket we
saw chin-ups
uh we saw in the championship bracket
the favorites winning I mean I don't
know actually we we the Sea Dog won but
Frank vs xqc was was anybody's match and
just so many different story lines
incredible moments
memes dreams schemes
and everything in between I'm just I'm
glad to be a part of it and uh Frank vs
Sea Dog is the rematch of the final of
group a so
Frank gets his revenge potentially Frank
gets the Revenge potentially he said his
plan was to stick in it and you know try
to be cheeky against xqc and cheeky he
was right he had enough tricks and traps
and stuck in it despite xqc playing from
a plane the truth is Frank I think
played the better chess I mean honestly
overall and I know this one came down to
a win on the clock in the final game but
but Frank played fantastic so but all
right we didn't get to talk to xuc there
was a Mad Dash behind the scenes for
those who love knowing about that and uh
Felix was literally trying to join us
from a plane didn't work out we won't
talk about that but we are going to play
the interview that he sent us he
recorded a video and uploaded it for us
and here's what Felix had to say uh
because he couldn't join us in the
interview
[Music]
okay so the event
um there's an invitation there was one
uh chess.com and also um
weapons completely degenerate and
flagging as I'm lagging absolute
Shameless Behavior
[Laughter]
but look at that even with the trash
talking on the plane he says he's gonna
donate his winnings to charity and 10x
the value I mean I know we can afford it
I'm not sure if he knows that we're now
showing that private DM on Discord on
screen this is happening in real time so
uh there you go xqc we're donating your
money to charity and we're gonna hit you
up for 10x value I think if I can just
sign off on a philosophical note
um what I've learned in my mid-20s is
that very few things in life are
completely black and white as we finish
off a chess event and uh
the level at which xqc has risen to he
does things that rub people the wrong
way he does things that get people mad
he does things that are probably
objectively uh you know to be to be
rightfully criticized for but at the
same time he is also a like absolutely
Transcendent Entertainer and uh there is
good in that man's heart and he's
probably going to donate something like
a hundred thousand dollars to charity
and you take the good you take the bad
and we're all flawed individuals in one
way or another just some of us broadcast
it every day to a hundred thousand live
viewers and our entire lives are on
social media Danny so none of us are
perfect and that's sort of my mindset
with xuc so I think I I mean honestly I
could have said it better myself and I I
agree I think I made a comment on the
first show I hosted for this this year's
podcast five with Andrea that he's the
closest thing we have to The Truman Show
being a real thing and part of the
reason he's so fascinating and I think
people love him is because he's flawed
if you want to use that he's a real
human he's vulnerable and he and he and
he does things that at times make you go
like
did he just do that but in the end he's
also I think I think a pretty good
person and we see he's going to donate
um some money to charity and he'll be
missed in La we're going to be dealing
with uh Frank and Sea Dog and then cutie
and uh virtual on the other side of it
so um
so there you go we're gonna be in La
remind everybody as we uh we want to
take one last look at that beautiful
Skyline that we're headed to in Los
Angeles the City of Angels everyone else
gets a flight besides cutie she gets an
Uber Uber black we'll get her a nice one
it'll be a five-star driver I promise
we're gonna see everybody in LA and uh
on that note let's also remind the
community who's tuning in that they also
have another Community event they can
play and I talked about the Untitled
Tuesday Levy real quick shout out to the
other community event which is the
community bullet brawl happen on
Saturdays we have the title player
bullet brawl Donya noradiski won it last
Saturday everybody in the community can
play in the Untitled bullet brawl that
doesn't quite roll off the tongue in the
same way but sign up you can play become
the next bullet brawl Champion all you
got to do is join the chess.com
Community Club to participate go for it
use the command CBB to join and there's
also all kinds of prizes as you can see
Diamond memberships and chessable
courses so Levy I literally don't even
know how to unpack what happened today
um
me neither
but uh I did my best at the end I did my
best at the end and uh I'm realizing
that in in all of my career of talking a
lot to a camera and then posting it on
the internet and talking about Chess
that uh I am still I think more of a
human being than I am a YouTuber or a
streamer or anything else and I just
don't try to judge people too harshly or
too intensely or take one extreme of a
situation so uh this was a blast that
was specific to obviously uh xqc but um
I had a great time the last couple of
days it's been cool slimming down the
field now we have four people and we're
gonna have a live final and that's gonna
be great and Ludwig's team did buy me a
plane ticket in the end I was scared
that they wouldn't and I'm looking
forward to it very much so it's gonna be
my fourth or fifth time in Los Angeles
in about six months and the flight is
brutal and the commute is brutal and LAX
is probably only slightly better than
going to jail but I will be there and I
will be very excited
I will be there as well coming in
getting out fast
um no but it's gonna be a fun ride we
hope that uh it's a it's a fun finals
that everyone Tunes in for
um and we will see you we will see you
there until then thanks to the whole
crew because this is our last remote pod
Champs the last one the next one we'll
be doing will be in Los Angeles so
thanks to the crew production our mods
the whole team that makes these things
happen uh my uh my partner here Levy
Rosman and uh for everyone at chess.com
and all the participants that
unfortunately will not be joining us in
La this has been POG Champs five we will
see you for the final next week and good
night everybody
wow I'll resign
it's playing too fast it's over 11
wonders bro what oh he lost look at this
win on the spot
let's go oh my gosh
this is insane oh my God we're going to
La oh my God
holy moly I need a coffee and I did a
thing I lost track of the night begin
and now we see him dropping f-bomb's
crotch what a game dude
oh my God
oh
absolutely beautiful
thank you
[Music]
foreign